Five four,
three,
two.
Oh Shit.
We're back my all time favorite kind of podcasts by companions.
Eddie,
come on through fucking Bravo's house.
Thank you for having me.
Brendan.
Mother fucking kid.
Kido Quito tee shirt on.
I told the dude to make a kid Quito tee shirt.
He fuck it.
Jumps on.
That Shit is an entrepreneur.
The kido kids stuff.
What does that Ketogenic ketosis a bad for a while.
I'm a forest.
No,
no,
no.
He got me on.
I'm obsessed with it.
Last night I was in a Phoenix walking by restaurant.
This girl,
maybe 18 goes Shahab I'm I keyed.
Okay.
Head
a bunch of older dudes to like,
who the fuck is she talking about?
Larry is,
that's so fun and just shot the documentary sugarcoated.
Oh my God.
Have you seen it?
It's terrifying.
Holy Shit.
Mother on that sugar movie seen that sugar movie.
Jesus.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Sugar is terrible.
I'm just a conspiracy theory here.
I had no idea it was right in front of my fucking face.
It's not everyone's on everyone's table.
What it is,
man.
It's a drug and people are addicted to it and it's in everything.
No,
but what I'm talking about is there was a conspiracy to pay off Harvard
scientists and professors here we go to keep sugar according to that movie.
I'm gonna stop movies.
Bullshit.
No,
I'm sure it works.
Then when we talking about the sugar association,
they didn't want it to be labeled as for what it really was,
uh,
an addictive toxin.
They want her to keep it.
It ain't that bad in moderation and ain't that bad.
It makes things taste sweet.
It's about love.
So they,
they paid according to this documentary,
they paid out Harvey now cause everyone's like,
I'm science,
I'm a science.
This,
I'm science that says it's beautiful when people do that because then all you do
is buy up all the scientists and you got everybody.
I love some sugar though,
man.
Everybody loves sugar.
That's the thing about it.
It tastes awesome.
I mean it doesn't,
it's not a drug that works because the effects aren't pleasurable like sugar.
It's very pleasurable.
It also has its benefits too.
Postworkout stuff like that.
Certain athletes need that stuff,
so it's different than a lot of
sense that there's arguments against that.
Let's say there's more for it.
I don't know that's a sugar coated because I know about the conspiracy.
Brendan is about that.
Exactly.
I always thought when people ask me about sugar gets bad for you,
but as long as you don't get too crazy with it and you don't,
you don't have nothing to worry about.
You're not fat.
Only fat people have something to worry about as long as,
but according to this documentary,
people that are in shape are getting adult onset diabetes because they think
that apparently according to this doc one coke a day increases your chances for
diabetes by 30% if she,
if that Shit's true.
It's a lot of coke and one coke a day is some insane amount of 50 grams of sugar
sugar,
40 40 it's only supposed to have 25 in a day.
It's ensuring,
yeah,
that's including fruit.
Lactose.
You're only,
you're only supposed to get sugar and no more than 25 grams and actually nobody
deals with fuck that noise.
As a kid I was balls deep.
200 grams a day.
Watch.
That's what it's about.
We bring it back to the postworkout shit cause mark Sisson was talking about
actual gains that your body has more gains if you wait up to an hour after a
working out before you supplement,
before you take anything for you taking any food.
And I started doing it and he said that there's a like a reaction that your body
has where it produces more um,
hormones because your body is just had like this brutal workout and your body
hasn't had a replenishment.
So because it has an end,
a replenishment,
I guess during that time period,
if you replenish,
I think the sign,
the sciences or the your according to him,
I mean,
I don't know what studies smartest done.
It does a very smart dude.
I'll take his word.
Yeah.
That it's better to do it that way.
You get more results hormonally than you do if you immediately glycogen load
because otherwise your body stops doing what was going to do.
Right.
Because let's slow it slows it.
But you know,
it's so hard to,
oh,
how the fuck do you know exactly how someone got their gains?
You know,
you're talking about athletes,
right?
So you're talking about people all work out hard.
There's some of genetic freaks and you know,
most people are on slightly varied diets and slightly varied sleep schedules.
So it's super hard to say like,
if a guy didn't do it that way,
how much of a game he would calculate?
I had some silly bitch telling me forever to drink chocolate milk mail that was
supposed to be the craze for get them off the time that was supposed to be the
craze.
It's,
it's a good excuse to eat chocolate milk.
Hell yeah.
It was so Nestle Quik,
so with a fight that's about to start.
Bruce Bruce,
buffer looking slick as always is Josh Berkman verses Paul Felder.
This is a fucking amazing fight.
Great.
First of all,
Josh Berkman has fought as high as two oh five.
Josh Berkman fought Jeremy Horn one day and uh,
Jeremy Horn choked him out and spit on him and his aggressive.
Oh my God.
They must have said some really dark shit to each other before that fight.
That's aggressive.
But Josh Barkman is a bad motherfucker dude.
And at one 55 he's so God damn strong.
If he can do it and do it successfully,
he's a bully at this weight.
He's just a tough,
tough motherfucker and he's slick.
But this Paul Felder kid can crack a lot of tools.
I feel like it has more tools I think standing he does,
but Berkman is down dude,
that guy with his board game.
But I feel like the game,
it's evolving fast and filters more evolved them accent and younger and less
miles.
What I like about this less miles for sure,
but what I like about this fight is,
this is essentially an old real fucking crafty veteran in Berkman who is a dog.
I mean he's a fucking bull dog.
Game is they comp and you have less other yeah,
fuck him.
And he shut.
Heck Act along bowed down to one point.
One word was on Tuesday and Lavard was juiced up and you know,
Lombard
kept swinging at him and Berkman kept moon.
But Berkman was cracking him a little.
Yeah.
And it got lumbar to a point where Lombard slowed down his,
uh,
his attack because he kind of knew that he wasn't gonna Take Burke Mountain.
He was going to have to do the long haul.
Like our Feldman TKL.
Do we have to say man?
Oh yeah,
it's four 50 right now for 48,
four 47 first round.
Paul Felder,
Josh Bergman,
a fight that I've been really looking to for this.
I feel like this whole card is totally under the radar.
I mean Hanan Barao was fighting Jeremy Stevens,
the fucking,
the Khomeini.
It's incest,
the combing.
I think it's more,
you know,
there's no,
like for the average fan,
there's no huge draws.
But as far as Joe Silva and those,
and Joe Silva,
who's the other dude who does the matchups,
Sean,
Sean Shelby,
Bro,
they got their money's worth.
You know what I'm saying?
Like they paid them exactly what they should do because these matchups,
these aren't matchups that you can go like five or six,
right?
Two verse three there are amazing to me it's the best card of the year.
I'm pretty sure Sean handles the match ups for the lighter weight fighters.
Correct.
And then,
I dunno what,
what?
Wait a silver takes over,
but we,
both of them are doing a fucking awesome job.
And this,
this card,
this card show,
you look at it,
you're like Jesus Christ.
They just want the matchups.
I wouldn't think about it.
They just went shinny Shin.
Let's pay attention to the year though.
No,
no,
no.
Really good cars.
As far as match up match up wise,
it's an amazing card.
It's a really good card.
It's way,
way better than people are giving it credit for.
I mean this is a,
this is the first UFC I ever saw.
I'd be like,
Holy Shit,
what a nutty sport.
I'll call this UFC just fucking watch.
Just like straight up.
Just watch it man.
I know you don't know the guys,
but this is going to be a great night of fights and if you're betting it's can
be tough to pick man for experts.
Try picking this card.
I'd like to see someone just go,
whatever,
uh,
eight for eight.
It's going to be a beast.
Yeah.
You know what man?
This is a sneaky fight.
Oh good.
Nice front kick to the body by Felder and Josh returns it
perfect.
Felt has got a lot of tools when it comes to standup.
He's a real sneaky,
he does a lot of weird shit like cowboy man training at the ranch.
Real similar in some ways,
but also because he's got a taekwondo background.
He throws more spinning shit than cowboy does.
Cowboys like straight Moy Tai who these guys are straight forward a couple of
times.
Man had a lot of checking.
Good,
good defensive skills here.
Yeah.
Felder's off fucking attack or two man,
he's tough as shit.
Berkman went to a belt or before that Raymond had kids.
He got caught,
went to world series of fighting.
Any choked out.
John Fitch.
Remember that fight?
Yes.
Do.
That was a huge fight.
Yeah.
He choked out Fitch and real quick fit.
Shot in for a single.
Was that the fight one?
Fitch tested positive?
No,
that was the Paul Horace fight.
Boom.
Paul has got that knee.
He got him to pour as his fucking leg locks.
I mean maybe Fitch was like fucking,
I know this guy's on it.
Yeah.
Understandable.
Who knows?
Did you see bars get wrecked?
Yeah,
I daddy got Merk got wrecked.
Wrecked by some viking dude.
Fuck the one named Mick like 50 seconds.
I don't even know the name of the show dude.
It was the show where mayhem.
Uh,
weight in 20 somethings rounds.
Burke too.
He got submitted.
Yeah,
I would think that's a fatigue thing.
I think it's more he just don't want to be there.
It's like self sabotage.
Need the money.
Ma'Ams ground game was so legit.
Super legit.
It'd be real hard to tap that guy for doing black belt.
Yeah.
Well rolled with him a bunch.
He's a monster.
Yeah.
Jason's no joke.
I remember,
uh,
when,
Jason fought Jake shields and had his back and had a fully locked in Vernon
naked choke in the fucking bell rang.
I mean he had a,
I believe he had gable grip,
but he had it under the Chin and everything.
It was a tight,
tight squeeze.
Oh Shit.
They're going home.
Wore Nike.
What's some good movement?
You see?
But this is what Berkman wants.
Fell down.
He's a not do this.
He's more technical.
Boom.
We get some guys back.
Oh it fell.
Just take them.
Failed is in a bad place here because on the ground Berchmans a beast.
Super fucking strong again.
You gotta think about Berkman has fought successfully at one 70 and all the way
up to like two oh five we get that old man strength through.
He just tossed as youngness.
He's just a guy who's been around a long fucking time.
He's a smart dude too.
Yeah.
And that,
that Hector Lombard fight shows how smart he is.
He was never really in the pocket.
He just avoid all his is.
He doesn't lose his shit.
No.
Like,
like the fire will be hot as fuck and he sits in there and doesn't lose control
man.
Exactly.
He can do what he can do and he's not going to fall short.
Psychologic stays in his lane to,
he doesn't try anything too crazy.
You know,
I can see you have fricking stupid Chris Weidman bullshit spinning kick or
something like that.
Yeah,
we never saw that from Weidman here.
He did.
Well let's not see it ever again as crazy.
Crazy.
It costs you the fight son.
Yeah.
The Art of getting back up is,
I mean it's so deep.
It's the fence crawl.
Some is really good at it.
Some guys are okay and who's the best I've ever seen who?
Keith treading.
Really?
Oh my God.
He's tried to do things.
God Damn Animal Dude.
He would always go,
go,
go straight to the cage and walk,
go walk.
He was just such a beast.
Straight to the Cajun way.
Wherever you work,
you got to get to the case.
That was his thing and that's what I started doing.
That people like no,
what are you doing?
Like I doesn't a pound your face and,
but that was Keith thing really.
So he was one of the first guys to figure out to use the case to get up.
He,
that was his thing.
As soon as you get taken down.
If the guy had your hips,
you are scooting to get to the cage to use it to crawl up,
and then he was so fucking good at it,
man.
None of us get holding down.
Hmm.
Interesting.
Yeah.
Keith Jardeen is a guy who doesn't get the credit he deserves and a lot of ways
that's fight with chuck.
I'm going to fight with trial.
What a fight.
Lift that leg up,
man.
Yeah.
Keith was real smart with the application of leg kicks and he hit him with that
big right hand.
So awkward man.
This,
this whole like I rang a Tang jump,
jiggy hands,
so offered.
He wrote Turang and tank style.
Ooh.
Berkman cracked him.
Here we go.
This oh sidekick.
Boom.
Straight left lunging sidekick.
Yeah,
he's doing that.
A lot of guys are doing that till legs now.
Dangerous.
Jon Jones loves doing that.
You mean for someone's knee?
Look,
you see Berchmans willing these exchanges.
What would you,
I'd rather have someone do that to my knee.
Then someone Shin kicked me in the head.
Definitely dangerous.
It's more dangerous than that.
It's totally agree.
100% totally good point.
There's good.
Yeah,
but the idea is that we're used to being able to tap from knee injuries.
So,
uh,
you know,
because of like a knee bar.
So when people look at a strike to a naval go all that's not fair because he
can't tap.
But Eddie,
you made the perfect point.
It's the perfect point.
That's a fight.
Yeah.
Because if you kick somebody in the head,
it's fucking way worse.
You can't tap to that.
Let's,
let's just pull up,
but let's just go over the,
so if you knocked me out by head kick on what spending six months you kicked me
in that front knee,
you blow blow my ACL.
NCL.
I can't work for a year.
At least I,
we'll come back.
Let's be totally honest.
If you get,
never heard of that ever happening.
I've never heard of it.
It's like,
just start with just the new thing.
Give a title in the UFC it's always,
no,
it's been legal.
But Jon Jones is really the first guy to start doing it.
Act upon felt to just cracked him.
Guys getting kicked like that.
Like does one five eggs break.
There's one finance Miguel Torres,
Miguel Torres gets um,
he get an oblique kicked on the knee and is this was in a legacy kickboxing
fight?
I think it was.
It was pretty recent,
like within two years.
And Miguel Torres,
his knee just went fucking sideways.
It was nasty and he screamed and fell down and got back up and kept fighting.
I don't know how the fuck he did it.
That's one guy that I thought it was the Sharon Woods would still be at the top.
Miguel.
Well this is what,
this is what I was going to say.
Knockouts,
man,
you're not,
it's not just as simple as you get your ligament repair and you do your rehab
and your back.
Nine months later you might not ever be the same guy again.
Talking about the dot count.
Yeah,
like a real knockout,
like a real knockout.
But that's what you sign up for.
You expect concussions now.
I don't expect get my need blown out in a fight.
But it's a part of your body.
Like if someone can attack your head walk,
shouldn't he be able to attack your knee?
Will same.
Seems crazy.
Fell let's same reason the NFL.
Like you can't attack the idea that sells a sport.
Yeah,
let's use,
this is a sport,
but this is the sport of fighting what?
With rules?
Yeah,
but the rules are stricter.
Rules are already really brutal.
Like the idea of taking out a rule of kicking the knee when you can kick a guy
in the fucking jaw face.
But I can't kick him in the face if he has three points on the ground.
So there are rules.
So you can't say it in that sport.
Well honestly I don't agree with that either.
I don't agree with that either.
I think this,
you see where that UFC line is?
See where the outside logo is and this is the line,
the inner rock to guys.
What I say is everything outside that octagon,
you can't kick him in the face because it's too close to the cage.
The only problem with kicking someone in the face when they're down is that the
cage could prevent you from moving and you'd get kicked with something that you
couldn't normally have prevented.
So there's a an obstacle and that obstacle is sort of artificial.
And since we can't just an enormous basketball size playing field,
which is really ideal,
the ideal way to do MMA is not to have any walls.
There's something stupid about having walls.
Well,
we really should have is a large like football size arena.
Put a guy and I said,
why not?
You have it for football,
but a guy,
he put it,
God guys,
look and feel it.
That's the only way you're not having this bullshit.
See,
there's nothing wrong with learning how to clinch and fight up against the cage.
It's super important because you use a cage.
But in reality a real fight should not have anything to do with the wall.
You press the guy up against in a sport,
you have to have a structure,
bro.
No,
you,
you stay in bounds.
This is your boundaries.
You have a big ass,
terrible experience at Disney babies.
But you wouldn't have this shit.
You wouldn't have this pressing against the wall.
It is an art form,
but it's an art form that's artificially created by an obstacle.
This obstacle should not be there.
You shouldn't be.
Shouldn't be able to press people against it.
But no,
that's,
it shouldn't be.
But that shouldn't be a part of fighting.
So there's,
there's water everywhere to you.
Free treason.
He can't do it.
I'll put it in football.
That's like saying well there should be no out of bounds.
You guys just run.
Football has bounds.
They have plenty of room cause you never larger.
They have a large arena but oh fell to just cracked him on the left hand.
This man,
I said second round,
just hill.
I think offenses are artificial and I think they should fight in large
unenclosed areas and if you hate viewership,
money,
purity.
I want no gloves,
no more gloves,
no more hand wraps,
no risks,
shapes Dr own shit.
No more.
No,
this is nonsense.
He's gloves are stupid.
These gloves,
these gloves only exists for people to watch at home day,
brother.
Only for people watching at home.
If you're a real martial artist,
you would not want gloves because gloves,
gloves give you this artificial idea that you can hit someone as hard as you
want with your hands,
without them exploding on you,
but you got everything taped up wrapped up.
Unless you're going to Nelson,
that gangster ass motherfucker doesn't even wear wraps.
He's just good.
I'm just going to
punch you and choke you.
He's like,
I'd like to fit in my hands.
I could fit it better.
You're not getting on Fox with no,
no gloves.
Fuck you know this case fell.
Felton was getting hit by Barbosa with those kicks.
Felder,
Feldman,
the no fucks,
no blocks.
The
he said he just walked in with a bottle of wine and two fucking goat cheese,
milk,
cheese.
Everyone.
Good enzyme.
Get it at whole foods.
Fuck yes.
I got it from whole foods.
You son of a gun and a lot of money too.
They were like ha that much.
I was like,
that's right.
I have a successful podcast and I'm friends with Eddie Bravo.
They said you have that last powerful cheese anyway,
no gloves.
You're crazy.
Don't wear Shin Pads.
How come you,
how come you don't wear Shin pads means you have to wear gloves.
That's stupid.
And why it impedes grappling.
Keeps you from getting chokes.
Do you want no gloves boxing to know if they want to do that?
That's their nonsense.
So if it's combat,
combat,
silly,
there's no kicks
man.
Crazy.
I guarantee you,
I don't know what you smoked before this,
but you're crazy.
It's not a good way to do it.
I mean box,
they're doing wonderful sport.
It's wonderful sport to watch it.
But as far as like fighting,
it's not a good way to do it.
Like this is the only way to do it.
This is fighting.
Okay?
So if we represent real fighting,
and this is what this represents,
this represents what happened when guys are led to do everything,
when they'll have to do knees,
like that step,
and he fell to just slander.
Take kick to the body.
Fellow just landed.
Oh see this is,
this is a real fight.
This is what you do when you can do everything.
You do everything.
So I love boxing,
but it's rough.
It's only a sport.
This is fighting.
So if we've got,
if this is real fighting,
why,
why are we wearing gloves?
Why?
Why do we have wrist tapes and all that nonsense on?
I got a question for you.
If somebody doesn't get cut.
No,
it's so you don't break your hands as easy,
but you,
you shouldn't be doing things that break your hands.
Why don't we put knows protectors on it cause you want to head butt each other
with our faces,
you know,
oh my nose is getting broken too much every time I headbutts well don't head,
but then you'd have to figure out what it actually does work.
Even artificial surface over your hands that protects your hands.
As far as I'm curious.
As far as the Pearson a pure fight,
you're probably right as far as a sport and growing it and getting kids to get
involved in,
you have to have some sort of structure.
I think one day they're going to figure it out.
They're going to have no gloves.
We're going to look at this and then go to say,
this is silly and guys got hit with a lot more shots.
You're,
we're going to see more,
more shit.
You're gonna see probably bigger gloves you see from the head gear or some shit.
All that would be worse there.
The science says just like football,
but just like football,
but bigger gloves is actually no better,
worse.
Correct.
That's why.
And so to the science doesn't support it.
And even headgear,
they're thinking now,
oh,
we just tagged them with a right hand.
Hey,
gear does nothing.
Headgear actually can can give you a larger fulcrum point apparently,
and he can spin your head around more.
You know what I like about the gloves is that they can fucking punk.
Full blast.
That's true.
And you don't cut your headline,
but how come he can't take from here?
Shannon's like you could just hit them harder.
Why can't you tape up your insteps and you shins like they doing Muay Thai
fights?
They should,
but then it's up.
Well,
granted you can say the gloves or hindrance grappling,
but if you have shin pads on you're going to move as well.
Dude,
you ever see like some of those really good guys who do their Shin and ankle
ankles?
Like I was in Maurice's corner once,
Maury Smith when he had a kickboxing fight and uh,
you know,
he's taping his ankles up and shit.
You know when those guys do that mean they make that thing like almost like a
cast,
you know,
it's all protected in their,
they layered in there.
Some dude's more than others.
I mean some guys don't wear shit.
You see a lot,
even the top guys in glory and lion fight and those kinds of things,
they don't wear shit.
I'm psyched that bell towards going to have that kickboxing organization.
Beltour kickboxing.
Yeah.
That's awesome man.
Dude Felder would that beautiful combination still get that,
that he's taking with the hands and that the smoother with that,
that switch kick on the front leg.
Then the back leg kick his [inaudible] so pretty man,
he's fun to watch.
Yeah,
it really is.
And fucked and decisions a bunch.
You know what,
man,
he's just fought real tough guys and had real tough fights,
hard being the crazy clothes.
But when people get upset,
hey man,
that's just reality.
That's where you stand and you got to get better.
Like he looks right here.
It looks better right here.
Right?
And why don't you say [inaudible] go for a finish.
No Man.
He just needs to keep training and fighting and being Paul Felder,
he's going to get better.
Oh,
look at that knee,
dude.
He's already getting better.
Like,
look at this fight.
He's performing spectacularly in this fight.
He's smooth.
His timing looks excellent and he's fighting a fucking animal.
It's for an older guy too though.
Fighting an animal though.
He's very good.
Bob Dale.
He's not.
It's not,
I guess it performances and slacked.
He might be older,
but he doesn't look bad.
Berkman hasn't looked tired or weak in a fight.
Gentleman,
this is a 2010 boy Yak and joy.
This what's a boy?
Jaak Brian [inaudible].
It's a French.
It's a French Gooch who just took his ass down.
Oh,
you're this gentleman.
Cheers my boys.
Cheers.
Thanks buddy.
We're back.
Put your headphones on right now.
It's a rule.
Ladies and gentleman.
We made rules for you guys.
One of them is we try not to chew into the microphone cause I don't know that
it's so annoying.
Especially if you're at the gym and you have headphones on.
You're mcing.
Yeah.
If you have headphones on,
it's even more rude because it's like in someone's ear.
That's a nice wine.
So Bergman's cut.
Um,
he just landed to take down.
We were talking and I didn't get a chance to see what the fuck happened.
But he's got a pretty nasty cut.
There's a lot of blood I can't see.
I think it's as nose man.
It might be as nose.
Oh,
nice knee to the body filter beneath the,
yeah,
it looks like the forehead.
Maybe more than one cut.
It looks like there's something coming out of the nose.
The bridge of his nose and his forehead.
Does this kind of blood make the sport more popular or less popular?
That doesn't have an effect on it.
Just like,
I don't think that sponsors had an effect on it either.
I don't think anybody looked at it and goes,
this shit is how come they don't all have the same clothes on.
Nobody looked at it and said it needed a uniform like that.
That's more of the UFC brass doing it for a corporate to try and be like
everyone else,
but it didn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
I like bud and manner well in pro wrestling and just tuck down.
Fell,
got paid on blood,
fell on his back and the other round.
Wow.
Fucks twice.
But it helps him up.
He is a fucking stud.
Yeah,
he is man crush.
Yeah.
You,
you do.
How does a beast man fucking animal?
Uh,
I think he's probably 36 37 amazing.
Let's find out.
Oh,
that's what it is as elbow.
Elbow bridge of the nose.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
It's beautiful.
Hey Vegas,
let's get more fucking came on the job.
That's know what that's going to win him.
The fight too because they're replaying it.
Felder so durable.
When Barboza was kicking him in the side and you could hear it,
it's like having a gun shot and he just didn't,
he never stopped.
He just wondered how somebody can take that kind of a beating in the Bible.
Let me tell you something.
He hit Barboza.
What's some good shots too?
It felt,
but Barboza is just so God damn fast,
too quick fluff,
and that was just one of his first jaunt into the higher echelons of MMA.
And what's going to happen is Felder,
as you see in this fight,
I think you looked as good in this fight is he's ever looked and he's going to
continue to get better.
He doesn't even those other fights he did,
but I think he looks even better now.
I mean,
he's,
he's a young kid,
he's improving and he's smart and he works hard and he's got Donald with them.
I mean,
having Serone as a training partner,
you so goddamn gigantic when you got a guy who was,
first of all,
is an animal,
a fucking fight.
Anybody,
he'll fight if they call them up to fights,
deep paid me.
Oh check as well.
What I gotta do,
he'll fucking hot right a bull over to steepen the whole camp over there.
He'll ride a bull
wild man.
He's a total legit while my men super successful as an MMA fighter.
So for a guy like Felder to have a guy like Donald and have them be a colleague
and the two guys be able to train with each other like that and work with each
other.
God,
it's giant.
You know,
it's like those camps that have uh,
other great guys like look at core me,
Aa and nothing.
And then [inaudible] and then Habib,
Nigga met off and you look at these now,
your boy animals,
the kid,
the k one champions there now trying for MMA.
What's his name?
Oh Rico Verhoeven.
Oh my God.
He's the best out of all of them.
Good luck with that.
Is your a miracle one with ground and pound his first MMA fight.
But he is a fucking athlete.
You might be the best bodyweight striking athlete in,
in combat sports.
He's a real big,
he's just like two 40 solid viking genetics.
How many Japan in this Cup there before we do
let's go and piss them.
Stop sign you up for the UFC.
Mel Hollin guys don't get cal Bro.
Those Holland guys don't mind taking steroids.
Is Yoda marrow?
No,
it's not a lot of raw milk.
Raw Milk and horsemeat right.
Yeah.
It's not a single person is more of a fan of a,
of Dutch boy tie fighters in May.
Like Ramon Dekkers oh come on man.
Rob came in the best.
Who's so that greatest combat sports athletes of all time with Dutch kickboxers
there's so many animals.
I guess Melvin men who've got robbed for in Bellator.
I didn't watch the fight,
but dude,
people were calling me up saying,
do you see that shit were furious.
I can't.
Apparently even Scott Coker was pissed and manhood.
He's another one man.
Jesus Christ.
See terrifying,
scary
his and he's a regular training partner.
Badr Hari's another fucking psychopath.
Literally Psycho.
Literally cycle and fuck with that.
God Damn,
he's good.
He knocked out Dan over it.
Yeah,
like that horrible.
Fred's matches the past.
Those were the days.
The best rematch with him with Baader is uh,
Stefan Leco cause he fucks deaf on Lek on Stefan that go,
knocked him out with a spinning back kick to the body.
So he came back and knocked,
let go out in the next part of the spinning back kick to the head.
He got him with the same kick and he was like almost like a turning sidekick.
He was real skinny Badr Hari back then.
He wasn't Jack Butter horror as he got older and got involved in gangs.
I mean now that I'm a little more educated on the steroid use and legendary is
when I go back and watch a lot of these guys fight in MMA.
I go,
Oh,
you're,
you're an absolute giant and there's zero reason you should be that bulky and no
and no body fat and somehow or another can go on forever.
How interesting.
Maury Smith,
Fuck Kevin Randleman.
Uh,
rest in peace.
Who was a great guy?
Kevin Randleman.
Really truly,
it was a great guy and he was one of those guys that was probably like one of
the freakiest freak athletes that's ever fought in combat sport.
The best athlete to ever compete in the UFC.
He looked,
he looked like a better looking Mike Tyson,
like a prettier Mike Tyson when he was in his prime
plucked eyebrows.
I promise you
it's not and dyed hair and beautiful died.
It's a beautiful and guy with blonde hair.
Dude.
He's a beautiful man.
Stolid
um,
where was I going with that?
That oh,
he's fine.
He thought Marie Smith and a,
after the fight more,
he said,
okay,
freak of science are freaking nature.
What is it that was what more,
he's calling me out.
That's great.
What do you think?
And I said,
man,
there's really no way to tell.
There's Maurice and a roundabout.
It's tough to tell.
He said they got got,
never got tired.
He said he never got tired.
That's a different,
well,
no,
cause he was in,
in college at Ohio state.
He was a freak to it.
There's,
there's legendary stories,
so it's easy,
you know,
you could say how's he tried them in his life?
Maybe,
but that's not why he's such a freak.
I don't like when people discredit guys like that.
He's a fucking man.
When you look at how muscular he is now that you know a little bit.
He definitely had to know.
You got to see me call caught like high.
There's pictures.
I mean the High School Jack,
like he's just,
he's a free Brock Lesnar was that way.
He was in high school.
He looked like a like a freak.
There's this definitely freaks.
Yeah.
I'm not saying that there's not a chance they dabble.
Neil bags again,
supplements let's,
this thing is a guy like random and you have to have two things to look like
that you couldn't take a guy like a account.
I was going to say,
I was going to say somewhere else.
How do you even,
not that I'm not even talking about like just shit like just shoot it.
Let's be honest.
We take you.
Yeah.
Okay.
You would,
there's no way you're going to look like that.
It's just no supplements on,
there's no,
he's out of the frame and this frame is insane.
Look at the Moscow there is in high school.
He's just stuck to college.
Is that college,
but look at him.
This is ridiculous.
He Moscow stud wrestler.
I mean just in a really powerful athlete and there's guys that are just,
they're just more mesomorphic another balance.
The steroids.
I don't think it was not,
you know,
he was not fuck you.
He was when he was like 14 when he was 16 years old.
Gentlemen,
hold on.
When he was 16 years old and looking the same and knocking dudes into a coma,
like a grown man,
Mike Tyson was a freak of nature.
I'm with you.
I'm not discounting that her is like band or Holyfield.
It's like,
all right,
what are we doing here fellas?
Like Evander Holyfield could we got first and Mister Olympia?
Oh,
of course.
And Tyson was obviously on some shit too.
Well why do you think he was on some shit?
He's willing to do everything else.
He had no problem with any other drug.
You know what I mean?
Pictures and not take steroids too far.
Crack.
Oh No,
no,
no.
I wouldn't think about for health.
I would think about it.
As a matter of fact,
there's apparently very little evidence that with all of the steroid use that
people do all the crazy bodybuilders like not that many are dying.
That's true.
There's
fester or watch.
Wwe is dealing with painkillers,
you know that and I know that pain killers and steroids,
steroid use shore but it's the painkillers that are killing everybody.
My boy Chris,
Ben was like,
Huh?
He was on some shit.
That guy also had some serious CTE.
Probably good Jay and all those dudes are still blaming each other and hitting
each other with chairs and shit.
What about all the time bodybuilders like if they're still alive,
they are,
aren't they?
Most of them are still alive and there's some of them were really abusive.
Like definitely there are endocrine system is shutdown.
Definitely they have to take hormone replacement therapy but that's available.
You can do that.
What you look at them though and you're,
you're not looking at like a old boxers or old like you go to like Muhammad
Ali's era,
which is the same I guess maybe,
you know,
he predated Swartz and by a little bit like 10 years or so,
maybe more,
more,
more when he,
when sourcing our first burst onto the scene.
So if you,
if you look at Sally and you look at,
um,
obviously he's in a bad,
bad place,
right?
But you look at Joe Frazier before he died and you look at a lot of those older
boxes from that era,
they're fucked.
They're fucked.
But the older bodybuilders,
there's a lot of them that are still a restaurant.
Arnold doing physics,
he's fine.
He's a chill in the,
had had a panel at its heart,
heart surgery,
but he's fine.
And that was that valve issue.
But yeah,
they said that was something that he was hard.
They said that was something that he was born with,
right.
That it was a a condition.
Yeah.
There's,
if there's no evidence that steroids into special is terrible for you is like we
thought,
right.
Because it started with is Zeto remember that he was like,
oh I have this cancer,
this brain tumor cause I took steroids.
But there's the scientific research to back problem is some people just get
brain tumors.
So you got to wonder like how come everybody's not getting a brain tumor?
Right.
Are we sure that the brain tumors from that?
Like it's theirs.
There's very
individual cases apparently it's really hard to tell what's the ultimate cause
cause you're dealing with all sorts of environmental and also look at broad
trends like they were talking about cell phone use,
cell phone use has gone up a great deal.
But since 1992 from the last statistic I just read,
which was yesterday,
the Gliomas,
brain tumors,
the really dangerous one kind have not,
they've stayed pretty steady since 1992 so you'd think with all that solution.
Yeah.
No,
that is interesting Brian.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
So you would see a huge market rise over the last 20 years,
the massive course,
but you just haven't,
but the 26 years you haven't,
it stayed very steady.
Maybe it takes like,
maybe it's like cigarettes for awhile they said cigarettes don't cause lung
cancer.
Yeah,
50 years to figure it out,
but it's not ionizing radiation.
It's radio frequency.
It's not ionizing ionizing like which would be x rays and gamma rays,
that kind of stuff.
That's ionizing,
so what that does actually is it changes.
It knocks Adams,
I guess off the DNA or if screws with your DNA,
which can then lead to cancer itself,
but it doesn't mean that it necessarily will,
but what happens is like if one guy dies of whatever cancer,
he's took steroids and he accused that,
then we liked,
oh,
that's what steroids do.
If there's one example,
the media,
Russia's,
here's an important point.
Crispin Rob was just a bad dude with some CTE and for a lot of things wrong,
he was on drugs,
all kinds of painkillers.
Who's on steroids to steer those things?
Also,
when you're taking painkillers,
certain painkillers,
they react really badly to other drugs and of course alcohol.
If alcohol is involved,
I don't know if it was,
but then they react even worse.
It could've been just a shitty person too.
You don't like maybe he's a bad dude and they got all high and did some fucked
up stuff and he could've,
you know,
gone crazy.
Who the fuck knows?
But uh,
the Lyles adal an important point is that lie allows,
ido was taking human growth hormone hormone and a time where they were getting
it from cadavers,
they would get there.
We're getting human growth hormone in a different way than they gather it.
Now.
The way they gather it now as they produce it with bacteria that they use yams
and stuff.
That's for testosterone can,
it's also for estrogen.
There's,
there's steroid,
uh,
fucking soaked yams,
it sounds so crazy,
but they get testosterone and they can get a female birth control out of why
Mexican wild yams
yams are super good.
Super good.
So like everybody that is on testosterone replacement therapy is getting it from
yams.
Yeah.
It's a problem with it now according to what Novitsky is that they're,
they seem to have figured out a way to get it from animals.
So you're going to get testosterone from animals and it will be because the Carl
identical.
Yeah.
Cause the carbon and they figure it out cause there's a,
it has a different carbon ratio or something.
Carbon Isotope ratio keys on it.
I'm sure he still figured that shit.
He's a fucking altimeter when it comes to that shit.
Snitch.
Golden snatch,
the whole golden showers.
You know,
ultimately we are finding out what really does and does not,
what's really real legit and we didn't know as well works.
You mean how as far as who's on what?
Oh yeah.
Cause everybody was lying.
But look,
but look it over,
reign over.
He was like,
yeah,
I'm not on Shit.
Look at me.
I'm fighting for a world title.
Well,
how about uh,
my man,
Tim means the dirty bird got busted for taking some creek fucking dirty for
crazy creative and they tested his creatine and it's,
it's,
it pisses hi stew found some shit right off the shelf.
They tested it and it pisses hot.
I'm taking.
Craig goes,
well,
it,
listen,
you can take it,
but you got to realize that most of the stuff you're buying,
if you're buying things from like GNC muscle building,
they there,
they put steroids in them.
Wow.
There's a list on the EU side of it is massive.
There's a list and Usada all these testosterone boosters.
How many of you make you piss hot in the Olympics?
It's like thousands of cat dude.
Like we,
Jamie and I went over to the other day.
We tried to just get through the letter a a is hundreds and hundreds of stories
and a Bowlick animal.
I'll take any steps to whey protein basically.
And this is what they do apparently a quarter to a friends that are,
uh,
that are in that world than in the supplement world.
What they're allowed to do is they can take something like,
it's why when you buy a gas station,
boner pills,
they have viagara and steroids in them.
Who's buying the really Brian Red Van?
He buys them all the time.
Hey man,
he lives off on,
I don't have friends.
He doesn't even test them.
Just fuck.
It takes two or three throws with that goes towards rock hard.
So they actually know.
So it,
it's,
it's a steroid to,
there's like,
it makes you look super horny.
It makes you aggressive.
Yeah.
They're like,
but what happens is they get caught and then they take it off the market and
then they come right back with a new name.
Now it's rhino pay church.
They don't,
they change.
I can molecule if it is on the bay.
This change of different names.
So she had some friends,
it's not banned list.
They just lie about what's in it.
They don't go that far,
but it's like legit.
Nobody's paying attention by fake marijuana.
That's what you're talking about it.
That's what they do.
No,
no,
no.
He's talking about bass salts.
Bath salts is what they do when they take Mtma or anything.
It's usually crystal meth and they fuck people jump out of windows.
Is it fake marijuana as a plant though?
How they want to kids come by.
Wait,
that's sold it.
What?
So how do they do that?
What do they do?
They would distribute it and like the people that would,
yeah,
the story.
They're wanting it.
They would get hit up by the FDA or wherever it was against it,
the DEA,
and they would tell him what specific chemicals were illegal.
They would then go back to the lab is to take that specific molecule out.
Change the number like from CLL.
Right,
but how can they do that with weed?
They did those.
Andrew Stevens.
How we'd,
it's that spice.
They're spraying fake THC on it so people think they're getting
oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
Okay,
so [inaudible] is like a legal,
anybody could buy it.
Whoa.
Havana is,
hey,
we tried it.
You were trying to get the fuck would I,
would anyone try?
That's what they do.
And then they change it 15 and busted out and then they go back and the same
company makes it and they twisted a little bit past salts,
bath salts.
If you,
if you've seen videos,
kids freaking on that.
What the funny thing about people still doing that he's these pills from the gas
stations is there,
it's not like a similar stuff to Viagara.
It's the fucking throw Viagara in it and steroids.
You're taking that Barry bonds.
Yeah.
You take it all kinds of shit and fuck girls hit baseballs.
You know what I'm saying?
I can't believe you have a friend who takes that shit.
I always looked at it like
he's out of his mind.
Does he buy fuck those lot lizards.
We never met Red Ben Brandon,
he never met red man.
Met him very briefly at our,
at our first live show at the comedy store.
Cause uh,
Rogan and uh,
him came through there.
But I often we talk to each other on Twitter,
but I've never,
I've never had a conversation with them shit,
which is weird cause he's just friends.
So you think we'd link up but no,
he's ridiculous.
He'll take those things all day.
Some people don't care really is carbon nichrome systems.
Mushrooms just shatter.
It doesn't give a fuck.
Smokes a lot.
Smoked cigarettes and drinks.
That's like my friend was like,
I want more energy.
Can,
can you help me?
I go,
is you smoke?
And he goes,
yeah,
I go,
you gotta Stop Smoking before I start talking to you.
He goes,
no,
I can't do that.
I was like,
then I'm not going to have a conversation with you.
You can't like,
what the fuck do you know that you're talking to?
And you said you've got to stop smoking.
The famous,
he's a famous,
he's a famous director,
no doors.
Okay,
but he's a famous director and I was like,
yes,
I smoke.
He goes,
no.
I go,
can I go?
You're going to die.
He goes,
why the Hell I've never,
I've never fucked with by ag or anything like that.
Good for you.
You have no,
of course.
Really.
I took it once.
It gave me a headache.
I'm on it right now.
I knew this podcast is going to be strong.
Well,
11 that right,
and see that rhino 12 the graphic is so intense.
I'm not taking that.
I don't want to blow.
It makes sense that what kind of pussy picks up rhino?
Seven.
Damn,
I wasn't gonna write to Rhino 12 I'm taking that rhino 11 I'm like,
well,
we hit a party.
See.
I'm like,
you know what,
Rhino seven leaks were bitches rhino 11 I'll take.
It's interesting that just having might be for girls,
it's almost
Jesus Christ means he's getting ready to party,
time,
size,
and stem.
And he's not kidding,
man.
He really does take those headache,
dude.
There's some dude did a review of those things online and he said they fucking
work.
Not only did work,
it's like they're crazy good.
Maybe he's getting sponsored by or something.
And every day,
I'm only kidding when I say every day,
but he takes it a lot,
Brian parties.
But then once you don't,
w when you stop taking as your Dick not work,
you know,
like steroids to talk to him.
Hey,
I'm going to say test
Lorens Larkin and Jorge Mas Brendan up.
I'm not gonna say it that I've ever done.
Viagara I'm not going to say definitely,
but I'm saying if you ever do Mtma,
you're going to need that shit.
Trust me.
That's all I'm going to say.
Well listen,
listen,
let me,
let me know.
Let's watch this fight and because this is a big one,
Lorens Larkin and Jorge Mosfet all this is how they're on the side.
Super Skillful fight just to get to this.
Okay.
That's a sleeper fight.
Great fight.
Larkin and underdog.
A little surprised.
Well Larkin had that fight with tune off.
It could have gone either way.
Yes,
that was super close.
Fight Larkin is a slick stand up fighter.
Real slick,
but so is mosfet all remember Mossville dolls like kind of the first Kimbo
slice.
He was a backyard fighter in Miami.
Well he was,
yeah.
He was in the same group as Kimbo.
Yep.
Right.
Yeah.
I mean he was in some of those early videos.
Yeah,
man,
super game.
Phenomenal Ref.
He's good at everything.
Yeah,
he's good at everything.
He's a very smart guy.
Very,
very sneaky.
Remember when he fought,
he fought eve Edwards and I think it was Bo dog.
He had kicked him.
Dude,
if he's on,
he just,
I don't see how guys beat the,
that was what you did that everything is back when ease was considered to be one
of the best in the world.
Everybody thought ease was,
I mean is after ease.
I think it was after he had beat and Josh Thompson so talented for a long time.
Oh yeah man.
Well,
you know,
father time catches up to everybody.
Just,
just people that can do things that your body just can't do anymore after.
Not just father time,
but I think more importantly,
beatings.
Yeah.
I can't take the beans.
I think it's more the reaction.
Like last,
like last night I was working at Shane Mosley fight and asked him afterwards,
I said,
you know,
he fought a young guy,
he's 25.
I said,
what was the difference?
He goes,
my reaction times just not there.
He's way younger,
faster like I have to do.
Yeah.
He lost his decision.
He goes,
I wanted to throw something.
It's just not there anymore.
He was like this the first time I've noticed it to go.
And how long has it been since his last fight?
Uh,
he felt like six months ago.
Seven months ago.
But he fought,
you know,
not the same caliber guys.
He wasn't fighting getting guys.
Right.
It's like an older guys.
And I fought a young hungry line and Shane was always so quick and he was young.
So quick man.
But you gotta think Shane's also been punishing his body through camps 44 yeah,
for all these years level for 20 years,
you know,
for more than 20 units.
You know,
he was a stellar,
a nice switch kick to the body.
He was a stellar,
a amateur fighter as well as the amateur fighters.
So you've got to think about all those years of boxing and all the damage that
does to you.
After awhile your body just does not want to perform anymore.
He still almost beat that young cat,
Larkin fight out of,
what's it?
He's good man.
He's stands on any Jujitsu.
I'm millennium MMA,
but he is he a stand up fighter first and grappler second?
He's,
yeah,
he's,
well he's,
he's got skills in the ground for sure.
But yeah,
on his feet.
He's super sweet.
He looks for his take down a fence is amazing.
He came to rain one time and just wrestling.
Fuck.
We can,
people couldn't get them down.
Tell him he owes Cummings myself.
Why?
He's a monster.
What?
Well,
he fought it and high level class,
he beat Robbie Lawler and Strikeforce at one 85 people forget about that.
The Larkin is legit and at this weight class now?
Yeah,
at one 70 he's really,
really good.
But it just shows you how deep the pool is because Tumen off beat him.
Although I,
like I said,
it could've gone either way.
He,
he throws this really creepy fucking spinning heel kick to the legs,
a lot nasty.
He's really good at it and he does it on the inside and the outside.
But he did it on the outside a couple of times against [inaudible] and I was
like,
Whoa,
I want to see him.
That Jude last fight,
he fought.
He was in the guy in the,
and the calf.
It was just crazy.
I was just thinking about like,
these guys are so talented.
Right?
And you look at welterweight,
you look at middleweight,
it's like Bisbee.
It took him 10 years to get a title shot.
10 fucking,
that's how tough it is,
man.
I know.
And meanwhile if you all were marrow didn't get popped and if was ray didn't get
hurt,
he wouldn't have even gotten that call.
Never got a title shot.
It's your son.
Nice.
Not,
not necessarily true.
He could have beaten one more guy and got a title shot,
but he wasn't really in line.
He's in a tough spot,
man with it,
with with,
with this career.
Physically his eye.
He's tough with Joel.
Go to Jackson's.
Is he training there?
Somebody said,
I don't know.
I had heard something like that too.
I don't know what they're going to do with him.
He was another one.
He is another one that he had a supplement that he took an off the counter
supplement over the counter supplement that was tainted.
Yup.
There's a lot of them that are changing shit.
Yeah,
but it works.
It works.
There's other reasons why this stuff has shifted.
It is,
there's reason you can't take it.
Your,
your friend tells me it works and you're going to work.
You're going to,
you're going to next wines.
Yeah,
but he just makes it,
I was glad to see him get a title shot,
but it sucks.
It's that way.
But now I think of it's probably the only way it was going to happen.
Yeah,
most likely.
Mosbey dog just slandered.
Good right hand.
Well you mean it could have happened.
He couldn't look.
He just beat Anderson.
You know they're both older though.
July Keon some joc gray Hillel,
Weidman,
the eye,
it's going to be tough night for him.
Could be,
you know,
I mean the odds are it won't be in my favor.
The odds would be in that favorite,
but not 100%.
You know what I mean?
Like this is a thing about guys that are tough,
like Bisping as they figure out a way to get shit done.
So he just poked his shit out of his eyes and it looks all my God,
Ahh,
muscle can't fight after coming back from that.
Oh my God,
I fucking hate Ipos.
He knew right away too.
He said,
fuck nothing.
His finger probably went into his brain.
Hey Joe.
Hey,
here's a,
an idea for you as off with title shots.
You know how they say,
well,
anyone that top five needs to stay ready.
If there's a title shot and I want to see this,
hello.
Oh my God.
To show you how fucking effective I poke isn't,
I don't think it was question that Brian,
you get in a street fight technique craze that chroma growth then shit.
Right man,
I fucking hate the openly thing guys.
It looks fine.
No,
no,
no.
He's hurting.
He's good.
I know I'm planting my fingers in a dry rice from now.
Listen,
man,
do you think about when you get poked in the eye,
how long it takes before you're ready?
He's ready to go.
Yeah,
because they're making them,
no,
he's also got a bunch of like this.
It feels fucked up.
Do you know,
I would like to see statistics on how when guys fight,
what happens after they get time poked?
Somebody do that.
One of you and I made websites and poke them in the eye.
No,
no,
no.
We're talking about results.
You go through history of birding happen.
So one of the MMA sites,
please,
please do something on this.
If you have the,
the the notion and kicks to the balls kick to the balls are good ones,
but I think I poked her worse honestly.
I bet you'd be surprised at both their clothes.
Maybe you get kicked in the balls and lack of saps everything out of you.
That's like,
that's a good question.
Remember when Chris does?
Sure it got kicked in the nuts by Gonzaga and they're like,
you good bro.
He got kicked so hard.
He goes,
yeah,
I'm good.
Obviously it looks like shit.
He's a Douche.
I had kick game over.
Not that I wouldn't happen anyways.
That was the worst I've ever seen.
Yeah,
it can be bad.
It certainly can be bad.
Is part of Congo's gables a tricky now cause you got a cup.
So sometimes like when these guys are going at it,
man,
Gilbert ival and Bandera Lake fought in pride and,
and,
and vandalize kick Gilbert and the balls.
His cousin matter what his cop,
his cup was caught like right on his balls and it like that.
I'm looking at your balls.
It was a different kind of pain,
still pain that he could not recover from.
It was a different game.
But I want to see a statistic on what happens to guys when it's a close fight
like mitre on and Travis Brown and then it gets,
I poked and then from then on it's a blowout and there's a lot of fights like
that where a guy gets,
I poked and like it looked towards the end,
like mosfet all had recovered.
He looked like he was fighting really smooth and well it didn't look like,
like Travis and Mitch reone is a perfect example of like metro was not the same
after that.
Hypo.
You could tell he got Jack Dan poke twice.
Yes he did.
And they did nothing.
Yeah,
it was not a good refereeing job.
I don't believe who did it.
What do you do that way you don't want to call them out.
I just remember being upset with it.
Like when a guy gets his eye poked that bad.
You know,
like there's a real problem with making a guy go fight when you know he's
compromised.
And the reason why he's compromised as a foul,
so everybody was watching,
wants to fight to continue.
We don't want to be disappointed,
but it's not like the fight is being stopped because of a legit technique.
The fights being stopped because of a foul.
Well that's where,
or what would you do?
I would stop the fight.
He's blinking,
blinking a lot.
He won't stop blinking now.
I would honestly,
I think a guy goes down
like that.
There's almost a good argument to stop the fight.
It definitely changes the dynamics.
I would like to see those statistics too.
I guarantee you it's probably in the,
the favor of the go pokes.
The judges should be allowed to see the replay and go,
okay,
that shit was deliberate.
Boom.
Minus a point where it's not deliberate.
It most times not deliberate,
but if it is certain guys,
how are you going to judge that though it,
but what if it's cleaned?
Fuck.
If it's delivered,
who cares what they were thinking?
If it you fucking landed it,
you're going to get penalized 100% that's it.
It doesn't make me the best way to stop it for sure.
It's never going to stop.
But because it's an instinct and because a lot of guys trained Moy,
Tai and so they used to open handing people on the forehead and push him off and
then you go to do it with a regular gloves [inaudible] time.
They do it.
If you don't get a point taken off,
if like for the first shot,
then a guy knows he has one free shot at the balls.
Right.
Here's the words a while they don't have complete data,
they did find 32 I pokes.
That led to a pause in the action from a sample of 1,333 fights and Ramey
estimated you're likely to see an eye poke in three to 4% of UFC fights taking
it at the high end,
you're likely to see an pope once every 25 fights are so conservatively.
96% of fights transpired,
devoid of,
I Prokes didn't say the,
it doesn't say the success rate success.
That's interesting now to hear that.
Yeah,
it has.
I figured behind that three,
I mean three,
4%.
Well,
how many John Jones fights?
That's probably the three to 4%.
I mean,
there's some guys that just their style and he's so long to see that rumble.
John's fight because,
well,
they're not blowing enough fighting Carmine's going to fight
all
over grumpy.
I'm just crush can fight mosfet all it looks okay,
but no,
only he knows whether or not he got really compromised from that.
Pokies definitely compromised.
But you can still get a win,
but it's definitely,
but it's not the same.
I agree.
I'm with you.
I wouldn't mind if they stopped then came back
to us.
It all looks good.
I'd be pissed if they stopped it.
I agree with you.
I'd be pissed that they stopped it in this fight.
But I think in the mitre own fight,
there's a good argument for stopping it.
That fight.
He looked like way more fucked up.
Like when he went back.
He never,
why he's saying it terrible man.
They do ninth there's a good argument for stopping it is cause it's almost an
unfair to let it die.
He's qualified on,
I think it does qualify to get poker.
If you're talking two to three times what the fuck you gotta do and it's still
an accident and even if it's an accident,
it's still,
it's still does damage,
but then you have to kind of the rough,
I think it's up to the ref.
The ref's kind of assess exactly what kind of an,
I put too much pressure on the ref to give them that kind of power.
Mosfet I a not.
Let's see if he can get a Lorens to the ground.
Lorenzo's fighting it off cause take down a fence.
Neth di Lorenzo is so slick but so's Mazda Donald Man,
I'm liking the,
he's fighting here real that right.
Bam.
Look at that
little doll
some dude made that gave it to me.
Atlanta.
Cool man.
Come on.
That is dope.
Dope.
It's going to be like an animated series man.
I like.
You'd be the star of it.
It's hilarious.
When,
how long it took to me.
It's funny cause the UFC made those little,
they made a lot of hotels and they made me one of me and they,
they'd given it to me whatever the company was and I was like laughing.
I was like that is so ridiculous.
Doesn't look anything like me.
Like didn't look anything like me.
I'm like did you just like pretend it was me just a ball.
Just loving it was back when I was bald.
I think I had hair back then but it was so bad.
It looks like your torso and your arms just like me.
The guy did a great job.
You look a little older than that.
Yeah,
but still,
I was going to say that's fine.
You know we're all getting older.
We're all getting older though cause I just want to get out with that.
Thank you.
Well she's definitely getting older.
Everybody does.
I mean like nobody said immediately.
Ah,
you look all there.
It took a little bit cause we all expect us to get and that you Brendan,
but for us in our late forties compared to you guys,
how old?
33 Christ save every bit of it.
Yeah.
Once you hit 40 you want those guys that had food.
Look at that too.
Right?
Come on up.
Come up.
Come closer.
You guys are wiser though.
It's good to have friends to Larkin.
Let's look in smooth hair,
man.
Maza Donald standing.
Ooh Donald.
That switch kick.
Damn,
I love that switch.
How many he's to get caught here.
That upper cut and them.
Well,
Mazda dolls.
Real,
real sneaky but so's Larkin.
Larkin's real sneaky with this arc and stuff to train for man.
Yeah,
so unconventional.
His angles are weird.
Is Weird.
Boy,
he's got a little bit of like karate mixed in with a lot of boxing and more time
like,
oh look at some of his moves are like karate moves,
but Mazda dot might have tagged them.
They're looking at this La Rocco.
Ooh.
Who saw that coming when I'm around for sure.
Ooh y'all.
All I was saying on those title shots.
What if you know how they say anyone in,
in,
in the top five needs stay in shape.
Just the case guy gets hurt.
What if during the title shot the UFC tells a guy he's the reserve,
so find me,
gets hurt.
You're up brother.
You don't have to go a training camp but be ready because you're the first guy
we go to.
So we should have one around that like laid out like on the card,
like the alternative.
I don't think you tell people because why not say in DC Jones case,
let's say rumbles.
The alternate people want to see that fight.
It's like come on to hopefully get hurt.
I don't think you tell anyone.
You just surprise him,
but only up fight or nose and you start paying people I think was the most
dangerous fight in many ways because Jones does take hits to the face and he
can't do that with,
with a rumble.
I don't think you can do tomatoes.
The alternate either.
Either fighter might have someone pay someone off to make sure that
motherfucker,
you don't tell anyone.
No one's going to do that happen in big title fight.
You're like,
shit,
I want to fight that guy.
I don't want to fight.
Which you'd have to about is some unscrupulous promoter or Sonia for sure.
Like you get about Tonya Harding.
I think if they told Bisbing hey bro,
uh,
you know Susan's out for awhile,
I'll see our boy.
Y'all was out for awhile.
You're,
if something happens a wide means there's a good chance because he does get hurt
Europe.
So don't go to Toronto and Phillip Film a movie.
Yeah.
You tell them one in five,
you're one of five guys were thinking about.
Yeah,
but don't say one to five and they talk to you a fucking move.
No one knows the,
you realize you're at the end of your career.
You've got to take that movie.
Oh,
I'm not hating them.
I'm just saying if the,
if the UFC had a plan in place,
yes,
but then he would still have to take that movie.
Can you get,
you got to take it because it's a burden the hand,
you know,
maybe you would train a little bit.
General guys aren't filming fast and furious nine or whatever.
You know what I'm saying?
You remember like shale sown and Jon Jones,
if you had a backup in case you still have a fight.
So a Weidman is out for a while.
Man.
He's got some disc issues in his neck.
He says he'll be back for that Madison Square Garden Card.
Yeah,
he wants to be,
but he's gotta be real careful because you don't want to rush something like
this.
It's got a bad one.
Herniated disc in his neck.
That's,
whew.
God Damn Lorenzo's fast.
Speaking of herniated disc,
I go on,
I go into surgery Tuesday.
Oh Shit.
Damn Bro.
This replacement baby for your lumbar lower.
Yup.
Wow.
How bad?
How bad is it in my desk?
My l five s one is doesn't exist.
That's why I'm in my lower back is in eternal constant state of inflammation.
It's just sore all always pat,
just a wreck every day,
no matter what.
I could stop working out for two months and it would feel like I did squats the
day before.
Is there anybody you guys know?
You know what I mean?
For she that surgery.
Is there anyone you guys know who trained in Jujitsu for a long time who doesn't
have some issue with their back or neck?
My doctor,
my doctor said,
knocking on your neck and back all the time.
I mean,
it's like it's part of the game.
My next.
You get girls in here or done anything and they're 23
against the cage.
Nope.
God Damn.
Lorens is tough.
Oh.
Oh Shit.
Woo fight dude.
God Damn.
Oh Ba Huh?
Hmm.
Oh my God.
This is a fucking slobber.
Knocker Real Dani.
Oh to pass.
Nope,
he's out.
Do you see what he's doing?
That is crazy.
He's bridging on his name.
He's in trouble now.
It's over the neck.
Hand defense.
That's a lot of sweat.
Beautiful defense.
Mazda dollars.
Fucking relentless to Jesus Christ.
Larkins take down events.
These man.
Hey,
come to fence.
It's nuts.
He just went up on his head.
His good team defense too.
It was insane.
Especially at this when he's this tired.
Yeah.
Third round of Mike Ross started wearing rash guards.
If they wanted to know,
you should be able to wear that.
If you want to girls wearing,
why not?
Why we keep the girls are titties out
takes sweat.
It takes sweat out of the game.
Which I think would a show more technique,
especially grappling
increase
is that kind of
matters accounts guy gets right back.
They should make rash guards mandatory.
No,
no,
no.
I should wear sunglasses.
No,
there's benefits to it.
And then there's negatives to it.
If you're a striker you want to keep Fabi rendering walked in.
Yeah.
Oh he tagged him with an upper cut price.
This fight is amazing.
Crazy nuts.
Definitely not mandatory.
But you got to,
we got to remember this is greasing illegal or illegal.
Illegal.
It's easy cause it's the Ford stuff.
No,
no,
no.
But why though?
Cause it's some substance and then what happens?
Come on.
Don't play games.
So benefits the benefits that guy that has it on him because he can't get the
tannins.
A foreign substance.
Yeah,
of course.
But it's nothing like sweat.
Well it's,
it's nothing like,
it's very much like sweat.
Sweat is slippery and grieves me,
sir.
What is very slippery?
It's very similar.
It's just,
it's just shut down.
It's a lot more extreme.
That brain and that pattern just dealt double duty.
And he wasn't going to do though.
Uh,
put a,
we're not talking to your back for your aisle.
That's like the key argument when I was in everybody wear a g no,
it's just if,
if,
if going home is illegal because it makes it too slowly.
If Greece is illegal,
if it has nothing to do with the gate,
if greasing is illegal because then make shit too greasy and it's a foreign,
the problem is there's no tests for it.
Right.
But uh,
rash guards,
foreign substance,
you can crash cart tests because there is no test.
But tell me about the test,
you know,
with,
with the Vaseline or whatever.
How do they test?
Dude,
you can tell you have a commission following you around from the locker room
till the cage,
but there was no tea,
there's no swab.
And then they put it in,
it's like testing in a cup.
There's no official test that says that you went over the grief limit.
Well,
we can't,
let me,
let me stop this right now because one thing you definitely could do,
100% that has been done is you take a mineral oil bath the night before.
Yes,
take a mineral oil bath the night before she could get into that cage and you
don't have anything on.
You took a shower,
you don't have anything on.
You are so Lippert right
the fucking time.
There's nothing anybody can do about it.
Nothing.
Anyone can do official tests,
but there's no official task.
But since girls are wearing,
girls were rock stars all the time.
Hey,
I need a rescue guy.
So,
but I don't think he was a huge issue where the Dana's going,
holy fuck everyone's slipping missions.
We'll figure something out here.
Every year the NFL has meetings to change stuff to make the sport more a
offensive.
They always,
they're always figuring out a way.
They're always handicapping the defense.
Try,
you know you can't hit the receiver.
You're always handicap in the deep and she wanted authentic as a league.
The same thing with can be done for MMA.
You get together and go,
how do we improve submissions?
For instance,
you improve submissions by make it around.
They want knocked out the one that counts as much as they want.
Some Mitchell.
Exactly.
We do something for the knockouts too.
But you do something for submissions to you every year.
You do something a little bit here and there.
Girls,
whereas cards all the time,
so I can take her titties.
I'll take rash guards,
no gloves for a thousand hours.
Damn it.
No,
no guys,
no gloves.
Let's do it.
That'd be perfect.
You wouldn't have to create this test for this thing that you made illegal.
It's illegal,
but there's no test cause it's not that big of a legal,
hold on.
Hold on.
I don't think you're rice all the time.
Don't think you're right.
Cause I know that herb dean tested someone before.
I know her,
talked to him personally.
He took a swab off.
Someone did is just to test it.
It's like,
listen,
it's a,
it's a crazy event
wouldn't horse.
It's like it's a tremendous advantage.
What did her upset?
Try grappling with someone greasy.
What did herb say?
Punch him in the face.
You said you talked to her.
He said that he's done like onsite shit where he'll like look and see,
but that doesn't stop a guy along Moses.
Maybe a couple months ago,
maybe three months ago,
and I know there was at least I was asking,
there's no test.
They just Lorens Larkin the monsoon because that's a good question.
That's close to close,
but I didn't,
I didn't want you to close enough to judge,
but his take down definitely helped them.
Those two take talk a little bit more amazing fight,
but we barely paid attached to,
let's be honest,
you're talking about illegal greasing and rash guard.
While I'm saying if it's illegal,
come up with an official test.
If there's no official test,
then the symbol,
the symbol could still expensive.
Temple do what the girls did.
The girls wear tops mean.
What's interesting with sweat is that it was sweat the,
the conditions naturally change.
They actually changed.
They start off dependent upon your preparation.
Like that's one of the things where Nate Marquardt fought Paul Harris.
He wore a rubber suit backstage and Nate like really got super sweaty and then
when he went out there to fight,
he was already sweaty as fuck and so when Paul hires one for that leg lock,
Nate was all sweated up.
Nate slipped out and Pahar started pointing at a Nate punches fucking lights on.
That was great.
One of my favorites of all time.
It was great.
It was his greatest dude.
Well,
it was a great ending and he was like Turkish oil wrestling.
You should check it.
Yes,
I'll Turkish oil to the rest of the,
they look like they look like you had mustaches.
It does guys reach into each other's pants.
Then the gravity of this deck and they usually just,
Dick
don't know Bruno.
When it goes,
the body will follow it.
You guys want that to no gloves and Dick,
what's your
mustache?
Handlebar mustache.
You'd look good.
I have a question for you.
Head gear is there,
is that science that it actually is worse for you when your box can be worse?
It's not necessarily worse,
but it can be worse.
Why's?
It makes a larger fulcrum because it's a larger thing and you get clipped and it
makes your head spin more.
Oh yeah.
And it's also a heavy,
yeah.
So you have this thing,
what is a way like half a pound,
a pound or hash?
It makes your head,
it's slower for your head to move.
One of the things about punches as you see them coming,
you got to learn how to roll with Shit and you can't roll with shit if you have
this big ass fucking head gear on,
but then you can't begin because it's good for cuts.
So he can't get cut.
But that's just in training.
It's only training.
Yeah,
it was not,
I mean it's,
it's,
I think you're better off grease in your fucking head up,
but then there's a problem cause they grease heads up,
the grease faces up and shit.
And then you take that same grease and you put it on a dude's chest as you're
trying to take them down.
And then you grab your arms,
you wrap it around at night and get grease on your arms.
Boxers aren't bottoms,
Vaseline in the face up.
You're allowed much Vaseline are they using in the UFC these days they're using
less and less.
That's like leftover bullshit boxing shit.
While it makes Vaseline all over your fucking seeking slip punches,
makes punches not cut you off.
So they hit you,
but they slide off instead of instead of them grazing and scrap by with the
leather gloves.
Hey,
I'm down with that.
I will say this.
No Vaseline,
no gloves,
cheese,
rash,
guard,
no gloves and rash guard.
You said rash cause you could wear a rash guards.
I don't think there's a problem with rash guards,
but I think rational idea.
I feel like your phones would cut skin rash guard you against that optional.
This theophany Kamozi it's a bad look.
You could put your fucking Reebok on that.
A big,
can you imagine the Reebok rash guards that can come up with,
with the red and the black love and closes his door.
Vito Vito Miranda.
This dude's a bad motherfucker.
This is a serious fight here.
Kamozi Miranda.
Yeah.
It'd be a grade d.
Where's he from it?
I got a zeal Kamozi so game his name and his game as fuck and he's been training
with Weidman's Kim,
great hair trains in Denver,
and then he was going out to wipe off the camp.
Tough man and soul.
Miranda Miranda is a little older thing.
Miranda,
I want to say he's 34 35 but he's a multiple time kickboxing champion.
He said nasty.
You start remembering the fraction and a Russian assassin.
Even though he's from Brazil,
he's not rush.
It's like a Russian.
He was a finalist in the ultimate fighter Brazil.
Remember Jesus,
he's just fucking monster.
It was babies.
It's the best.
It's a tough fight for Kamozi.
[inaudible] to tell.
If I click on this,
click on his name please.
Victim.
And so you find out what his last fights where one calle last fight.
I think he's three last three fights.
Three finishes in that,
right.
I can't see that.
When,
when?
When?
Scroll down.
J.
O.
K.
L.
What's up son?
Oh yeah,
Masa Marcello,
Gui.
Marez,
Mara's.
I forget how to say that guy's
name,
but he knocked that dude out.
It was nasty and Gomorrah was,
uh,
was a really good striker himself and the clinic has to fight to woo.
I was like,
Jesus Christ,
she's only less that decision.
Ultimate fighter finale.
And he'd just wrestled him the whole time.
Yeah.
He's a bad motherfucker.
I'll fight for Kamozi stylized.
Kamozi is not a wrestler.
He's not a grapple.
You likes to stand in Bang.
He know what though?
Kamasi.
So God damn tough.
He's just so fucking tough.
He's one of those dudes.
You just can't count out now unless you,
unless it's fine.
Junker a drug.
I said,
what?
I'm gonna eat that ass up.
Easy paycheck.
I was so crazy.
The exact same way.
I'll do this shit all day.
Yeah.
Well I for commodes those losses,
like you know,
you recover from those pretty quick.
Tap on the next week.
It's all good baby.
Now.
That was fucked up twice.
Short notes fights those killer [inaudible] Shakuri his ground game was he tore
his meniscus or something.
Yeah,
he's got a,
he's got a neat,
it's a little beat up from training camp for Vituro tour.
What he did to veto was just she,
Jesus,
he should have taken a fucking cortisone shot and jumped in that fight.
He really showed up.
I agree.
You know,
I almost failing unless it's really fucked up.
But I just feel like man,
he's going to get a title shot.
But he fought against Rockhold and everybody knows it.
Rockhold took that last fight with staff.
It's staff and it's fun.
It's pretty fucked up.
Everybody fights hurt.
You know,
you're telling me like this opportunity I guess maybe just wasn't,
he was eating donuts and shit.
Maybe just wanting to break or maybe went on the boom bar.
You didn't know what it is.
Do you laugh and you know,
no,
we're talking about steroids.
Yeah,
exactly.
I don't think he did.
I don't think it would drop right.
Did,
but um,
it sucks that he didn't take that fight cause I think stylistically that's a
really interesting gonna happen though.
You mean,
you mean it's going rock hauling?
Rockhold they fought,
they fought in Strikeforce and Rockhold wanted decision.
And I just,
I still think,
I still think the guy who's going to beat both Weidman and rock hall by any of
those guys is a Yoel Romero.
Maybe he's just so Romero barely beat Jacques hurray.
Yeah,
he did.
But like what is,
when you think about why,
when you think about it,
of course it's tracking,
but it's raising Jocko raped,
beat Ramiro rather.
That's why he uh,
he was next in line,
but,
uh,
when Jocko Ray beat Ramiro,
he almost got taken out in that first round,
but then he came back in one second and third.
Yeah.
But you know,
Ramiro,
I think we,
we fucking missed out.
You can keep it up here hiding.
We'd for Ramiro missed out in that.
He's like 30,
late thirties,
like 30 6:37 PM late.
Yeah.
If we got ahold of Romero when he was like 26 what I mean,
he was just a God damn super duper athletes.
All natural.
He's a free,
well,
you know,
I don't know,
but he,
he did beat,
um,
Cael Sanderson twice,
twice,
which is,
you know,
you're talking about the Olympic gold medal.
He walked through
the,
in that finals against that Korean guy to win the gold medal.
He walked through that guy.
He was like,
he was just,
he was just crazy man in monsters as a wrestler.
I mean,
I've seen him do stuff inside the octagon like you,
just,
his movements.
So like when I'm watching fights,
you know,
up close and you watch like thousands of them or whatever,
I've watched at this point,
do you like get you still at certain speeds that people move under and every now
and then someone to move at a speed that you're like,
Whoa,
my brain is not recognizing this.
Like,
how's like Barboza switch kick?
My brain just goes,
whoa,
whoa.
What the fuck?
I'm good dude.
And I think that one of the biggest examples of that is Yotel.
Yeah.
Well,
the way he moves when he throws people around,
it's almost like he's not even the same thing as them.
Well,
I can just toss this guys around like,
like you're,
you know,
like,
like he's just some crazy ass silver bag and you're some dude in a rubber
gorilla outfit.
He lost the Tim,
he lost a jock gray I think.
Well he didn't lose the Tim but he definitely should have been disqualified.
Definitely cheated.
And I thought he loved me out.
He knocked out Tim and the third round but never made it to the third brown.
They should have.
He didn't,
he was not capable of coming off his stool for the third round.
They should have stopped the fight and they should've given to cheating.
No,
I think he should have laundry or per site based off that disqualified.
I thought he lost her job gray.
He definitely lost a jock ray.
He lost a decision.
He definitely know.
But he was like kind of close and they know,
I think well he almost put joc raise lights out in the first that's spinning
back fist and then after that was,
thank you ma'am.
But I think you're crazy if he had him and half guards,
you see that when he stood right up like you know there's something about Joel
morale or where's that where it seems like Jocko Jujitsu,
nothing was going to work.
Yeah,
it was a very close fight.
But I mean he's the ultimate athlete.
He makes other athletes like fat slobs.
He's afraid he makes like real Alec.
If you saw like Chris Weidman as a study.
Yes.
Chris Weidman is standing next to y'all was like,
Chris,
why don't you work out?
Right.
And Chris is a great restaurant but it's wrestling.
Chris looks like next door.
It was just like super skinny.
I'm bummed out.
He's got a neck injury cause I want to see that motherfucker fight.
It's a great fight.
It's up and the rematch matched amazing.
But that neck injuries,
no joke.
And I just hope he doesn't do something drastic quickly in order to repair
himself quickly.
Tried to get from passage where it goes.
Does he needs surgery for the neck or is it just might not be,
I mean it's,
it sounds similar to the exact injury that I had.
What I had to do is take a log time and you have to do decompression.
I do,
I have this neck harness that I hang on a door.
It hangs on a doorframe and it's like I'm hanging myself.
It velcros in place.
I pull it down tight and I'd go like this,
click,
and I hang on my neck.
How long,
how long does it take?
Why they need surgery?
Sure,
why he does this and in doing that and doing that,
what I just described over a long period of time and Regena keen,
those two things,
it stopped my bulging disc and it's sucked back into my neck.
My disc stuck out.
Like there was an Mri when they looked at the disc and it was like six
millimeter bulge.
Now I have none.
It went back.
You can do it,
but when you go to doctors,
one of the first things you want to do is cut you.
Now obviously is a super important to talk about everybody's injuries different
because it worked for me.
It might not work for you.
Your,
your injury might be worse than mine and it might get to a point where there's
nothing they can do except for surgery.
But you don't know that just by talking to some doctors because some doctors are
just ready to cut you and they might be right and they might have had success
with it.
But that gentleman was on TV right now is a testament to the fact that it does
not always work.
And boss will tell you he's had several neck surgeries and because of that,
because of his neck injury,
his arm,
he has one arm.
It's atrophy that he calls baby arm because his,
his nerves weren't firing to his arm was impinged.
Yeah,
I mean serious,
serious shit.
What,
what they're going to ask what Chris is decision to be based off of what's going
to get me back faster.
It's probably gonna be surgery.
You can't,
but he's got a thing called the no,
tell him.
Anyways,
he's got to think about the future because he's one of the baddest motherfuckers
on the planet and I think you can get back in action but he's got,
it's an injury and you've got to let it heal up instead of like cutting it out.
Now in Eddie's case,
Eddie's got a totally different case.
Any disc is gone,
it's gone.
It's just my lower back is in constant in a constant state of inflammation.
It's been like that for maybe eight years.
I've tried fucking everything.
He also has finally,
well finally got my Mri.
People kept saying get an Mri and I tried all everything,
fucking chiropractor,
all this shit,
acupuncture.
And uh,
finally I got an MRI and Mri shows.
I mean any fool can see there is no distance and bone to bone.
I know you,
you,
you are in a constant state of inflammation cause I would stop working out.
Once I started having back spasms in my back,
felt like it was just going to completely cut out.
I stopped working out altogether and in two months I still felt like I did dead
lifts the fucking day before.
Well,
Miranda's back probably think great.
He doesn't it these 37 yeah,
I started,
I have no idea.
I thought he was a young dude.
No,
I think he was 35 when he was on the ultimate fighter for him.
Yeah,
no,
he's a stud and,
but you know,
hormonally the thing is when you get to be that age,
it's like you're,
you're dealing with a reduced level of testosterone unless you're like super
vittores saying pre super on point with your diet soup trunk point with your
rest.
Super on point with consumption of saturated fats and cholesterol.
That's very important.
If you want to have a natural testosterone production,
and this is something that I really get pissed off when people start talking
about the dangers of saturated fats.
Like you're,
you're,
you're preaching some outdated nonsense,
some nonscientific bullshit that people have said and they've said it to
demonize meat consumption.
It's right.
And meat consumption.
Look who scientifically it's not bad.
What's bad is ethically and we,
I think we all agree that factory farming's bad ethically,
but when
it comes to like scientific conceit,
consumption,
saturated fats are super important for testosterone production.
Super Important for brain function.
Cholesterol,
not just cholesterol produced by the body,
but dietary cholesterol,
which by the way apparently barely moves the needle on blood lipids.
Yeah,
that's a big,
that's right.
Does the new science new?
Well,
yeah.
I mean eating the yolk of the egg is not,
is not going to move the needle in terms of what you,
you and that's where most of the nutrients are.
US.
I just got five new chickies.
Um,
I got five,
a little baby chicks.
It's,
where do you get from the other chickens?
You had a little farm and ever seen here?
Old Chicken?
No,
no.
I don't eat them.
No,
no,
no other pets.
They're like pets.
We've put them out here to play with them and stuff.
I remember one thing about factories and shit.
Oh yeah.
There's no way we can't eat.
You can't even,
they've died.
They've died.
We don't eat them shot.
No,
I don't even know.
Wow.
Now they're pets.
Amazing.
While I can be nice there,
patty mandated standards like about like her own food,
chickens,
you raise them to eat 'em to do it.
Like I thought that was the ethical way and he's going,
shit,
I hardly ever eat chicken.
You're using them.
But I wouldn't,
I wouldn't eat them because we have a different kind of relationship.
The relationship that I have with them is that they're egg layers and there are
little friends like we go in there and my daughter picks them up so they still
pay him off from personalities?
No,
they have different personalities.
He was there like one of them was really smart and she knows when you actually
my dog killed that one,
but we had one that was really smart and she would uh,
pick up the,
uh,
the dog got in the chicken coop.
Man.
It's so funny.
Like in the Fox,
in the chicken coop.
Smart with time.
Unfortunately the smart one wanted to have the lowest perch.
I guess she wasn't that sports.
Yeah,
it was a smart one.
Yeah.
She knew to follow me around and uh,
like she knew that if anybody picked up rocks that like my wife would like lift
up rocks and she would go into that and get the bugs.
She knew she,
she followed you around waiting for you to pick up rocks for smart little
chicken too stupid.
You kind of understand a little bit in my obsession with my bunny.
Oh No,
I totally understand.
People thought it was not as I had a bunny and I was obsessed with that man.
That was,
I fell in love with it.
Dude.
I was fucking 41 41 in level of rabbit in love with the bunny dude.
I was in love with it.
I was,
oh Kamozi elbow Sun Kamozi tagged him.
Dude was straight left hand when,
when,
uh,
I was doing the show and that one of the guys who,
that second id had a,
an African gray parrot,
I think there was a cockatoo and he had it for 17 years.
Oh my God.
And his wife got an argument.
The para was on the ground.
He stepped on the parrot and killed it.
After 17 years,
man.
And he came and I had macaws so I knew what he's got and he came to work and he
was all bunched up and my friend was like,
it's a fucking burn.
I got dude,
it's not just a bird,
Bro.
They're really smart.
And it was his best friend stepped this wall arguing with his wife.
He's like,
you bitch.
And another thing I say,
it's a God know what the fuck did you make me do you make 17 years.
He met,
he had the bird way before he met her.
He blamed her Kamozi scramble,
scramble,
hips out,
hips out.
Get that fucking little lingo.
I'll be carefully from the box,
from the bar because this might be an improvisational knee bar.
Get out of there now that everybody
is a purple belt.
50 50 there you go.
Yeah,
it really is.
It is,
right?
Yeah.
This is like his defense.
The defense on the one that,
I mean it is in terms of nothing's going to happen.
No.
Kamozi Kamozi got some.
He's trying to set him out.
He got something.
If he wants it,
he'd fucking definitely it.
If he knows what he's doing.
He's got,
he does.
Yes a lot.
I don't know if you're gay tone and yeah,
he's going to be fine.
That's interesting.
How hard are those elbows to the thigh from that?
How much does that suck?
No one ever.
I've known I've never had it done cause you would think that a guy who's got
really good elbows could seriously fuck your leg up like this here.
You see what I'm saying?
Like Miranda is like got some serious elbows and I'm watching him and I'm like I
bet this guy can fuck your legs up.
The this is interesting cause cause come along and have a question like this.
Exactly.
He could,
he could release that body locking
the body launch rare is a week of moseys punching him in the face from the
fucking
oh you go for leg locks.
Guy's going to punch.
You.
Rarely do people say get a leg lock position but instead of finishing them
because Kamozi isn't an offensive position,
he could go after that.
He'll fucking thing that's going on.
He's,
he's,
he's punching the guy back.
What's going on is Miranda backwards.
He,
this was going on.
Miranda's trapped.
Kamozi can move his body forward and back.
Where's Miranda can't.
Oh,
now come on.
And he's trying to lock it in and he's Oh,
times out puzzles.
He hit him with some hard,
right.
The rest are going to score that.
Well,
you should
give that rounded.
Kamozi well,
not just that,
that position,
even though Miranda's above him,
you have to understand who's close to getting something done and who's being
more effective.
Kamozi had a,
he had a heel,
he hit a potential him and then he also punched him in the face of the big
things,
the punches in the face.
Even though Miranda's on top.
Kamozi is tagging him with that right hand.
Kamozi also made that position happen.
He wasn't put on Bob exactly,
exactly.
Which is a big day.
There's a,
a new level of leg lock game.
The John Danaher put together that,
you know,
um,
a very,
very important part of Jujitsu right now.
And 10 planets all over it,
man.
We,
we've taken the leg lock game to the next fucking level within ourselves.
You don't see a lot of it in the UFC.
Now let's come on.
Ryan Hall.
Yeah.
Ultimate.
Ultimately Francisco
say that's a shit.
One thing that you're going to see that's different is leg lock battles against
the cage.
There's a whole different thing.
There's going to damn rash guards and leg lock battles.
Super good point.
No,
Eddie,
that's a super good point because they can't go anywhere.
I'm telling you about the future and you're sitting here talking about the
president.
Hey
Miranda Ravo Miranda's
got some nasty smooth kickbox.
Oh by the way,
look at that leg.
Look at that inside me.
Well,
the inside leg kick he's,
he's doing,
he's attacking the knee itself.
May last three strikes have gone like right on the two skinny.
He looks like he's got skinny knees there.
Kamasi is made out of iron.
Fucking kid's a stud.
He's iron man.
Nobody's needs are your needs.
And I made for sports.
How about that?
Go ahead and kick the knee.
That's all bone.
So well.
Moran has been slamming his Shin into the outside and the inside of that nature.
Ouch.
The mushy parts.
Yeah,
he's definitely a,
it looks a little
inside Ne.
Yeah,
but why is that one okay?
If people that are upset about attacking the knee,
that one is almost as devastating,
especially the outside low kick.
Like Ernesto who style.
By the way,
I've flipped flopped.
I'm for stopping.
I thought about what you're saying this whole time where you were saying this
whole time.
You know what?
Oh
Shit,
into my gym again.
Kamozi on Todd's fucking leg kicks.
Are they going to walk with the grandchildren?
People don't think about,
they never think of Google.
Eddie Miranda's got a maze to get to his fucking buy.
A fucking ivory handled can.
Looking at Miranda's left leg.
It's amazing to get to his dick.
You go in and you've got to follow the law.
Follow the bread crumbs.
It's the grandfather clock maids.
There's amazing.
I was left this.
I'm saying that a Brazilian accent.
It's great when a short girl from my knee amass all the way to my,
all the way around just going north.
You find it way.
There's no cheese,
cheeses,
openly gay play by play commentator commentate this fight,
a Brazilian Brazilian,
this guy's heart
strong.
The mass
oil
oil.
It's no,
I have questions
I'll be answering you just um,
it's just sweat.
It's not,
it's not an oil sweat for debt for the body on body.
They're just working out really hard in your body.
Your body heats up and um,
hit hit all the head here.
Yeah.
Why,
why are they are so strong?
Because they're,
they're fighting
other men.
They have to be strong.
Otherwise you get your ass kicked and you know,
you want to protect your joints and stuff sometimes,
you know,
it's ridiculous.
Come up.
I don't know.
Well,
you know,
the closer,
I'm pretty tight.
They've got quality Reebok gear on here and cops and stuff.
Everything's fine.
You don't have to worry about that.
Okay.
You already smelling good.
You are.
Judy will shower all day and I just got back from bear hunt,
smell like bear and I smell and I like the forest.
Vito Miranda cut over the left eye.
Joey what?
Chris most Wellman Kamozi working animals ground.
Well you know,
you,
you know as well as anybody that the gaps in grappling are the hardest to close
for some reason mind,
you know,
not the hardest,
the hardest.
Every,
every gap is a hard gap to close.
Right?
You say striking but not necessarily in the case of like a guy like Damien Maia
to a guy who was a good high school wrestler,
you're never closing that gap and your lifetime.
Like you're going to have to become obsessed with Jujitsu and live on the mats
for the next 10 years to even get in his neighborhood.
That's a good point.
Cause there's got like,
like Alistair Overeem who's just look at this,
Ben Rothwell for ratio for doom added the tool three in Cleveland,
googly Mowgli in that crazy that uh,
I liked that fight and you got Steve Bay over him as the main event.
I like that fight too.
So why is there not an automatic rematch for,
for Steve Bay?
Everybody doesn't get an automatic reminder.
You do.
It has to be,
but I mean,
I don't know why he doesn't do that cause it was a Kia that was in his,
a lot of people waiting in line like over him.
I want to see the Overeem.
I want to see the Overeem steep a fight.
As much as I want to see any fight in the UFC other than the cane and VRE doom
rematch,
I want to see Cain for doom,
sea level
Kane.
I want to see Cain in great shape.
I think I still maintained that.
I've seen like again,
it's just coming to movements and what you see inside fights.
I think Kane,
like in the second fight with junior dos Santos,
I think that is right up there in my eyes with faders fight with cro cop where
you just seeing a a mauling by a better animal against an animal in his prime or
the best game we've ever seen in that.
I really would.
I really would have wanted more than anything else in the history of the
heavyweight division is that cane versus that fade or fade or versus cro?
Cop vs Cain junior too.
That's sick.
That would be the ultimate who's the greatest heavyweight of all time because
right now then it just becomes speculation.
You know,
after Cain gets like a back injury and two knee surgeries and shoulder
surgeries,
you got to go.
How much of him does he have left?
I mean,
how much are we seeing?
Are we seeing the same came that fought junior dos Santos?
Are we seeing the same cane that uh,
you know,
ran through guys on the way up to the title of the ran through Rothwell.
I don't know if we are with specially with his style.
Yeah.
Style.
Just break everything including himself.
Bull dog training,
mental toughness,
ferocious born
to fight and the body just can't keep up with the mind.
Yeah.
So to me those are the two does,
that's number one.
Number two.
But then Cain and bull and fade or both submitted by Verdugo.
That's right.
Both of them for dumb submitted the three greatest heavyweight talk to you for
dooms the grace.
Have we had look,
could are,
you really can't.
It could be Steve Bay.
Just shut the fucking show off so you can't argue that you still can.
You can't base it off one fight.
Right?
The product,
you can argue it and also Verdomme realistically is in his late thirties and
clean.
What's going on over here?
Why did they stop?
Cut His cut.
That's a bad one.
Above the eye.
Is that,
but I'm saying it's thick.
He's going to be fine.
Oh yeah.
It looks nasty.
Yeah.
Just don't worry about it,
doctor.
Don't take us as doc.
Smile.
That doctors,
that motherfucker is from Vegas,
he's not letting that.
He says he can dive it
is,
I was falling off.
Now he's not saying that.
I'm just going to stop that kind of shit.
Gotta be disgusting.
Like the crowds got to go.
Shit like your,
your ears kind of fall off cozy.
Kamasi's kickboxing's very good man.
Very good.
I'm really impressed.
It's like his kickboxing has gotten smoother.
It's timing has gotten better and a must be because he was really concentrating
it and knowing it was going to fight Miranda and I think that,
and then he also went to these coasts training with Ray Longo and why going back
to Denver re log in is Chad man wait long.
It was an excellent coach.
Oh look at this Kamozi with the tig tone.
Commodes he's such a good dude too,
man.
Great Guy.
Both guys are.
Miranda is a really nice guy too.
He's been fighting forever,
man.
On the Denver scene.
He was kind of like the first guy was just doing the damn thing.
Yeah,
and again,
not particularly physically gifted,
just fucking smart optimus Kamozi I thought he was younger than that while he's
been around.
I think he's 34 34 four 35 but he has a shitload of experience.
Powerful sock.
I tried hair.
It's got sharp hair.
The Denver Water and veto Miranda on his back.
This is not good for the third round.
No made on the Great Jersey.
Kamozi Kamozi clenched down,
cover his face,
stop debrief adding cover his face.
Go for hidden alarm comes from here and compress saddle leather brass.
Congratulations.
That's a lot of look at his skin.
He gets exfoliated with a lot of geeky training.
Are you doing any facial stuff?
I got to get a facial.
Got a g training.
It's going to give myself facials.
I give myself,
Eddie has the best skin here.
Look at his skin.
Beautiful Skin.
Come on.
What are you talking about?
How old you are and you look at our fullest mouth is.
You've had a lot of world.
He had a lot of work done.
Thank you.
If you're serious,
I know
I am.
Maybe you're just being gay with me cause you want to be funny.
Well both but you do look good.
Well thank you.
Randy.
Got Back to his feet and need of the body.
He's exhausted.
Turned on as well.
That helps your hands into the size and then you could probably do anything.
Fine.
Oh
you better not hold me down.
Jesus Miranda taking down.
Still throwing head Kish.
Shoot.
Kamozi Miranda's going for it man.
Oh Shit.
Wrestle him.
This is a frantic fight.
And that's another thing.
Here's another thing to take into consideration.
Time limits,
time limits for rounds.
They impose a different style of fighting because sometimes sense of urgency.
Yeah,
better,
better entertainment.
But are we sacrificing reality for entertainment?
I don't know if I'd make better fights.
I think you,
you got to see under barriers.
No,
under,
uh,
confines and boundaries.
You can still have the same kind of excitement or maybe more excitement.
Listen to me,
but if the goal is fields one 30 minute round,
hey,
come on dude,
this is too much.
No,
I'm a,
I'm a visionary.
A football field.
You throw like trash cans in there and hook.
No,
no,
no.
Homes now looking for reality.
I'm looking for the least amount of variables possible.
And you can pick the weaponry.
It's like an alley.
The stage is an alley and that's the fight is done.
No one,
in reality,
he knows in reality trains for a street fight for six weeks.
We're not talking about reality,
not talking about the purest form of the competition.
Did Frank Mir on our podcast said that he would never,
he just recently started warming up because he considered a fight in the
octagon.
He was looking at it as practice for a real street fight.
Frank Mir is a maniac.
Walks down like an armed fucking weapon.
Yes.
Straight up.
He's a maniac.
Very ready for the,
for the Zombie apocalypse.
He's one concussion away from doing some crazy shit.
I think all of us,
the be money for the gun store.
Frank would be like,
I've been ready.
I've been waiting for this moment my whole life.
Great guys.
The best way to capital Kevin and that's that and I do like as soon as I love
him.
He's a great guy.
I love framework.
Can't have 60 guns on you though.
Yes,
you can flip right.
Even one is,
oh look at this Kamozi with the uppercut and Miranda tries a wheel kick.
This is a crazy fight.
We're missing it.
Frank Mir was the most dangerous man on the planet.
I'd be going nuts right now.
Yeah.
One thing I really worry about that all the years of yelling in the UFC have
strengthened my vocal chords and my vocal cords will get out of shape if I
stopped coming to me now cause you're going to stand or will they blow like
that?
I Dunno,
but the yelling is I'll fucking 100% natural when when fights,
I don't even realize I'm doing it until it's out of my mouth.
So like you've never lost your passion for the,
I dunno
how it is done.
Just keep screaming,
creaming.
Yet even just,
I don't know how many times I've said this,
but just yesterday I did a podcast with nick the tooth.
I did his podcast and I love that dude.
Good guy.
Anytime you come up,
what's happening?
I got more wire to my mom come on.
Used to I,
I lay it on thick like for 10 minutes.
Like how much better of a commentator you are than anybody out there.
I mean,
no one even fucking comes close.
Brian stands good.
Kenny Florian is good.
I like John but there ain't no Rogan out there.
That's very nice.
You can't throw it down like you.
You can't know cause he has personality and you start talking.
When you guys started talking,
talking about UFC,
I feel like I'm a fucking beyond a lower than the amateur marching.
I just let you guys talk a holy Shit.
You guys retain a lot more than I do.
You have seen in my head I don't.
I don't have any kickboxing and like a motherfucker when all you watching this
shit,
how are you watching game of Thrones
doing podcast three times a week.
You got a family and kids you spend a lot of quality time with.
He's part of the Illuminati.
Fuck.
Are you watching kickboxing and boxing the robot because
here's how I look at it.
Do you sleep?
He has some supplement.
We don't know about five.
The option of sleeping eight hours a night and not watching fights or sleeping
six hours a night and watching fights.
I take the six hours.
I watched two hours of sleep.
Is that what you do before you go to sleep?
All the time.
Holy Shit.
I never do that all the time.
I have everything.
Everything's conspiracy theory documentaries.
That's fucking,
that's what you're paranoid and I'm happy
you're out there killing
gigantic
ethical meat acquisition,
sir.
I'm not cookies.
Two hours of fights every night.
No wonder he's killing bears.
Now.
I always want to watch a smaller organizations.
Fuck a wrestler,
a fucking bear wrestler
when they
barely 27 book Kim.
I want the real bare.
It's not even close.
Kamozi powerful.
Kamozi great.
Fucking win.
Very nice.
Um,
you know what man,
I'm attracted to.
Should I just go with what I'm attracted to?
Holy Shit.
I love,
I love watching Moitai they'd been watching a lot of Moitai lately.
He gone waves though.
I go in waves and then I had to do that boxing.
So for like two weeks I was balls deep and boxing,
which is so much fun,
man.
But then I'll take a break from fighting that.
I'm balls deep in cars.
Well Dude,
I know I'm go,
go,
go.
Days watching hours and hours of archery every day.
I wish hour an hour shooting.
Hey Sir.
That's weird.
That's fucking weird.
It is weird.
Until you start shooting things with bows and arrows.
And you realize like you gotta be really good at archery to kill fucking elk and
you're gonna your will.
You miss with a bear.
It's game over Sun.
Joe Rogan.
Brilliant.
I know you're going to be my fucking master to get me to Joe Rogan's fucking,
I'm not doing it for that reason,
but I know how to do it.
Like I can tell you where animals would likely be more than most people will be
my leader.
And you listened to hunting podcast on the winds of Myla for six hours.
Not,
no,
not just listen to honey podcasts.
You look at my podcast like all my podcasts,
it's all like antlers.
All of it is on
your shit.
Started criticizing the lead.
The most powerful apocalyptic grew ever.
I'm going to lead them,
right.
I'm going to read or write to the Yellowstone apocalyptic where the fucking
super volcano is going to blow up.
Like we want to be like right there when it blows.
Guys.
So sorry to interrupt.
Did you get coated Josie far?
I'm just going to keep,
because you got to,
you know,
if you're going to leave,
you still need some tightening lots together,
you know what I mean?
Update you and all that shit.
We need someone to hold pads to any,
any
privates.
Cool.
Listen,
here's the good thing is 400 pounds.
If you kill now we all,
we all going to show you got to commercial freezers back there.
I need to,
I need more flip top dog frozen anymore.
Is it frozen though?
Yeah,
it's frozen.
Solid.
Yeah.
Oh no,
the only one eat it.
I might have some.
Um,
do we have any of the elk?
The summer sausage that's not frozen.
Gentleman were drinking.
I'll be
there.
Just tweeted that.
What may,
whether Connor live on paper view November.
Oh my God.
Check this out.
So serious.
Yes.
Check this out.
Just so I was with the boxing community this past weekend.
This is for real.
This is happening.
Investors,
investors in Mayweather's campus.
When did you find out about it?
Last night?
Investors and Mayweather's camp.
They're like really big in this promotion.
Say it's going to happen and probably November and they don't know shit about
MMA.
Did I go,
do you know Conor McGregor?
I'm like I should slap the fuck out of both of you.
Oh my God.
I think Dannon white.
Matt Serra and nick the tooth just wrote a ball.
Yeah,
they did write a bowl.
Dana is a,
they're going to do stand up on a Sunday night
at the laugh factor.
You're on the show,
right?
I guess how I couldn't be on it.
Um,
cause I'm doing shit.
I'm,
I'm ramping up for my special in a few weeks.
You big.
So uh,
they want me to come in,
I to do Braya no,
I'm doing Bray.
I'm judging him.
Problem two sold out shows.
I'm coming in on Saturday to help them.
I guess it's a good idea.
You're going to help anybody more than anybody else is going to throw anybody
any fucking fake advice.
Why not?
No,
I'll help both.
I think I'm mature.
You Jack Him off for me too.
I would,
I would not want to be in Intel contest of the Matt Serra.
I think Matt Serra is probably going to be really good at standup at Dana
White's probably super used to public speaking and I think nick to tooth does a
lot of drugs so there should be a lot of fun.
Plus nick is like an open minded,
very smart dude.
Definitely smart guy.
Good photographer.
He's one of the best guys ever.
He's a sweetheart.
He's so cool.
He's real smart,
open minded.
He's a really interesting cat electric.
I'm psyched to help you.
Second high purple belt.
He's in tremendous shape.
He's in his forties is my age.
Tremendous shape.
Really careful with his diet.
He's at tight with half a Mendez.
They're like Bros and shit late too that he trains with him.
What is just a nice brothers are so fucking technical.
God Damn it.
I went on to a Jujitsu ramp page like a couple months ago and I watched a lot of
phases.
Watch a lot of a rolling.
I've watched him roll with um,
it was him or guy who rolled with Jake shields where they put a video of it
online.
It was half,
half and half.
It was just,
just,
just impenetrable in penetrable off his back.
And then once he swept Jake and he got his back,
I'm like,
Jesus Christ,
you've seen just this laser satirize shorts,
scalpels,
fucking sharpness of technique.
Fascinating to watch this,
this like small guy.
Not Small,
but I mean in comparison to Jake,
I mean Jakes probably one 90 and a pretty strong stout eighties yeah,
yeah.
High one eighties and maybe Hafez like one 60 right?
What would you walk around?
Fuck,
by the way,
he does Abu Dhabi one 45 same James.
So not a big guy.
He's not a big guy.
Strong black.
A big guy.
Like he have some roles with him and Andre Galvao world class.
I was like 200 pounds,
this world class and us round that off site.
You can't pass out.
They bought bye bye mom.
Bye.
They boom by on that Brazilian beef jerky.
Yeah.
Well,
you know what man?
This is like,
there's this strength that you develop from repetitive technique.
There's like this.
Like if you look at someone's body,
there's a dude like,
here's a perfect example,
Michael McDonald.
Do you know that dude?
Uh,
fights in UFC?
He's 21,
maybe 22 now.
Wicked knockout artists,
man.
Wicked.
But if you looked at his body,
you would never know.
But there's a,
there's a strength in his ability to execute particular.
Yeah,
Bang.
He's just got that groove carved in his,
his synapses and when he unleashes shots,
man,
they just ferocious bombs row and you know,
like here's a perfect example honey.
Ya,
Ya honey.
I is not a big guy,
but that mother fucker gets your neck and he's a fucking school.
Same stores.
These,
they got that squeeze.
Think of Saint George got his dad at like 600 him fucking hiking up mountains
with tires.
Easy Jack.
But there's babies strength.
Like there's like,
no,
not compared to like Randy coming toward Randy couture's gotten timeout going
man.
Fuck you.
Straps
that hold your risk.
I'm going to let you know those young guys just call him or how'd that,
how'd that all fucking all night break Sukarno was also 285 pounds.
But I mean,
it's like there's like some,
some ridiculous like grapple strength that certain do tat for sure.
Shield has a squeeze to be developing in every choke.
It's not just chicken to squeeze in one choke.
Marcello Marcel is a perfect example.
The chrome Gracie from Great Britain,
the shop has that kind of strength,
but Brendan is also a gorilla,
but there's the thing about crone is it crone looks physically imposing.
Like when clone crone doesn't have a shirt off you go.
When he has his shirt off,
rather you look at him,
you go,
well,
that kid is obviously doing something.
He's obviously doing some gymnastics,
but you think it's like,
fuck it.
Oh my God.
Ridiculous.
I saw crone.
There's a video of him doing the shit on Venice beach where he sourced Sanama
where he's swinging and flying to the air and catching the next bar and then
swinging and flying to the and find that Jamie.
He's also a dime piece.
Yeah.
He's also a really good looking guy.
He's also very smart kid.
Yeah.
Runs Chrome Academy there in Culver City.
He's very principled.
Why over here?
Take some pretty big heavyweights and do whatever he wants to.
Okay,
let's let off the gay stuff buddy.
I'm just saying,
here's crone.
Here's crow.
Check this shit out.
Watch this video.
This is in Venice,
but he's,
he does this shit on these bars.
Like look at this.
He's don't worry your soft side.
Why not man?
You can worry.
Sucks,
whatever the fuck you way you want from grace.
Oh Joe Dude.
He is the lineage.
The greatest fighter in the history of Jujitsu.
He's the son so he can put your socks.
He works in gray.
He could wear those Marvin Hagler socks from the fucking
the shit.
He's picking this man
who let them out.
Crohn's.
A bad motherfucker.
You can't wear your stuff.
He's a bad motherfucker.
Fuck yes.
His jujitsu.
The best guys ever.
And here's the thing man,
like his dad is the greatest of all time for sure.
His Dad is like a legit,
like,
like a mystic almost.
His Dad would roll in.
I'll never forget this,
the room full of the baddest dudes
on UFC fighters.
The WHO's who of Jujitsu,
he walks in there.
It was like Blue Fossa
bowed down and shit.
Let me get on a neat,
the one,
the one thing he has the most high level Jujitsu players don't have good light
when they're going to MMA besides a good looks is uh,
uh,
when you're,
when you're talking about just pure Jujitsu,
whether it's gear Nogi,
the full guard is totally optional.
You don't ever need to develop a full guard of,
it's just grappling.
If you ever have someone to full guard and I want to play,
you open it up and then you start playing,
you know,
butterfly guard or whatever.
Oh,
full guard is totally optional.
There's many great jujitsu players that just said,
fuck plan,
full guard.
I'm going to do some other shit.
We're going play open guard della Hiva.
We start opening up and start swinging around.
Never really engage in this full guard dimension that's completely optional.
Geeky or no Gig,
no gay.
If you don't want to play full guard,
if you don't want to develop a full guard,
you don't have to just open up your fucking legs and then just start planning
MMA.
I'm sorry.
Let me just finish this real quick.
But in MMA it's the most important guard.
Full Guard.
It's the most important.
You have to fucking play full guard when a guy is trying to smash your fucking
face and controls.
So now,
so now you're forced to play a card.
You didn't have to play in grappling ever and now an MMA,
but crone is one of those rare Jujitsu guys that in his grappling,
his full guard is his main weapon.
So he gets dudes in full guard.
That's his shit.
If he watches geeky grappling or Nogi grappling,
he wants to get you in full guard.
His Guillotine is among the best.
That's why he's doing good in MMA because in MMA he's forced to play a guard
that he wants to plain rice.
Pardon me,
in front of a ton of people.
Super embarrassing,
super ambitious.
That's got a real rough considering.
He's like,
they were clapping 70 may be enrolled for 25 minutes straight and then we were
like going back forth.
No one tat know what tap can rate from animals and then it just came out of
nowhere.
It everyone standing up.
I was all embarrassed and it's beautiful that he got,
yeah.
Hell yeah.
You got to appreciate it.
You know you're a gorilla.
Yeah.
Hey,
I'm [inaudible] y'all for sure.
He was even [inaudible] 70 he was smaller than that one.
He submitted me.
It's,
it doesn't matter.
One of the most satisfied baskets in the world ever.
One of the most satisfying aspects of Jujitsu is that it's truly one of the only
martial arts where a smaller,
more tactical person can overcome a bigger,
more powerful person Shankar when roles in that motherfucker gorilla.
That's a different girl at [inaudible] so far beyond,
but I guarantee you if he got in there with Fabrizio over doom and they were
just grappling for Breeshia would tap him.
You know it and I know it correct.
100% for [inaudible] here is going to tap them and who is bigger for breezy or
Shane?
Shane's bigger,
but it doesn't Matte Taller.
There's a,
but there's a level,
I guess it gets to a certain level where the technique can overcome massive
physical as well.
Pecking order.
Dude.
It's fucking look our friend Cade,
you know like uh,
Cade is maybe one,
how much does kid way one 35 one maybe one 35 that motherfucker has put me in
danger.
Tanga golf lunch.
At times I'll waste smallest one 35 locked me up and triangles where I'm like,
Oh shit,
I'm going to have to tap to a dude who 70 pounds go ahead and rampage.
Okay,
I could do that.
But he's your friend.
You know it's supposed to do.
But I mean what I'm saying is that his technique that some of them,
like my friend and my friend Danny is lighter than mean Denny.
Denny taps me all the time.
If,
if Denny and I roll right now,
I'm not having rolled in a while,
but if we were rolling,
he would always tag me.
He's better than me.
Cause even though he's smaller than me,
someone's,
he's just a heavy tech people get,
they're just better.
They're just better.
Like Marcello's when I was watching lines up with your weight has anyone else's
style,
oh try this guys.
We can't talk over each.
Sorry.
So try this raw mill as any guys were talking about the nightmare hosted most of
China.
The two tests might change.
She's,
we're on the same diet.
Yeah,
cause I'm not into it.
All right,
sounds good.
I think I'm going to say oh did you didn't hear Kiddo.
Just looking away from you.
I'm thinking about the poor little couch and sitting there and getting it's tits
sucked
bad.
What?
No,
he enjoys that shit.
Otherwise the bill down and joy.
It's like they have to keep them in a state where you're prepared to fight
tonics affidavit.
I love watching.
It was a very good fight.
Rick Story.
Who's got damn gorilla?
Well he's been out for a girl or rip.
Yeah.
Where's Rick Story?
Ben?
It's a long story.
[inaudible]
out of the park.
It was the week
that ball landed in the bed of the
slam dunk.
That bread ball broke the window of a convertible Archie bunker.
It's a long story.
Safa Dean tried to avoid that takedown can only get this fucking cheese on my
face.
You know what I mean?
Is it that good?
It's so good.
You go fuck you.
Cheese.
Those cows in there suck.
Those suck everybody's tits.
Why didn't you,
sorry guys.
Cheese gets me crazy.
Raw Cheese.
Raw Cheese,
I don't pass.
Right.
Did you know they put by Agora in Rochester?
Yes,
I got it at the gas station.
They put that Rhino seven and the final column lag when everything the rhino
color,
not just like sugar,
just putting back
shit.
You got to cut down on your Biafra free food.
We'd come back around people fight,
that'd be Viagara conspiracies huddle by Agri Association bought off Yale
professors to prove that it was a good for longevity and enter properties.
Good for endurance.
And they came up with,
if it was like a blood pressure medication,
something,
what was that?
Because it's illegal to take leave.
It was blood pressure and open up your,
your uh,
capillaries or getting hard on it's illegal taking the Olympics.
Oh yeah.
He has liquid money to get you more about that.
You take fucking Douche shot shots.
Also,
um,
uh,
Propecia was for prostate cancer and they were growing hair and they're like,
what the fuck's going on?
And what it was.
It was a master.
I still hold on,
I am,
don't take it.
It was a cardiovascular thing for it's ability for it to lower blood pressure
that everyone got the right shit.
Yeah,
dude,
that stuff's not good for you.
First of all,
because they took it out and then when I got off and Ari took it and it made
them depressed.
Are He got severely depressed?
His cock you might be.
Maybe you'd be more happy if you weren't on it.
That stuff,
I'm not kidding.
That stuff is very directly to depression because it fucks with your body's
ability to produce hormones.
It,
it suppresses dihydrotestosterone,
which is a derivative of testosterone that causes you to go to balls and that is
a part of your overall system and when you suppress that one aspect of your
system,
it could fuck up your whole end.
Chris was Joe.
He's already like the same thing with steroids.
I don't have to be sad with a lot of hair than happy with no hair.
Okay.
You and I are very different obviously,
but Joe,
don't you think a always the exception?
No super depressed.
No,
because it's a common common side.
Disposed to that.
No,
it's a common side effect.
I'm telling you already gone off that shit and it changed him.
It changed him.
It a nice set of here that might be yanked total dose.
No,
it kept his hair barely.
Just like me.
Kept my hair barely and when I got off of it,
my body felt way better.
I had more endurance.
I was thinking I had chronic fatigue syndrome or something.
I was like,
why am I fucking tired all the time?
It's hard for me to muster up energy to work out.
It was doing it all on willpower.
I got off probation.
My body was like,
it felt 30% better.
I was like,
this is ridiculous.
It's like I've been like on a drug for Brian.
I got off it too.
I was on for a while.
I ran out,
so it's been three months,
but I've dog back on it.
It doesn't make me feel bad at all.
I'm out of the sun about feeling bad.
It's like you still get those bones overall like yeah,
how long are you going to get a 10 years.
Eventually it's got to,
it's got to cause it keeps you,
it keeps your approach smaller.
So yeah,
for dudes you don't come,
you know that's all about dudes.
You don't come.
What's the,
do
you know the jerking off,
just jerking off and having regular sex is the best.
Reduce her prostate cancer.
That's fine.
It's old dude's who's come backs up inside them like old sewage and just stews
up inside.
No worries.
I
think if you took like a bunch of Harry Shits left me your toilet and what that
would do to the pipes.
I hadn't been eating bunnies by the Harris Kaia hairs that are breaking off from
your asshole.
I wax my asshole.
How do you stop
saved my ass hole changes the way my fart sound.
All they clap.
They sound like it's somebody else's fault and I'm like,
who the fuck back?
Then I take a clipper.
Do you actually believe there?
There's guys that are getting to a certain age and they just stopped jacking off
depression.
A lot of guys lose their testosterone and you can't gather guys dead.
Hundred percent
I can't.
Well it's some days I need to,
here's the thing,
everybody fucking Jack Cause I saw something weird way more than they should.
Well this is something we know
this slow drawn out.
Oh,
not to keep up with.
I was like,
we need to stop.
Stop,
stop to start a movement,
hand Hashtag and jerking off or or,
or slow in maintenance,
man.
It keeps your body healthy to get hurt.
Slowed down his neck.
Maybe not end.
It does.
Slow it down.
No,
I think they can't slow it down.
Everyone's all aggressive.
Slowed down just a little bit.
Powerful Terex afternoon that Brendan,
just half the names of a rough man.
He needs to,
it needs maintenance.
I'm not that crazy.
Listen,
when you have,
first of all,
Eddie,
you and I can't talk about him because he's got gladiator jeans.
Look at his body.
Bodies like that are meant to come.
He's the most to me all over the land.
Oh,
I got a half a Chubby,
which I'll tell you like six,
five,
six,
four,
four natural to 40.
Just shut the fuck up.
Everybody got to come a lot.
But it's true.
You don't want to run to the street.
Gulf cocking your neighbors.
Give me a child.
Let him see.
Sure.
There last night to tell girls,
take my wife.
I want to raise my,
I want to raise your child.
Listen to Rogan.
I got to come.
Don't be fucking calm to look at stuff.
A Dean with story on his back.
That's crazy.
Safa Dean took story down.
Sabba didn't trains with guys like Henderson.
Yeah,
well that's who we went to when he first started.
Uh,
getting into the MMA game.
Fuck it.
You can go to her and Olympic wrestler figuring out how to stop this bullshit.
Good clinicians.
That black house a lot too.
Oh yeah.
Warren.
Well,
you know that fight with Nate Marquardt was a fucking excellent example of a guy
who's got just like super fucking high level.
He
tactical striking.
Nate was trying to eat it for a while and then when you eat a few of those you
like,
you were like,
oh my God,
I'm stuck in a pattern.
And then you got to take yourself out of the pattern.
Right?
We got to break yourself out.
Well,
you can't go against a high level Bob kickbox like this and go,
I'm just going chuck them all night.
Let me ask you this.
If you ever had a fight where you went into it and you were too relaxed,
you were too confident.
You asking me,
Roy Nelson,
fight the teacher,
big knock fight way to relax.
That's a bad place to be.
It's like everybody wants to be super confident,
but you don't want to be too confident,
obviously.
Um,
it's just,
it's,
I mean it's,
it varies with person to person from instance to instance.
But I would think that you're almost better off being fucking terrified and
dealing with all the horrible feeling.
Because I remember the taekwondo days whenever I felt like too good about things
I didn't find,
never went good.
I fought like clumsy and I was too aware of what I was doing instead of being
instinctive and,
and like real fast twitch and sharp terrified.
Yeah,
I hear Ya.
But,
but nobody wants to deal with that feeling that all,
all the day of the way ends the day of the fucking,
but it's also what makes,
makes you great and it's also what makes the experience of being victorious so
powerful.
When you see a guy like chocolate Dell run around the cage and throw his arms
when he would roar,
like when he knocked out Tito or when he knocked out,
Bob on board did the same shit exactly.
Like you've got to realize that feeling doesn't just come from victory.
That feeling comes from all that turmoil and that did the fucking who knows
what's going to happen.
It comes from when it comes to chuck and he knew how much bigger that picture,
Goddamn,
look at chocolate has the best picture in UFC history.
Those trunks he's got,
you know how much pussy this is going to get me?
That's the truth.
Hey Joe.
But he was an animal,
but just as good as the winds are.
When you're that scared,
when you do lose,
when you're like,
yeah,
what's what's can happen,
you lose the worst way.
Those same fears,
you're like,
fuck going through that man.
Fuck that.
Because you don't get the same pay off.
There's some extent.
There's certainly that as well.
There's certainly that as well and there's lows are low and the highs are high.
It's also guys where you start realizing the lows are coming repeatedly and it
doesn't seem like there's an escape for them and you've got to realize what are
the consequences of these lows.
They're permanent like a really smart guy like Mac Dansik,
like when Mac Danzig decided to retire,
he was like,
that's a smart dude.
He should've done it before.
That may be,
but it's hard to see when you're inside of it.
Very few people,
me included can see themselves as well as other people can see you because we
all have a certain amount of protective layers of ego and of narcissism,
professional fighter.
If anybody,
anybody that's trying to do good at anything and anything you,
you have to have a certain amount of self esteem and ego in order to pursue that
goal because otherwise for sure for sure,
but most,
most also,
most likely their motivation for getting in the first place is they had really
low self esteem at one point in time in life and fighting showed them the way
out.
Correct fight.
There's so many fighters come from abusive backgrounds stepfathers that were
assholes and all that shit.
Oh Shit.
[inaudible] with the fucking question mark kick over there said,
oh,
that was story storyland to that kid.
No,
he didn't.
He didn't know Safdie did.
And then he turned him.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Which one was showing crazy?
Am I right?
Who's going crazy?
I don't know.
Fucking cheese.
There's,
again,
it's both.
I'm going with the wine and the wheat cheese.
Since 2008,
uh,
Uconn has turned down.
We got through four bottles.
We get loose tonight.
Do we have to reimburse you for this now?
And you know,
wireless Callan Eg throwing 200 bucks,
we'll call calling even know.
Biggest probably crossed a to man.
Listen,
man count.
And you still haven't shot your bow once I did it,
I keep asking him,
I got to come over and you definitely don't keep my ticket.
I do occasionally throw it out there.
You don't get specific at all and you don't get proactive even slightly.
I need to start,
keep texting.
You have a serious talk right now.
Let's be honest.
Be Honest about how much you've I,
this is one of the things I decided because you kept telling me that you wanted
to do archery and you wanted to get into bow hunting.
So I said,
okay.
What I'm gonna do is I'm going to give Brian a bow and now I'm going to let,
we'll see how proactive he gets with this.
And uh,
it really hasn't panned out.
Give you a nice job.
Let's not a hunter.
Yes,
I am a hunter.
You're wrong.
I've seen Brian kill animals.
Yes,
I seen Brian Kill and butchered deal.
Now Brian,
Brian is a good shot.
He's a fucking calm dude.
Under pressure as good at it.
Doesn't mean he likes it.
Brian's crazy as fuck.
And I love him to death,
but that dude stays calm on the trigger.
Let me tell you something.
If I needed somebody to shoot for me,
all your friends,
one of my number one picks out of a guy who keeping,
you only get one cause he's so fucking crazy.
He can keep it together under pressure.
That's Brian Cowen can fucking there.
They could be a armies running and Brian's direction.
I guarantee Brian,
we'll shoot as good as he as he would if there was no one was.
There's no doubt about that because I've been going through that my whole life
in my head.
He's crazy.
In a weird way.
He's a smiling guy that knows how to shoot.
Yeah,
that's true.
In a weird way.
Now let's look at me.
I'm hungry right now,
coming over us and Wisconsin.
I'm coming.
That's Bible.
That's the dude we met in,
does a great job during is one of the best human beings has ever walked the face
of the planet,
a great meal.
He said his wife,
he's a gem of a person.
You know his wife drew,
she,
she's a painter.
She was like,
how beautiful is this painting?
It's a painting of him on the cell phone like this.
She goes,
cause this is how we have dinner.
He's like this looking at his phone.
Powerful first light.
How much longer we have here.
We were laughing so hard.
How beautiful is my firstlight?
Cammo.
Aww,
that's beautiful.
Yeah.
We were talking about shit on a stick.
There's a,
there's a mold that looks like shit.
We barely pay attention to any of these fights.
Meanwhile,
Rick Story and Terex half and he had been going to war and we're like those
assholes and the fucking first row,
they're drunk.
They're fairly pitch tie
to it.
I swear to God,
you're going to show another dimension.
There needs to be a vegan hunting show where they get a Vegan that goes out in
the wild.
I'm coming in this week.
I want to see me crying on to me.
I'm coming in this week,
the hunt for wild edible plants.
What about terrible idea
for wild edible plants?
Well,
I think there's going to be sure.
I'm not going to be a real problem soon with plant intelligence,
whether they're understanding things about the way plants communicate with each
other,
they're not much different than look octopus,
it's really super arguable that we probably shouldn't need octopus because
octopus are smart as shit.
They can read your facial expressions right?
That well not only that,
they communicate through the texture of their skin.
They can kill,
they have ink that they blast in front of things so they can get the fuck away.
See Ya.
They're really complex.
Many times I'm a freak out guys.
We can't talk over each.
All don't,
I'm sorry someone has to just back off.
You got this Eddie.
I was just wondering if octopus was like spinach.
What do you mean?
Cause you're saying you,
there's a real good argument between the plant life and hell.
Smarter plan is,
I'm good.
I'll get really weird.
No,
I'm good.
Doug,
don't talking about spinach and AUC.
Do you want to be a podcast or just certain things.
If you want to be willing to get so high you say stupid shit be with us.
He will watch this bro.
So what were you saying?
Gosh,
to buses and spinach.
Oh,
well,
you were saying there's a real argument about plant life.
How smart they are.
Cause Vegan sale.
Well,
we plants,
right?
Well the,
yeah.
the argument is that we're starting to understand that plants communicate with
each other and very strange way.
Don't eat octopus.
They have more genes than you.
Dude,
I love it.
Nice on the Guardian.
Whoa.
Taste delicious.
No,
no.
Not to eat.
Apparently much friends,
plants,
we have those chickens.
His friends.
I'd like octopuses friends plants react and don't show it,
but the same way they do calculations.
Here's what's weird about plants.
They do calculations and they communicate with each other than it's weird way.
Like,
here's a perfect example.
And acacia tree,
if an Acacia tree is upwind or uh,
yeah,
it's up.
When the animals eat it,
like a giraffe eats it,
the wind goes down and the wind goes down,
hits the other case,
you trees.
And they changed the way they taste.
What they become bitter.
We fact there's a problem with animals that are downwind of a constant breeds
where they literally could starve to death because they won't eat their
preferred food because it tastes bad or reason to those plants up.
How about that?
Yeah.
It's a weird communication going on also with the ground itself because we look
at the ground as being just dirt,
but it's not.
It's full of arts and ecosystems.
It's filled with all sorts of different things and most importantly it's,
here's a big factor,
decomposing plant and animal material,
which gets absorbed into the ground.
Like when you eat plant food,
when you plant like vegetables and then you have to add soy,
you have to add minerals to the soil,
you have to add fertilizer to the soil.
Right.
For most lance,
because we've depleted the minerals in the soil,
but when you go to the woods,
no one's adding shit.
Okay.
What's happening is things are decomposing the recycling animals are decomposing
bodies or all sorts of things that are left behind are composing.
Yeah.
I mean it's,
it's legitimately what it is.
And plants need that as much as they need water.
There's like this constant thing going on.
So without animal life and animal life dying,
these plants are not going to exist like this day and their existing eating this
weird fucking ground and then water and then they're breathing in oxygen and
spitting or breathing in carbon dioxide and spitting out oxygen.
How about some Venus fly trap?
Oh yeah.
The things,
hey man,
that's a plant.
How about,
how about the one in the Amazon eats rats.
God does a plant that plant that each rock off.
Jamie,
Jamie.
We played this a dozen times.
There's a fucking plant in the Amazon that honey Dick's rat on a out to fall
inside of it and it closes up on it.
It's this fat crazy.
Look at this.
Come on.
Just sweat this.
Sweat this whole watch.
What happens.
Oh,
that's a wrap.
Sweden there.
Exactly.
It's sweet and it's slippery.
And this mouses Foxville now that mouse is not getting out.
Never.
They get eaten.
Well that's a Venus fly trap.
Oh c'mon.
C'Mon flies.
They so get that rat go down that hole and never come back.
Yeah.
Ted's on the rep went to red heaven,
which show that mad when we know it's like the little shop of horrors.
How do we know?
I don't know about that.
What are you talking about?
This fucking
bullshit.
That is bullshit.
What does propaganda fuck?
What is this Jamie?
Y'All fucking laugh.
Jamie.
What is this?
What is it eating?
You can't see shit.
That's hard to see.
It's a weird photo.
Oh,
I see.
The rat is stuck in there and he's like,
Oh snap.
It's over.
That's a little rat.
Fuck.
Why the fuck is the plant eating rats though?
Because
look,
he gets nutrients from it.
The same way it gets.
Nutrients are decomposing plainly grab animal matter gets into the ground.
Fucking plan.
What I was going to say,
it's all of the fertilizer that we use today,
either as it as it has to have nitrogen in it cause that's like one of the key
components,
but a lot of like what it is like,
especially when people make compost,
that's like the best.
When people throw their food waste in and then they throw worms and leaves and
everything sort of decomposes.
Yeah,
that's stuff.
Decomposes it and you can use that in your garden and that's like one of the
best ways of sort of replenishing nutrients in the soil.
You do that shit when you're hanging out with a chick stories.
There's one.
Yes.
I compost.
I grow.
I grow vegetables in the hangout with chickens,
but it makes me happy.
Makes me happy.
When I eat a salad,
when I eat like a some tomatoes that I grew,
it makes me happy,
so it makes me feel good.
It feels good.
It was.
It's a weird way.
It's cool,
man.
The patient makes me feel good.
It's a fun.
It's one of those things that I think a is like,
have you ever caught fish before?
No.
Yeah.
When you catch a fish,
oh shit.
Oh Shit.
You get excited.
Apparently.
There's also a similar reaction to people that are,
if you're a a a bug collector,
like a moth collector,
or not my friend,
but a flashlight.
I don't have any friends that do that.
There's something because human beings for a long period of time where
apparently insectivores Rick story won that fight.
A bear.
That's outrageous.
We do that.
What does that Jamie and horseback Ddo snake.
Oh,
chicken.
Chicken.
Oh my God.
Let it roll.
It eats a chick.
He consumes it that it's crazy.
A horse.
Just check.
Fuck with those teeth.
Wow.
Squished him like a Cabernet.
Oh No.
We were brainwashed to believe that we're herbivores.
Well,
they are for the most part,
but when they get a chance to eat checks,
what does hate chickadee move the fuck out of the way.
Wow.
That's,
that's like the smart chicken jump baby chicken.
I can't run away to a smart one.
It's a little ground graphs.
That's crazy,
isn't it?
Where'd you find that?
I forget where I saw it,
but I just makes me sick.
Oh my God.
Have you ever seen deer chase birds and eat them?
What the fuck?
No,
that,
yeah.
Deer eat birds regularly.
Not only that,
there is a fence that was put up and uh,
it was one of these weird,
a nettings and a bird's got stuck in the netting and deer were eating the birds
out of the netting.
Some evil as dare the Burgess.
He couldn't differentiate between the whole and the string.
And they ran right into it and got stuck on it.
And the birds,
the deer just aid them and they just needed the protein or something.
They don't give a fuck about birds.
That's what's really going on.
They're not Bambi.
It just looks like we have a real problem in this country.
In Disney's fucked our brains for the time we were babies.
I love it.
They're juicy.
Knows friendly.
That's,
I can't hunt them.
Yeah.
You gotta get over that post here.
Nah Man,
I'm trying to kill bears.
Doug.
I'll call what you do to they beers.
B e a or,
and we'd on this.
What did you mean?
I don't even know.
What do you say bears are?
Beers.
You know the grizzly crime.
Oh,
I thought you meant just for the narrow.
Do I need a gun?
Okay,
hold on.
No problem.
You'll set it up 100%.
Tell me why you set it up with a offer,
bro.
We're in.
Okay.
This is what we do.
A Hunter's done.
Here's what we do.
Peer pressure.
Do an August.
Bear hunt with rifle.
Fuck the three of us.
You guys,
you put these can use a rifle.
I'm gonna use a bow.
Listen,
you have a rifle I could buy,
although this week I'm coming over to,
I got to keep both,
borrow my rifles.
I'm coming over that goddamn armory and a machine gun.
I got a lot of shit.
I'll use that.
A lot of problems in my head
and I'm ready.
I'm ready.
I'm so ready.
You and Tim.
Kenny,
just Remy and Tim.
Ken nothin's,
everyday friends.
Uh,
but um,
this,
um,
this camp that we would go to in Alberta,
my friend John and Jen Rivet,
they're fucking awesome human beings and it places amazing and they have GI and
what kind of beers and here's the thing.
No,
but black bears and they,
there's grizzlies up there too.
I saw a Grizzly,
not where we were hunting,
but near it,
on the,
on the weight I saw links.
I saw many,
many Moose.
Mule deer all kill you,
right?
Yeah.
So I'm in,
well you got to do them during certain times when we're in the bear time.
And here's the thing about bears,
it's like it actually does help the population because they eat babies,
they eat cubs.
If you kill the big boars,
it actually is good for the popular.
So I need to hear it sounds counter intuitive.
That's all we need.
As long as I have a reason that I'll do it,
I'm doing conservation as well.
It,
it's,
it's a side effect of hunting.
But here's one thing that my friend Ben O'brian pointed this out this weekend.
He's a good buddy of mine.
I used to write for a Peterson's,
uh,
hunting magazine.
He's a super intelligent guy and he came hunting with us.
And one of the things that he said is it like honey as a con.
Conservation is a side effect of hunting.
And until we're honest about that,
people are going to always have this argument against us or against people that
hunt because like people like to say that hunting is conservation.
It is,
but it's a side effect of honey.
Like you,
you really want to hunt because you want meat.
Yeah.
Not trying.
Yeah,
but then there's people that don't and they don't really even really want me.
I knew a dude who used to hunt all the time.
He hated wild game and he hunted concerts to kill beef.
He's just,
he likes to kill.
He enjoyed,
he didn't,
he was a real problem dude.
He had a,
he's got,
he's got other,
but there's something about hunting horses.
There's something about hunting.
When you wake up in the middle of nowhere and you're walking through like in
Alaska,
there is something very primordial and very interesting about like not knowing
what you're going to see around the next corner.
Well,
when you and I,
we did that.
That island in Alaska is one of my,
two of my favorite times as a human being is when we were in Montana and when we
were in Alaska and we laughed.
So fucking hot and miserable.
Yes.
Kill anything.
Well,
we did.
We both did,
but in Alaska and neither one of us did.
Joe,
how long would the bear humpy?
Well,
the bear on I just did,
but was three days of hunting.
I can do one day of travel on each end,
so it was a five day hunt and I was unsuccessful with my friend Cameron Hanes.
Shout,
a seven foot eight bear.
Take telling you guys about it.
We ate that bear by the way,
and it's fucking delicious.
What about the rug and you going to make a rug from home?
We're going to use every aspect for the rug.
No,
no.
We'll use every aspect of the bear,
but the thing about bears is they do two things.
One,
they eat cubs like all of them,
100% of them mechanical.
That's all I needed to hit all come out.
Not only they come out of hibernation,
they come into hibernation.
Looking to get a cub stone cold cause cubs are easy.
So they go into dance because the females tend to sleep laters in the later than
the males.
And it's something that's set up because nature knows they don't have any
predator.
This is nature's or like a complex but really efficient system and nature
realize that there's these things are bears.
Nothing can fuck with them other than them.
So what it did is it made the men cannibals where it's very different from
wolves.
See Wolves.
You could,
a wolf could have a battle and get killed by a mountain lions.
There's videos online of wolves getting killed by a mountain lion.
A really recent one that Jamie and I played the other day of a mountain lion
killing a [inaudible] where the guy that was light on it mount.
Yes,
exactly.
You've seen it.
It's crazy.
Mountain lions are just way more gangster than wolves.
Wolves can suck mountain lines.
Dick was a mountain lion is like Kevin Randleman is prime and a wolf is like a
14 year old girl in a fucking mic.
Dojo karate class.
That's my favorite analogy of all time.
But there's a mountain lion eating a wolf.
He's just killing a wolf would his fucking face.
Well,
cats are just as the cats are as gangster gangsters.
Any animal that's ever lived,
they kill crocodiles in the Amazon.
The tiger killed.
But surely you've seen.
But if you surely seen these,
a jaguars killed crocodiles.
No,
I've only seen any top tiger.
Do it please.
Jack Joe Jaguar,
Haman in the,
he's kind of love for this face.
Cats are so gangster.
No fucking around moving.
He's not freaking out.
He's barely breathing.
He's just slowly killing that wall,
by the way.
Some,
by the way,
the Puma Puma.
And that's what you're looking at.
The Boma is considered the most athletic of all cats.
Yes,
you're correct.
So a house cat,
by the way,
they say if a house cat was as big as a house cat and be running shit,
yes.
It'd be neat to not a cat guy.
Man.
I'm allergic to cats.
I know.
It's weird.
The one thing I don't like about level,
never,
never had a cat cat.
I love them and I trust him to cats.
You know what?
You know what man is,
I got to appreciate about cats.
No.
Hold on.
Watch this.
Watch this Jaguar.
Sneak up on a crocodile jog.
Jacked that mother fucker.
He eats crocodiles.
Suck it.
Fuck yeah.
I'll look at the cre.
Don't fuck with Jak.
Two guys don't know shit.
Jags are no joke.
Oh my God,
they're about 250 pounds by those so scared.
But this whole swayed me towards liking cath cause you can't be like,
oh my house cat.
So like this,
watch our water.
Their water crackles,
swims out their water.
Babe.
When he's out to this little fucking island and the Jaguars,
you big lizard wizard creeping through the water and super slow.
Watch this shit.
Fuck over here.
He carries them off.
Yay.
Carries carries.
Like you would carry a roll of toilet paper.
I look at it through the water.
God,
we can't show this house.
You can't show what duty grabs and contracts and back in the day he knows
the homeys.
He controls that body so well.
They just swims across the God damn ready.
If you got a 10 year old boy in a headlock,
do you think you'd be worried about swimming with them?
It could be a problem.
That can be a problem,
dude.
Those fucking Jaguars are so gangster,
super gangs.
They're so gangster.
I ask or do that.
So with bears,
because they don't have natural predators,
they've nature is developed this,
this really dark,
dark system where the males eat,
the bait has,
so the struggle is constantly the males try and eat other babies in order to
bring the woman back,
the female parents back into estrous so he can meet with her and pass on his own
genetics.
And just the fact that it's hard to come by protein because they run fairly
quick,
but they don't run as quick as deer.
So the only deer they get to eat realistically or the babies or the injured
ones,
mostly Fonz.
So they say that bear in Alberta eat 50% of all moose calves and deer.
Fox got to kill him when we were,
when we were in a Alaska,
we saw a female bear with her cub and I came out with what yon?
What was his name?
You tell us.
Said that probably what was going on with she was keeping him in the highlands.
Is Her,
her baby away from the males?
Yeah,
because she was keeping them up high way too late in the season just to try to
protect his life because the males eat them and then you say mother nature's a
motherfucker.
That's what you're saying,
mother nature a fucker.
Well,
what I'm saying is that people who love animals,
the sentiment is beautiful,
but when you,
when you really try to let all your predisposed or your preconceived notions or
morphic this,
then there's a little of that putting given the us.
It's not just anthropomorphic,
it's also even little love of actual animals that are in your environment that
are not trying to eat you like squirrels and birds and dogs and cats and pets
that you and I both have,
we both love,
but there's a big goddamn difference between all of those things.
And then the wild itself,
which is this weird system.
Yeah,
and it's weird system.
Wildlife Biologists have studied this weird system over decades and they've
concluded that there's some benefit to removing certain dominant males from the
equation.
And that's what you hunt.
Right.
And that's intended about Rhino,
you know?
Yeah.
What's it,
well that's one of the reasons why that Cory Knowlton guy got off the hook,
whereas the,
the,
the lion killer killer didn't.
Yes.
They were going to kill that rhino anyway.
Cause that rhino was killing other male rhinos.
Yeah.
So Corey,
in spending $250,000 plus two to bid on killing that rhino,
rhino fed like a hundred fucking families.
Yes.
Not only did he feed a hundred families,
he gave $250,000 to conservation to protect the rhinos and killed a rhino.
They were going to have to kill it.
Yes.
Which helps out the rhinos.
It helps out the wrong,
but it's so complicated because you would think that if you love rhinos,
the last thing we'd want to some dude paying money to kill a rhino,
you'd be like,
that's ridiculous.
That's just the education.
But when you say hunting takes out the big males that kill all these,
that's what you hunt.
How do,
how can you tell the difference?
Just size.
That's what it 100%.
You tell by size.
I tell by smell.
Well,
Brian is what's called game.
I came by and came knows you fucks.
Meanwhile,
hem browse about to fight.
Jeremy Stevens,
the Goddamn Co main event.
My Hana Barrao is,
I'll see.
I like saying the obvious things like this guy's Hannah Brown was a good
fighter.
That's what I say when I work.
This is,
I gotta be honest with you.
This is the number one argument from me never doing commentary again.
You get Pi this fast.
It's like a best for hammers where balls,
I'm going to say something really.
I'm going to say something really cheesy.
I had an overwhelming feeling of kinship for all my friends here.
I know it's Cheesy,
but I love all you guys.
Dude.
There's a million.
I'm not drunk.
I'm just saying that it's the one in a million people,
more than a million human beings is going to listen to this and feel the same
way.
There you go.
Jeremy Stevens at and browse a motherfucker of a fight because Jeremy Stephens
is ready to throw bombs.
Super Confident and Hanan Barao first time in one 45 not knowing exactly how
he's going to do it,
gets one of the best knockout strikers in this division under browse more sales.
He's more skilled.
Hey,
don't say that.
No Hennen browse a guy who will trade and take shots.
Can you Kenny take a shot from Germany stealing the question?
He can
max out at one 55 guys.
Chip dos Anjos exactly with a ruthless uppercuts.
Jeremy Stevens is no joke.
Probably the hardest hit about 45 he's one of easy and it's kind of a cracker
costs,
I guess you've forgotten about the harsh mocks or let me tell you something,
Connor verses this guy,
Jeremy Stevens versus Connor would be fucking chaos and don't be surprised if
Jeremy Stevens wins.
There's your fight.
If,
oh,
it's this.
My God,
I think I was going to be Jeremy Stephens.
Shut the fuck.
No idea what's going to happen.
Neither do I can fight.
I'm ready Brian.
No one knows what's going to happen.
I know exactly.
There's,
oh,
we just tagged them.
The straight right guys keeping his head down and correct.
Hit behind the ear or not a good place.
Stevens.
That's all.
It's not an auction,
but somebody started singing.
I'm up.
Correct.
Hid behind the here.
There's very few things going wrong.
I'm allowed to be obnoxious about it.
Other than calling.
You're my man.
Oh,
I told,
taught by Borow every time you get them.
I told you Jeremy Stevens had like a brick mine like a bit both by that left.
He got tagged.
Cow Looks Good.
Browse,
browse,
looks great.
Have we forgotten how good morale as well.
He was without a doubt,
one of the best in the world at one 35 and I think it's better for him at one 42
much of a piece for him to cut.
They said they said it always killed him.
So you know he might be a monster at 45 how about him verse all at four Oh five
all we know where he would never do.
They train them to be surprised.
I don't want them to,
I don't want friends to fight.
I really don't.
I don't like it.
I'd be down for Tj,
like it's kind of fun.
Oh,
Barao with the take down.
I feel like it's kind of fun that there's sacred things.
I feel like it's kind of fun that some people just won't check.
She and those guys think it's fun though.
I don't care what they think I know,
but they make the match of stuff.
I don't care.
But my personal opinion,
I mean,
listen,
I call it,
you know what?
I love every matchup I call every match up with with love.
I love them all,
but I don't personally,
I know a lot of these guys,
I don't want to seen them fight there,
but if Hennen Browne,
all those fighting,
you got to call it,
you ain't shit in less.
This is what I want to say.
Unless they want to fight their friends and they think it's okay.
Like,
oh,
[inaudible] Pena.
Julianna Pena is very close with Misha Tate.
And apparently Julianna Pena said I would fight her for the title and if she
wins her next fight and I expect her to win,
I'll fight it for the title.
Oh,
so you're cool.
And they're cool with it?
Yeah,
because they're both cool with it.
Apparently they realize it's business that's life changing and they'll,
and they'll go back to being friends and being cool with each other.
I,
where's Tim Kennedy and why is he not fire?
Jim?
Tim Kennedy is still serving.
Oh,
Tim Kennedy is still involved in multiple things.
You can't talk about it,
but he's also trying to get a fight.
Yeah.
And they haven't given him mad and he would take a fight again.
And you know there's,
there's a legit problem,
I don't want to start any noise,
but Tim Kennedy is a very vocal critic of all sorts of different things.
You listen,
Tim Kennedy is a legit war hero and you,
you,
you can't get legit war heroes to play games now.
But also when they speak,
you speak,
it matters.
You know what I'm saying?
He's,
he's a critical thinker.
He's not a hater.
He's a critical thinker.
Nice level.
He is.
And at the,
at the highest level,
every,
every sport,
every endeavor,
every application in your own,
your own creativity and your own ideals.
But whatever you're trying to pursue in this life should be done to the highest
level.
So all criticism should be taken into consideration,
whether it's valid or invalid.
And a guy like Tim Kennedy,
I think is an important voice.
He's an important voice cause he's a legit human being.
I mean,
he's a,
is legit as a man gets
humid American in the fucking UFC for what he does.
He's one of them for sure.
Everyone falls short and they should.
They should.
He's legit.
I mean,
I've legit like massive respect,
fair minded guy and he's a smart dude and you know it.
You need people like that,
man.
Don't think you don't.
Cause there's people like that and the other side,
it's people like that in the world.
And the ideally,
yes,
we would all love peace and love,
but occasionally you have to deal with assholes and often you have to realize
that there's religious zealots and crazy people [inaudible] women about isis and
see how nice people are,
but just how badly they'd love to have a guy like fucking tenders.
All throughout history,
man.
Would you say about Isis?
Well,
the Yazidi's what they did to that community and Iraq,
the Yazidi women were always considered the most beautiful women.
They had fair hair,
blue eyes.
He arrives.
I'm not hearing great hair and big tits.
I don't even know what the fuck you're saying.
It's not serious
beauty.
What a moment mentee white skin where you could see your whole hand print when
you spank them.
Hey man,
did you say,
hey bro,
sir,
I did not say Iranian chicks,
but if you didn't say that all,
I'm really cute.
I don't understand what you're saying.
That part of the wall has done some of the most beautiful women on the planet
and lighting on wire a paper with red nail Polish.
Did you just say that?
Oh,
I didn't say that.
Sorry.
And asked to,
to waist ratio.
Yes.
That's always a very believes a man like a sports as to waist ratio.
What is that?
That that'll kill you.
That'll stop it man.
And His fucking,
that'll ruin your whole life.
A buddy of mine was telling me about his girlfriend does,
girl relativity was dating and they,
you know,
they got to know each other,
went out a few times and one day they went back to her place and uh,
she,
her waist was too big and it freaked him out.
It's a prompt.
It's fuck,
fuck with them.
He's like,
she's really cool,
but her waist was too thick.
I was like,
what's it been a ladies man?
I know.
Well,
she wasn't even,
I guess so.
It must have been,
but she wasn't even overweight.
It's just like he didn't like to her dementia.
I've had that situation.
I had a girl take her clothes off.
Hold on,
hold on.
What happened?
I said I had a girl take her clothes off.
She had a hairy ass.
I've talked about it before.
She was blowing her asshole.
No,
I'm sorry.
She had a ducktail her cheeks she had,
she had,
she had black hairs on her rump.
Like our Lawsky.
Yup.
And guess what I did?
I faked a stomach ache.
I would have fucked her like she was a female where?
Well after I came I picked her stuff like,
Hey,
I got me
fucked her.
Like I was trying to make her evolve.
I was trying to help her bring her up.
Pass the Paleolithic.
When you're younger you don't give a fuck around.
Dumped some caveman loads
just here all over ass cheeks.
Yup,
that's right for my friend.
And she had a white girl.
I didn't mind that,
but she had a huge Dick.
Literally breath tastes like a lot of common,
a lot of comm.
Nay.
She was a white girl B and she had a big beard,
but she's a great girl.
Other than that,
she was a pretty pretty girl.
He didn't get past the Dick and then the beer now.
I thought she was fucking a wonderful girl.
Bad mouth her,
but I couldn't.
We only did it for like six months.
Tops had smelly feet too.
Yeah.
It's a matter of feet and she wore diapers.
Jab.
You look at his ship.
An animated cartoon of Joey.
Oh,
he just got caught.
That's what Henry just got caught in a Chen got do this and and brow got right
channels.
Can we cut son?
There's nother one.
Stephen's really needs to work on.
Oh,
browse and trouble.
He's in trouble.
He was wobbly before.
Stan is still in front of them too,
man.
He's got to move.
Jeremy is going to time him.
He's head just got tagged.
We'll browse.
Looking to fire back.
Maybe it's not as hers.
We think he's,
he's actually,
he's playing.
He's playing like he's on Queer Street.
He'd come over the top three definitely got hurt,
but you got to think this dude is a Nova Uniao fighter and one of the things
about those training camps and Nolan Yao,
those guys go to war or stop.
They stopped all the pressure.
Boy,
that's hard to believe now.
Yeah,
that's their style,
right?
It's what your culture
is established.
He's a strong fund at 55 well he fought a 55 and really struggles to get down to
45 was Barao was fighting at 35 and struggled there and it's more comfortable at
45 so Steven's a thicker bone character.
Yes.
I think.
I believe he's an inch taller too.
It looks at how we,
it's fine.
The height and weight are these guys.
Yeah.
Jamie.
Jamie,
please.
Shaming please.
Jamie,
what does it say?
Height 71 seven that was quite a five six and five nine this is a big
difference.
What is this?
59 inches?
First is not five six 60 69 inches.
Fucking in his gut.
Ooh,
that's rough.
That's five.
Seven that's five six isn't it?
(609) 595-6960 six is five six.
That's why I said is five feelings.
Like he's admitted Hixon Gracie AB workout,
any of sucking it up pretty fast.
He got 69 is five nine,
right?
Because 12 inch and five six and five nine and then 66 so,
okay.
Five,
nine and five six.
But when you look at them and in Borow doesn't look that much shorter than him.
It just,
he looks like more slender and not as like thick,
like definitely
hard when you're bending at the knees and moving.
Correct.
Thick is Grau has a wider stance.
Ooh,
backache.
My vision is getting so shitty that it's hard for me to tell what that blown up
we're getting all of us,
whether it says 69 inches or five foot nine.
I mean,
I have beautiful eyes.
It's like just at that point where the six is blurry,
even as big as it is.
Hampson so depressing.
So you'll wear glasses?
I bread them only when I read things.
What about the laser show clothes?
And that's no good.
It's,
but it's only good for certain types of,
um,
Connie's well issues with your,
your,
um,
your retina.
So
you're traveling long distances now.
Much more.
It's close distances,
but even long distance,
not so hot.
I have no problem with long closer if,
no,
I still probably have pretty good vision.
Like I see you crystal clear.
I see you a Christian.
I can read it,
but it's,
it's,
there's a,
there's a certain amount of aura to the numbers.
He said,
not clear.
It's like say sick gave it to me on lights.
I'll put these glasses on and Bam and money.
It's crystal.
So just wear those like Malcolm X.
Okay.
Like man,
just shit.
No,
that's your shit.
Now they get in the way that my contacts off for good and fuck the contacts.
I would just want to cook glasses this year for sure.
Feel lucky.
I don't have the money to do lasik eventually.
But your problem with lasix is like Kathy Griffin and a real issue with it.
Apparently she's the Brown.
He's a crisp.
Ben Wa have lasik.
Right.
And Brown wouldn't say town,
but Jeremy Steals.
Oh boy.
I'll look and take that back.
Don't kid yourself.
Jeremy Stevens passed his seat.
Where are you at this bigger Stevens is also a training partner for Dominick.
Cruz is training at alliance.
I mean,
he's down there with l Eric Dolphy Futuro.
One of the most underrated coaches in the world.
Mountain Matt.
Yeah.
Melanzane went to black house,
didn't he?
Uh,
he goes to both.
I remember.
Oh,
he goes back.
He was there forever.
Maybe he is that black house too,
was there forever.
But I think they brought him in the black house in normal.
Jay was,
is out of a alliance camp there.
They're monsters.
Gustafson was down there with him.
They brought Pearson.
Did they give to us when a fight?
I feel like they feel like Gustafson just said something about not knowing what
he's doing.
I thought he said he lost the,
uh,
does the drive right.
So he went,
he flew from Sweden to San Diego to see if the fire was still there and he still
was questioned.
I,
oh man.
I think he comes from money.
That's the of the thing is he's got a lot.
How dare you just be?
I don't think so.
No,
I think he does.
I think it's not even real money.
It's like,
no,
these families are,
she has a lot of money.
Yeah,
but it's not even an immense.
He was always a kind of a problem child growing up,
but now he's a superstar.
Hardge and sweet.
It's hard to go back to that training when you're already kind of arrived.
People from Stockholm and to listening.
I was only joking about your money.
He's the stuff Brian didn't hear it do like,
what do you think's American
tax revenue is?
The only money is that it is a high tax rate.
It's like something like crazy.
Like 60% no,
that's not what I'm saying Brian.
I'm saying Americans better.
Yeah,
she's Merrick's son.
I don't care about their fucking tax rate.
Only pay 1% taxes.
You could suck my Dick.
You have to live in Scotland or wherever the hell you lift.
Put such in.
Stockholm is a beautiful sleeping and swimming in the water there.
I've been there.
You might as well be living on the moon.
Excuse me.
I did two shows back home.
I'm sorry.
I'm outraged.
I did two shows in Stockholm.
I was supposed to come in here and come from money.
I didn't hear that.
He's a fucking monster.
He'd go to war with John.
John Rich,
trust me and trust comes from.
Why don't you Google it?
Don't say me.
Trust me.
If you're not sure I'm better than Google and what are,
you should have an inside scoop on that to be honest with you.
No.
Do you really do that guy probably hates on him.
The guy he comes from,
I'm not saying he comes from billions,
but he comes from a well to do family as well.
It's not a bad thing.
I'm not saying anything bad about them.
That's it.
It's a good thing.
It comes from a good family.
A successful farm is very successful and apparently he was a,
I guess he had some problems growing up.
Okay,
hold on.
You know you have a phone,
right?
Yeah.
Why don't you look that up?
Well,
what do I,
how do I look it up?
It's Google Alexander Gustafson's childhood.
I have 1%.
Well,
oh my God.
Plug it into bed too late.
Just plug it in man.
I just don't feel like young Jamie would find that young Jamie.
We'll find it.
Here's the deal.
I think he's a spectacular person,
so I don't want to disparage his background and if he did come up from a
hardscrabble existence even more in,
the last thing I want to hear is the kid over there making shit,
talking shit and making things though.
He's a billionaire.
He says this God father's uncle gates.
They'll get uncle gates.
Jeremy Stevens,
dropping bows,
dropping knees on John Brown.
Light heavyweight needs with stream in the running since tough guy.
That's a real tough guy.
One of the best thing I'll close.
He was to winning a world title and a true blonde.
I call him the true blonde.
Truly beat beat Manama with no one had,
you know,
I mean he took a fight with manual and man one is Jimmy Manna.
What was knocking out anybody?
Everybody uh,
penance.
Bleeding man.
What happened man?
Stevens is just basically got in a fight.
What happened
had an is having trouble hurting Stevens with this damn.
He's got a big head and Jeremy,
oh,
he can just,
he can kind of walk through it.
Keep pressure on him like this.
Ouch.
Yeah.
He said,
Oh boy,
he loves us a damn upper cut does.
Well,
I mean it's one of his most spectacular highlight real case,
so you never drove it to the UFC.
Starts adding CGI blood like live.
They can do it like snap chat filters.
Now imagine if you could take 'em down.
Rash guards filters down to a man.
If you could watch the UFC through snapchat and you could make a Brad Pitt
filter erratic and Angelina Jolie,
we're duking it out to the death.
Oh,
you put Angelina his head,
you can use their bodies.
You can make like cyborgs body.
Like you could have cyborg fight.
Cain Velasquez,
next time for doing fights cane.
She's turning to Cyborg.
He was like really into watching the girl beat the fuck out here.
Hey you bastards and African this fight.
Let me ask a question.
Girl from frozen ANA for frozen.
That can be who's fighting and winning.
Oh,
those snapchat filters are crazy,
man.
Crying.
You could take your face,
put it on,
on,
on uh,
chavs body.
I know he could say anything.
I was as Brian Cowen,
I'm going to even with a good knee to the body.
I don't fuck with snapchat.
Do you Joe?
No,
I did not either do I?
You guys should do an episode where you play each other the whole time.
You're in character.
You're like Kelly cow.
The whole,
it's a bad idea.
Nobody kicked me.
Yeah,
you're right.
That's a good episode for three DB.
Patty Jenkins says hi to you.
She's done.
She's,
she's been directing wonder woman.
I don't give a fuck about wonder woman.
Patty,
can we,
can we salute to the fighter and the kid making it to number one on the Itunes
TV show last night?
Oh No.
I've no idea too.
You guys are number one on iTunes comedy TV.
That's kind of incredible.
It's kind of crazy,
but you know what?
We're proud of.
What we've kind of crazy.
That's incredible.
You're not number three.
You're not.
Number six,
he gives him,
you're not number two.
I got to start taking my success and I don't.
I always think of myself as a failure and definitely a failure.
I am definitely a failure,
but at least that it's just about,
it's about what you're counting.
It depend make you fail that basketball,
he never got to be in the NBA.
Then we're going to be in the room.
He looked at it,
you suck at software development.
You're never going to win this car.
Oh fuck.
There's so many things I'm never going to do.
Tiger.
Kim doesn't even know who you are.
I called tiger him tire camp.
They knew who I was.
He didn't know who the fuck you are.
Two of my kids are sick.
My kicks are set up too.
That's the fight right there.
Look at these two guys.
Two killers.
Good luck pin.
They can fight of the night tonight.
Dan.
These are good.
Well done.
Team one floor,
barely paid any attention.
Nobody that tuned in here wanting to hear us talking about fights.
I'm so sorry.
I feel bad.
Not me.
If you expected.
We were just going to talk about fights.
Ram your face into your wall.
There's,
I mean there's no,
we would never do that.
She Cowen.
Isn't it important to admit like things that you're a failure at support and
then you and I have had this conversation many times I'm a failure at almost
everything I've ever done.
Yes.
Ultimately you find ways to be successful at it,
but I've failed at everything.
Well,
wisdom.
What does wisdom I think wisdom.
What'd you fail in a way to get everybody to wisdom.
Wisdom.
Wisdom is not failed on the land.
Listen,
listen,
listen.
You always fail.
That's why I always say to younger people,
listen to me because I've made more mistakes.
Then you have wisdom and wisdom.
Listen,
everything.
No wisdom is
wisdom is coming to terms with your limitations and learning what to do with it.
That's where wisdom is.
Learning that you have limitations coming to terms with that,
accepting it and then learning what to do with that.
You're learning how to make that work for you.
That's what it is.
That's how you learn it.
Well,
you know you learn.
You keep failing,
you keep adjusting your approach and you can move on to something.
No,
sometimes.
Sometimes you got to move on.
Go Kido.
Sometimes son,
do all these guys.
You saw that
by the way,
by the way.
He's,
he's,
he's trimmed up man.
How about we have no idea who won this and we barely pay.
I'm going to go home tonight and I'm gonna Watch this shit before I go to sleep
now.
Really Getting Jeremy Stephens fucking with mother fucker.
That mother fuck powerful dad bought by DC on the side there.
The powerful Jeremy Stevens who is a heavy burden on being on the Joe Rogan
experience.
It's tough on him.
No,
Jeremy Stevens has been on.
Oh,
Rosemont again.
Anytime he wants Jeremy Open invitation my dog.
What a big win.
Huge,
huge fucking huge win.
Shutdown.
One of the guys who was considered to be one of the best pound for pound
fighters in the world just a year and a half ago for Tj,
it seems like forever ago.
It is.
Cj ate his lunch.
It is forever ago in the world of MMA.
That's like one of the weird things about this sport.
This sport is strange,
man.
You're only as good as your last fight.
Well,
you're only as good as your last training session.
You could have a bad training session and they'll go into fight like,
man,
I don't even know.
You know like there's certain guys that you can take on his training partners.
They could fuck up your confidence for a fight because you can know there's a
rumble Johnson like that out there.
If you're some due to trains,
light heavyweight it black house and you,
your training would rumble all day like what happened?
What am I doing?
Why am I doing this?
What?
I like concussions.
What am I doing?
I'm going to learn.
I'm going to get better with this fucking dude who's like the freak of freaks
don't.
Although like Anderson,
that's what makes him so extraordinary.
His his dominance for so long and then he got knocked out once and then broke
his leg and well selfless.
Sometimes it ends sometimes,
sometimes,
sometimes just those also 40 there's a hundred factors involved.
There is life.
There is,
there's psychology is psychology.
Psycho is also understanding who you are as a human being and how that gets
distorted by massive amounts of fame and praise and adulation and love from,
from your country man and from people around the world because you're the
champion of the world and recognize my opinion.
If you want to ask me who's the greatest of all time,
I will always say Anderson Silva.
I think Anderson Silva,
the greatest MMA fighter,
he's the best.
The best dinner finished everybody.
He did things during the apex of the prime of MMA that nobody had been able to
do before.
You know what?
He just was a monster man when he was with the knock out,
the veto knockout the feature,
not the person who was
named Mark Court too.
I mean everybody,
oh my God,
dude.
Everybody.
He was a month.
James Irvin,
how about the Forrest Griffin fight?
Jesus fucking Christ.
Anyway,
a full matrix [inaudible] matrix matrix.
Jesus Christ.
This coming,
you know,
even the,
even the first one for night but not for me.
So that was an interesting fight for me because that was a fight where I was
telling everybody that worked for the UFC.
I was like,
do you understand what you have acquired?
I'm like,
you have acquired,
in my opinion the baddest motherfucker in this division.
Like do you understand how good this guy?
But it wasn't that dominant in Japan but it didn't matter.
Didn't matter.
You're talking about Andy Simpson when Anderson came over the UFC I was adamant.
I'm like you guys have a guy who when I watch movement I watched like the way
guys move.
I'm like this guy can do some shit.
He did.
He was he just so much faster than most guys.
Only time man.
He's more ties just like super,
super high level there is up there.
This is Anderson versus Forrest Griffin.
Look at that behind you.
This is Anderson in his prime and by the way,
light heavyweight fight to a guy who's 20 pounds less as a champion.
And this is just an opportunity for Anderson to fight and not have to cut
weight.
And in Brazil was this Brazil against four you?
Same card.
Cause I fought Nogueira that night.
Pretty sure.
Am I right on,
do I feel like this is Vegas?
God,
you might be right Joe.
I feel like this is Mandalay bay
because I feel like this was Vegas.
I don't think this is Brazil.
Janie,
find out please.
Young.
Maybe shogun fought forest in Brazil.
Yes he did.
It's why I'm thinking is my bet.
But when the Anderson Anderson accidently I poked or something and also with any
does the Matrix,
this is in Vegas.
You're right Jill.
We opens him up and just relax as an Anderson was like really good.
They'd like figuring out your timing and lulling you to sleep with a false sense
of security and then out of nowhere he would just drop bombs on you.
But then he took it to another level.
Yeah.
Well I think with Weidman,
Weidman took them down early and threatened him with a knee bar and I think he
was really worried about the ground game in Philadelphia.
Was it filling?
Thank you chairman.
God
boom and,
and you know Forrest is in trouble.
Yeah,
sure,
sure.
Forced shook his head like God damn horses,
every bit of six for at least two 35 it's a big boy.
Yeah,
and he's a former arms.
He's the light heavyweight champ.
That's right.
He beat the beat rampage.
Well,
close fight and all that.
That means fine.
I mean,
I was at that fight though.
It was kind of cool when I was right.
Well,
I was with you.
Oh,
okay.
Oh look at,
oh goodness.
Another going out.
I'm going to sound
bad and it's just random person.
The way he moves his,
he moves his head.
That was like,
well dude.
Yeah,
it's almost like Anderson got it when we got upset about,
oh shit.
We get us matrix.
Oh,
he's beating them up now.
That was the matrix,
right?
They're slow motion.
You never seen some ramp that up.
He's like,
Judge Shit.
He got mad at forest when or what the fuck happened man.
Like,
oh man.
White anger.
Excuse me.
The only difference in
resilience,
one man needs more softer vitamin D.
I'm mad.
I'm mad at white people and I'm white and me to
make and those looking at blocking a shot,
he's still,
I'll bring that shit into my fucking forest,
like pulled back on a round kick.
Look at him,
Joe.
He realize how slow forces right hand and that's it.
And it pushed for spread out like that.
And that's a wrap please.
Enough is enough.
You know who talks shit on white people in the past is Joey.
Oh Joey does?
Yeah,
he's the,
he's the best.
I'm talking shit about everything.
Fucking white people.
What did you think you want to do?
Just fucking guy's been living in the jungle.
He's been docking Jaguars,
Jaguars eight and crocodiles.
This mother fucker's hitting him with a right hook.
He owe king him fucking white people.
He's,
he'll hook and flamingos and the
Alameda.
Alameda is
Centrum multivitamin once a day
and he's getting steroid shot.
And who is the hole in his dick with a Turkey baster?
Give him three stars or death.
Three stars that this is a photo from Joey's a Twitter.
I retweeted it like yesterday.
It's,
he says,
come on Pittsburgh.
Who wants to meet the devil and hotel room.
He's got mushrooms and the stars of death,
which I think these stars,
the pot gummy stars are like 500 milligrams of THC.
Look at that fucking photograph.
Thousand milligrams of THC and at least three grams of mushrooms you ready to
see?
That's a Thursday night.
Shrooms and stars
and stars and that's how he's living a real an Alva.
Does he take him fixed mushrooms before he performs?
Of course he does.
You shut the fuck.
Oh my God.
You hurt my feelings was a little bit.
Got a fix for the main event.
That is an amazing picture or wine please.
Is that anonymous Twitter?
Yes.
We may be told I haven't turned a very good.
That turned shit in.
My glass turned.
Turned me.
You're so gross with your wine.
Hold on.
That's good.
It's just different.
You hadn't get involved.
Look at that fucking photo.
Pittsburgh.
Are you ready to see the devil?
The improv at seven and 9:00 PM Oh shit.
I'm sorry Bob.
I'm sorry.
Come on,
dust.
You don't have to suck my Dick.
Dick.
Joey Diaz will be here on Tuesday.
Joey D's will be here Tuesday.
Hey.
Hey,
you fucks.
I'll be in St Louis.
Ninth,
10th and 11th and Sterling Comedy Clubs.
You Fox.
No,
I didn't say that.
That was Jamie.
Jamie,
this is Jamie.
Brian's going to be a helium coming from Saint Luke's.
Shit time.
I heard St Louis is a rough joint dude.
Really?
Yeah.
Helium.
No.
Saint Louis.
Oh,
I've been there.
It's nice.
It's rough.
Come on man.
What's his name is from Barry's.
Who's that wrapper?
Everyone's getting crazy.
Nelly fucking Nellie's my boy.
Hey Brian.
But that girl behind us,
we've seen the girl understands the camera's on her right behind.
Just look at her.
She's looking at Cody going,
oh,
fuck my mouth.
Yes.
I'm sure she's not a pro.
What are you trying to say,
Bros?
I didn't say anything just because the girls are a good looking girl.
That's all I meant.
That's all I met.
Professional hot girl.
But meanwhile if there was a guy,
okay,
that was standing back there and it was looking at a stud woman,
that's like the female equivalent to Coty.
That'd be like a natural thing to say.
Too many catches Cody.
Too many tattoos.
Of course.
Now of course I no,
that's how you attract a certain type of female.
Is that true?
Yeah.
One was Cody could.
It wasn't that dangerous shit.
The neck.
Some girls like dangerous shit.
They like it.
You know what?
He's so good looking.
He could do that shit handsome.
Oh,
he's,
it doesn't matter.
You can put a tattoo right on his face.
He's first job bins.
The captain now captain,
he's very cute.
He's very cute.
No short to beat.
Luke Rockhold changed the captain wrong.
He's tall.
Doesn't matter.
Luke's taller.
Luke could be with Versace.
Gotta put height and he seeks it out.
Yeah.
You don't have to face structure.
He's too legit TV.
He,
you know what I'm saying?
He's too legit to be signed.
Once you get signed by a modeling agent,
then you're a model.
If you're just as good looking,
you're not signed.
You're more legit.
I
think Joe bands more legit.
No,
we don't talk about anything.
Huh?
He says we're all fucking,
what are the so hot did he got the tattoos on his neck to keep the girls like at
bay?
So he's gay?
No,
it's just like shit.
There's too many.
There's nobody's ever said that.
You never know
what's going on.
Why do we have to go there?
That's not right.
I lanch what's going on?
He's just trying to get a specific qualities.
You know what I'm saying?
He's tired of women that are like looking for some sort of longterm,
serious commitment.
So your tattoo on your neck,
morals and religious beliefs
and only drags in the freaks.
He's got some tents on them.
I saw Joe ban,
giant poster,
New York,
New York City.
Him Shirt off.
Handsome man.
Oh Man.
Oh well we're talking billboard son,
Versace.
Really?
Holy Shit.
I'm Brian.
Why are you scared of weed?
No,
I'm not guys a,
I'll do it if you're friendly with me,
but,
well Brendan just reached for it and you put it out.
Oh good.
I'll do Jiu Jitsu to now on.
I'll tell you guys I keep going back job and you're fucking crazy.
You think anyone's on that level drag the conversation is going to be,
look,
it's going to be nobody has Rinaldo crazy.
Nobody has Rinaldo Chopin looks like Rinaldo not quite this conversation,
you know,
way to
shit that's,
and I'm there.
I'm there.
I'm with you.
I'm a wack Chabad Chabad.
Beautiful Man.
We gotta be a little better about talking over each other.
I know I keep saying this but he's guilty as everybody but only voice in the
wilderness.
He keeps bringing us back cause I'm the one who has to read the tweets here,
right?
No,
but it's something about your parents and this is the most beautiful thing ever.
I think we're all working together to create a piece of art.
You just gotta be real careful about stomping on each of those words.
A piece of bark up the Turkey base to steroids and some of these stick when
you're talking about gay shit,
saving gauge,
all bands.
A good looking dude.
I think he's first team Thomas Bro.
How many times I've got to tell you he's married.
Tom saw made is not a bad looking fella either.
If you're a man,
if he ended up,
he looks like a Dell
all due respect.
A lot of black guys,
exactly what they're looking for.
Hey man,
listen,
he's a twink.
He's called the kid is a fucking savage Tom Summit as a God damn.
SAS tough fight for garbage.
Oh,
Brian,
with this nonsense of winning,
as you saying about the last fight,
you were wrong.
Now I was painting you guys,
but here's the thing,
he's going to win this fight.
He certainly can win,
but you know what,
Cody can win to both.
These guys are undefeated.
I meet as the favorite I made.
It's got 22 of course he is,
but let me tell you something.
Brad pickets stunned.
I'll meda and he's stunned him and hurt him.
Pick pickets.
A great truths.
It's true,
but I'm telling you,
Cody Garbrandt,
I believe at this stage of his career in life,
he's only 24 years old.
He's faster and more dangerous with his hand.
He also hits harder than anyone at one 30 is boggling background.
Yes,
he's a very strong boxing background.
So if Cody can impose his boxing skills in a similar manner to what Brad picket
did,
we might see some interesting results by inserting mean Kale.
But,
but I'm telling you,
this guy's hard to take out.
He's a God damn savage.
This fucking kid,
Thomas Almeda is something super special.
Takes hits though Bro.
Chill.
But it comes back like he came back against Brad Pickett hits fucking hard man.
Chicken dropped him and Almeda came back and knocked him out with a flying knee
Kayo in the next round.
We're about to watch some crazy epic shit that could easily be a world
championship fight easily.
Maybe garb brand is a year away from world caliber.
Yes,
he wins this.
He's off to the races.
You got number eight undefeated and you look like that.
Cody is like in my opinion,
a year,
a year and a half away from fine for title agree,
which means it could happen tomorrow.
Hey nicknamed the last guy who was on rank to lead a main event that wasn't like
a legend.
Well,
what is courtesy ranking at all ranked while he's on the top 15 he's certainly
dangerous and he certainly comes from a really good team.
He's a team.
Alpha male.
God,
they've got a long history of success and knockout arts and knockout artists.
He has awesome hands tall.
Is He?
I think he's five.
Eight.
That's pretty tall.
That's not short.
Yeah.
Well you see five five,
eight,
five is tall enough.
Tall enough.
One 35 is tall.
He's fine.
I made is five seven.
When he want to know I made as a gangster dude,
he's so solid.
I liked garb.
Ramp,
man.
We're watching right now.
We're about to watch some fucking technical martial arts chaos that's we're
about to watch.
You can watch sock him in the face.
You might watch that or you might watch Almeda hit him with a fucking switch
knee as he's coming in.
You might watch some leg kicks.
It take Cody garb,
ran out of the game.
I mean,
it's all dependent upon approach.
This is like,
this is guessing and theoretical ideas.
It's like it's a theoretical that if Cody keeps it on the feet and sprawls and
brawls,
he wins,
but that doesn't necessarily mean it's true.
Fuck Kevin Randleman knocked out Mirko Cro cop with a left hook.
Yeah.
I mean this is a crazy game where we're about to watch.
I mean,
this is crazy.
A game as people play sport to bet on it.
Throw my bones at you with all my mind.
That's it.
The same kind of power that produces a 90 plus mile an hour fast ball and I'm
going to stuff it into your fucking lips.
The gaming show,
that's the game.
Make you quit or shut you up in the house in the fucking house.
Cody opens up the plan.
Crazy roundhouse kicks.
We touched the criminal complaint around house damage.
Here's the problem with that.
You should probably shouldn't be able to touch the ground on purpose and then
punching out with that same hand.
We've got the referee wiping it off.
Oh my God,
Joe,
come on.
No,
if you go to the ground and boxing,
they wipe your hands off.
You ever noticed that the wipe your hands off that fucking tattoo on the back?
Is that a rose and cause there's a bunch of people walking like the referee
walks through the arena and then uses those same shoes is walking around and
smack him.
Wash his feet.
I say I'm thinking of my people are in the ring though.
And baby wipes.
Yeah.
Oh Hey,
what?
I liked that part.
Oh my God.
We lost power.
A Fox sports one.
Oh Wow.
Came back.
Calm down.
No ideas won't shut.
The shutters does scary.
Cody Garbrandt with a left hook arm.
Right.
See the thing is [inaudible] oh we fight when it's dangerous.
Starts off with the hands because you don't feel comfortable enough to start
throwing kicks.
And last year some crazy Moy Thai style kick an expert where it's a part of your
natural thing killer.
But like guys who are like straight up MMA fighters,
they tend to favor hands with,
they're nervous.
So when your favorite hands,
carb brands got a pretty fucking nice advantage over a large percentage of the
people he's faced so far,
especially with his box.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Joe,
wouldn't you say most guys favorite grappling in the beginning?
There's a little bit of that,
but there's also hands before kicks cause it distance.
He's got speed and Almeda.
Almeda license throw knees and likes to throw kicks,
but he might get counter.
He might get conservative in his approach because of the fact that Garber hands
hands are so good that he doesn't want to open himself up to like he brought.
He probably considered straight right counters to the right leg kicks they garb
ramp might look.
Look how heavy garb rant is on the front leg.
I want to assume that he's ready for a straight right hand counter to that.
How quicker his right leg kicks to quick move.
His hands are lightning fast.
His right leg kick isn't really fast to mass.
Oh
hello.
He's a big trouble.
Cody garb.
Brands all over him relax to only,
and Jesus looks at this killer he's taught to.
How good is that neck tattoo.
If look if he went out,
what's up now Brian?
That's an APP.
If he wins,
he's
awesome.
He gets us.
Damn Amanda can take a punch guys.
Get a star right below his eyes.
If he wins 100% if I may can take up all bogus shit.
You see him just take that beating and state standing there.
This is crazy.
My son Cody is and off on a man who does getting a little reckless stake control
matter.
It looks.
Oh,
Gotcha.
Oh my God.
Cody.
When Cody is legit as fuck you up.
I'm top 10 now.
Hey,
you told shit
an you fuckers.
Carm just beat him.
He took him out in the first round.
You cheeto finger fucks rank him.
Brian,
didn't you say that you were a wanting for,
didn't you?
Well,
who were Tom's?
No,
I've been a Garber in France and it's fucking 90 96 wait a minute.
Did you say meda for sure is going to win?
No data and since 2011 he's been my boy.
I was watching this kid wrestling high school wrestling match.
Cody's in told you I told you for hardest sit at 35 son.
Yup.
Oh my God.
Look at this beautiful.
Oh beautiful Thai boxing technique though.
Even with the ground and pound going right to the hammer.
Oh my God.
It's beautiful.
What a beautiful fucking huge wind man.
Good for him.
To me that's like a mountain covered in snow with a sunrise.
Great.
It has.
It definitely has visual triggers like porn.
It's right up there with as to waist ratio.
Yup.
Well,
when I got there.
Yeah.
Brilliant.
That's beautiful.
I respect that.
I have to strongly disagree so he can barely keep
open his eyes.
So it's just this offs shut this off.
I don't want to watch anymore.
I found enough violence.
Garbin doing the damn thing.
35 son.
God Damn,
you look good tonight.
This was like a coming out party for garbage.
They give him undefeated 2108 rank guy in the world.
Any starches?
Not 21 to know he's lost two fights in a row.
No.
Well we mean you're not talking about tonight.
I'm talking about tonight.
Well Hanan Barao was lost a couple of times.
I'm not talking about whom?
Brown Cody Garbrandt and I'll meet a fight.
Oh,
Beatles.
Undefeated.
He hasn't lost confused.
I got baffled.
Yeah,
we'll cut what Cody do.
You had to rank them.
Yeah.
Well Cody did tonight was like impose his skills in a way that I don't think
you've ever seen him do before.
That was like the best version of all of his combination.
That part the most,
yeah,
for sure coming out.
Right.
He's a star now is a good looking dude and calm and all that fire and that fire
range and then fucking squadron of death range.
When you got to,
he was so,
his eyes are so focused.
He was so relaxed and I don't know shit about striking but uh,
I mean he looks like Bruce Wallace.
You know what?
This was a great car here.
Looks like this is your break card basis because the match ups were fun.
But look,
look what we had,
we had,
we had Jeremy Stevens beat Hanan Barao was like,
wow,
that was a big fucking wind for chairman Stevens.
Holy Shit.
And then because we had Cody Garbrandt take it to the totally next level,
so it was like,
it was a perfect,
like coal main and then main right.
Like said,
looking forward,
come on man,
how are you going to do that?
I mean it's also amazing that Hennen Barao who just two fights ago was the world
champion and and three sites and sites for pound best for best in the world.
It was,
they're like waiting and I'm in and out.
I was thinking he was number three.
I was like,
it was Jon Jones.
I felt like,
well four.
I was like,
because it was before,
although it got stopped by Mcgregor,
Jon Jones.
Demetrius was,
he was like a little bit below it was in,
it was,
it was all,
it's all subjective but it was in the mix and it was definitely in the mix.
Top five for sure.
For sure.
For sure and for all those peanuts are on the fence.
All those people that are on the fence about a neck tattoo.
Boom,
they got side kicked over pat time.
I know for sure it gets to get a neck.
Here's the thing,
I think this is important.
Talk about for all and then they fans.
There's a,
there's a,
there's an issue that keeps coming up with MMA and social media that I think
people need to relax about.
Like all of us as friends disagree about shit,
but we're not douchey about it.
Like if you think that Hennen Barao was going to be able to figure out how to
weight a way to beat Jeremy Stevens,
but I think that Jeremy Stevens power and experience at 145 pounds going to
prevail.
We don't have to be enemies.
This weird thing going on.
Like if you say something that you,
and I disagree with it,
like if,
if,
if that,
like if that hits online,
like if two people disagree online,
people assume that there's like some sort of a horrible argument going on and
they assume that,
you know,
there's like some negativity to me,
hey,
you hate each other pill.
No good.
But that's a tendency for tempo.
How many times have you,
and I mean you're as close to it as a human being as I could be with you guys.
All of you guys,
you later in my life,
but I was still up.
You're up down dog.
You know Bro.
You know what I'm saying?
Dog Coming Times.
We disagreed about shit.
We've had some,
we've had some intense disagreements.
Yes,
we've had some intense disagreements,
but through those disagreements you learn to consider other people's
perspectives,
but online Joe,
they call it they,
they'll say it's,
hey,
it's called critical thinking.
She doesn't listen to my love for both of you and you too.
All My love for all of you.
It doesn't change dependent upon whether or not I agree with you or disagree
with you.
Yes,
exactly.
Arrest example of that is the chem trail issue.
Yes.
It's pretty good damn chem trail and I'm all about Kevin and feel like I,
this is what I really feel like.
I feel like it is entirely possible that at one point in time they have
experimented with spraying things in the,
you were fucked.
It's entirely not possible.
They do it all the time and then it's just they just scattered will try to
control it all the time,
but then there's the issue of all the tensions all go through condensation and
the atmosphere.
No one said they would actually change the temperature daughter getting sucked
into turbines.
Exactly.
Like,
Hey,
I love you and you're trying to tell me that the NGS,
that's what we're trying to tell you.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
Heady
fucking told me that nine 11 was real.
What do you mean real?
It actually happened while I was here September 11th and then,
uh,
I woke up on September 12th and I'm like,
I'm pretty sure
both towers were a hologram.
That shit never existed.
Look in the scriptures,
the scriptures,
they never talked about the twin town
wine in your mom.
Chaos.
And you know you're doing the riders on the storm.
You know the craziest thing about the riders on the storm,
the craziest thing about the doors.
Do you know the Jim Morrison's dad orchestrated the Gulf of Tonkin?
No.
Fucking no.
Wow.
This is the,
that makes sense.
This is,
this is,
this
is the craziest thing.
And that's not in the best conspiracy.
Jamie
gold.
He was a navy high level,
high level.
Jim Morrison's dad orchestrated the Gulf of Tonkin,
but his dad,
because his dad,
his dad,
it's real.
It's not a conspiracy right?
This week,
a pdf pages being friends with both Alex Jones and Eddie Bravo.
Occasionally they have solid points.
None of a,
check this out.
Check this out.
This is the craziest thing.
This is the tip of the iceberg.
It's true.
You want 90 seconds of the craziest Shit that I'm into right now.
What?
I want 120 minutes.
Listen,
listen.
Real quick.
Real,
real quick.
I got a blaze of some shit really quick and you just gotta.
You just gotta go question Shit in my mind.
Opening my mind.
There's a,
there's a,
you got to know that there's a,
there's a woman named Kay Greg who was married to a high ranking army,
uh,
joints,
chiefs of staffs,
officer George Griggs,
Janice legit.
They were married and he,
and she knows all about his life.
He was raised as an assassin.
He was,
he was a navy seal.
He was a CIA operative.
He was UN special forces.
And then you became a high ranking.
This is not a conspiracy.
You're talking about the movie trip on his name is George Griggs.
There's,
there's a shitload.
Okay.
Did you just give us the plots of triple?
Exactly,
exactly.
There's a woman and K Griggs.
It was,
she's like,
she,
she's,
she was all in it too.
She's,
there's an eight hour interview of hers chopped up a million times with one
chip.
You can believe it or not.
Maybe she's a little crazy bitch.
Well,
let me take you through this chicken.
Be Crazy,
fully shit.
She was like,
she basically tells,
she's basically saying,
uh,
how the world is run based on her husband who was high ranking and army
intelligence.
Real good friends with George senior like right there.
She was,
she basically is a whistleblower.
She's on,
there's one interview,
eight hour,
she goes off and she breaks it off and she makes you,
if you believe what she says,
she basically says the CIA.
That's just a scape goat.
There aren't doing shit.
The people that are really running the world or army intelligence,
naval intelligence and air force intelligence,
she said they're the one K Griggs.
That's there's,
she says,
she says that,
that,
that fucking money in the world,
they're all,
and what it's all about,
it's all about a gun running and,
and uh,
and just selling arms.
It's all about all,
it's like Mafia.
It's all high ranking,
army intelligence,
Mafia gun running,
drug running.
They've always done it.
Her husband's part of it.
It's these assassins.
They uh,
can neuro Jews.
No,
but if you,
if you believe that,
okay,
let me take it through the,
so she's saying,
I thought you took army intelligence runs through all the shit.
Right?
So then you,
then you find out that,
um,
you know that actor Rockstar Dude,
Jared Leto.
Yeah.
You spread your sweetheart.
He bought for $4 million.
He bought in the Laurel Canyon in the Hollywood hills.
He bought a former top secret air force intelligence base there.
Was that in Hollywood?
This is Jeremy.
No,
no.
Okay.
I'm trying to let him,
let him,
come on,
man.
This is how it connects to Jim Morrison trying to connect them.
I don't know if this is real,
but this is what I've looked into.
You Look,
look investigating the shadow.
We conspiracy that Jared Leto the lead.
Jared Leto to bother nuclear fucking
curb Los Angeles.
Yeah.
Okay,
so you don't think that Jared Oban top secret air?
You don't believe that's true.
Hold on.
That's real.
Okay.
Hold on.
What's the big deal?
I know you haven't.
I know you have this instinct to mock things.
I'm like a monkey.
Fuck him.
Let him no man.
I'm with Jerry in your mind.
There's no need to watch you watch TV.
That's not true.
When you accept not to qualify them,
please continue.
This is game of Thrones,
which may have an ounce of truth.
It makes it better,
but game of Thrones.
Okay,
your watch,
game of Thrones.
This is so Jared Leto.
If you look at it,
he bought a top secret for since the forties it was top secret and what they
find them,
and this is all this is not conspiracy theory,
that this top secret air force intelligence base was mainly a full fucking force
film studio where they make propaganda films,
right?
Healing Hollywood,
Marilyn Monroe,
fucking Ronald Reagan,
John Wayne,
all of them making propaganda films that no one can,
there's no records of what films were made there.
You can't tell which films are made in the studio,
which warrant,
because like,
whoa.
And then you start looking,
you're like,
uh,
okay.
Okay,
Jared Leto bought this air force.
Okay.
And then you,
there's this book called,
um,
uh,
weird scenes and Laurel Canyon and in this book,
the author of this book,
unless it's,
this is the craziest Shit,
if you look,
it is not a conspiracy theory.
All the bands from the mid sixties,
the doors,
the eagles,
all of them,
Frank Zapper,
the mamas and the Papas,
Crosby,
stills and Nash,
they all came from Loral King and mother sucker.
Hey,
after this,
he's been on 16.
I know this is okay.
Okay.
So sorry to tell you some shit.
Okay,
so,
so this is what this book is about.
This book is about it.
Isn't it fucking weird?
Isn't it fucking suspicious and crazy that there's this top secret air force
intelligence base right there in Laurel Canyon and in the mid sixties all the
bands that started the hippie movement,
the Anti War movement,
they all came from law.
They all came from Laurel Canyon cosmic.
And guess what?
All their parents are in intelligence.
So these were all,
all of them,
the doors,
all of them came through Laurel Canyon.
They're all,
most of them in the bath.
None of them got drafted to Vietnam.
None of them got drafted.
Jim Morrison's father orchestrated the Gulf of Tonkin incident.
It gets pretty fucking weird.
Like this is crazy fucking weird.
And Jared fucking letter was raised by his grandfather was on his Brian Suggest
Brian.
No,
no,
no.
Let him sit through this.
I got it.
The Guy who wrote the book,
his name is
Sean.
I don't care.
It isn't that.
The book is called David.
Dave McGough.
I've heard of him.
Yeah.
So according to him,
and when you look into this,
out of nowhere in the sixties these bands didn't struggle.
They got signed quick.
All of them.
All these clubs in Hollywood pop up the Troubadour,
the whiskey.
This guy investigated this shit.
Yeah,
there's a conspiracy theory out there.
It could be total bullshit.
It could be totally blows,
but there's a conspiracy theory out there that you Loral king and there was some
intelligence.
There was a,
there was a base.
Brian,
let him finish.
Please let him,
don't tell me.
Don't tell me that the military fucking wrote that awesome music,
that fucking Crosby stills,
Nash and young kids in.
Dare you everybody.
Let me talk for a long time.
You got to let Bryan.
Okay.
How dare you give the u s military or the Air Force or anybody in the u s
government credit for the fucking awesome rock and roll that came out and
culminated in 1968 Bam.
Peaking at Haight Ashbury.
How fucking dare you the Mamas in the box.
You are a fucking plant and you worked for the u s
fucking
beat me up.
God,
let your fuck my ass hole.
All Right,
ladies and gentlemen,
this has been the Joe Rogan.
Oh,
sorry.
I thought I was fucking a lies
this,
as much as I realized this as much as anybody who has his big brown and we're
all parents.
Okay.
What we realize is it takes a lot of fucking time and effort to raise children
and communicate with children and raise children.
It's a lot of time.
And if you're working for the government,
you don't have that kind of time.
Correct.
Certainly don't have the kind of to hit and
tie some fucking kid and brainwashed them into make it in the most excellent
music the world's ever known.
Hold on.
That is the opposite of what I [inaudible] let you talk.
Keep going.
Just the opposite.
What the opposite is is a child that grows up in an oppressive,
strict conservative family that's connected to the military and realize that
this is bullshit.
And they start doing drugs and acid.
They start drinking,
they started hanging out with fucking Weirdos and they produce amazing music.
Yes.
And that's what we see and you can connect it to them,
but I think it's an erroneous connections.
I think it's a connection and it appeals to your desire to think that the world
is controlled by a cabal of intelligent super.
Come on.
He and I liked the cabal of intelligent super geniuses that have somehow figured
out in a way to manage their own love lives.
They're all in financial accounts are on real estate,
fucking holdings.
Their own stock market portfolios,
their own relationships with their coworkers,
their hobbies,
the hookers that they occasionally stick their penis into.
They have time for all that plus chem trails.
I say no,
there's not just time in the,
and the government did not make [inaudible] is not responsible for their doors.
I talked about this.
I talked about this before.
I want to,
I want to be in the Goddamn it a little bit naughty.
If their goddamn listening.
Of course you do.
You're just gave the military the military credit for all the great music that
came out of the 60s you fucking military helps you or I fucking just shift your
shot.
Want to start my own false flowers.
Jones is going to call you a shield Monday morning.
We got a disturbing turn of events at Eddie Bravo of how I've had on this
podcast.
I did not know he was in the Illuminati Shit.
Fuck yeah,
he is on the Joe Rogan experience.
Yes,
I didn't do it.
Get trails proven to be false.
Fuck yeah.
I want to fucking,
oh my God.
You're in.
Oh,
please.
Let me,
let me this way.
My own fault.
I talked about this before.
I would,
if I would get that fucking oil from Alaska,
I would go in there and make it,
make us elect Trump,
make it look like the eye.
Isis is uh,
uh,
Eskimos are trained in Isis.
I would,
you know,
you're a national treasure and I love the blue whale is a national trend.
I mean,
these things are true.
It has to be frustrating at iie to believe something.
He goes,
you constantly have to back years ago and this is very exhausted
with what we were talking about before the podcast.
Just think about that.
It's the same shit.
It's like that.
It's like God damn.
Sometimes it's,
please Illuminati.
Take me.
I want to fuck these mother fuckers.
I want to fuck with these motherfuckers that science and,
Oh,
I want to get science.
Why are you measuring shit?
You
know that the crazy thing is,
oh,
your distance and your speed.
Ooh.
What about psychics,
Bro?
Your measurable experiments.
How come y'all see the same shit,
Bro?
Every time I went to a psychic bro,
this tastes like shit.
I love that chaser.
It's weird.
It's both.
I think both things are true.
I mean,
Gulf of Tonkin was obviously a coordinated false flag event.
Uh,
the operation Northwoods was obviously an idea that they had tried to pass where
it got through the Joint Chiefs of Staff.
It was signed and vetoed by Kennedy where they're going to have a false flag.
And American civilians,
there's obviously have been throughout human history,
liars and manipulators that were in charge.
So we should do,
we should certainly have some healthy skepticism,
but we also have to take any consideration.
How much fucking time does a person having a day?
Who are all these masterminds?
I got much of this is just convenient.
Yes.
You're talking about the exception.
Yeah.
Well how much of,
how much of what's going on?
Like the 60 shit,
how much is just convenient,
rebellion,
obvious rebellion.
If you grow up with someone who's some sort of a fucking military asshole track
and he's super strict,
I mean,
I mean how many rock stars have come from that background?
It's like a giant number.
It's their outlet.
Being creative and trying to be a fight.
Talked to Cody Garbrandt.
He did not have a fucking cool seventh grade,
you know for sure some shit who's a Stepdad and mom had turned out brand tattoo
on your neck that says like self-made.
Yeah.
That's like you're trying to fight off something.
That's right.
Yeah.
You're not homecoming king and the neck tests,
but we also have to be taking into consideration that,
like we were talking about with bears earlier,
the bears don't have natural predators,
so nature is rigged.
Them Weird.
They've nature's wired them in some weird way with they eat babies,
whereas wolves don't do that cause he have to survive.
Elk Don't do that.
Pigs don't do that.
They have to take care of their babies because it's not as easy for them to
survive.
But the bears got to the top of the food chain.
They realized,
oh no,
we're fucked.
Like we,
no one can eat us.
So we can just keep fucking and making millions of us and we overcome all the
food and we'll all starve to death.
Okay,
we can start eating our babies and nature's rigged them in some sort of a weird
way.
You got to eat a baby.
Which one out of three babies too?
When you come to my house,
do not give me a hard time when you see my fucking mail.
Seven foot eight maybe eight.
Six cause I'm dead.
I and I got a nose for fucking bear.
Do not give me a hard time when you wiggle your toes
to my fucking rug cause I am saving bears by killing.
There's no sound.
So
we got a paper rock,
scissor who
we don't know.
We don't have to.
No,
you don't understand.
Look,
the rivets,
my friends who live up there,
they've got a whole set.
They have 30 or 40 different spots where they put people,
they have a,
they have a like a serious organization but also dude,
and they have to,
they get two tags per hunter a year.
You're supposed to kill to mature boars a years.
Hey Dude.
Triangulations honor you.
Stand the fuck down till I get my trophy and then and then you let me,
you let me secure shit.
You let me secure your hips.
He let me,
you say look Brophy.
That's a taboo word and that's supposed to say that trophy trophy taper off son
of a real hunter.
I Will Brian that meat.
I'll eat it all year.
Let me ask you,
this is a legit standup comedian and respect you and love you.
Thank you.
When someone says,
what's the difference between a comic and a comedian?
Do you explain it or do you say fuck you and walk away?
I say fuck you and walk away for you.
That's real.
Yeah,
that's what we're talking about here.
It's true.
Listen to me.
Please stand down.
Stand down.
You follow my fucking lead.
You stay a couple inches behind me.
Hey,
don't talk when I'm talking,
I'm an experienced,
I'm not a hunter.
And then when it's time,
when it's time for you to fucking shoot and you're breathing hard,
you're a regular guy and I help you with your breathing.
You understand me?
Me With my man because your breathing is like this.
And I go,
hey,
hey.
And I smack your face a couple times ago.
Look at me.
I kiss your mouth as a man,
as a friend because your mouth to wake you the fuck up.
There it is.
Look at me.
You're behind them.
Joe's behind your breathing into your neck and you,
you key into that rhythm and I'm breathing in near mouth and we breathe all
together as men.
Let me,
can I just step in from our buddy?
Go ahead.
Why do you want to belittle him in this weird way?
We see you're not a hunter where you know he's killed.
It leaves.
We just killed three deer.
Three days.
Yeah.
Three one in Montana to in Wisconsin.
Dear Bro,
he's killed three deer and eaten though.
That's a hunter and John.
Yeah,
dude,
he's made great shots.
He's maker.
I'm telling you,
Brian Cowen made a hundred and hire 50 160 shot yard shot in your first deer.
I think so.
Something like that.
Me and he made 'em to 100 yard shot,
second and third.
No,
no,
no.
You don't understand.
When you shooting at a living creature and it's all about getting it right and,
and trigger disciplined,
it's a big deal.
It's not easy.
And Brian,
every time he's attempted it and he's eating those animals,
he said,
hey,
look at me.
City boy city boy.
He doesn't like,
no,
I love hunting
city boy.
Boy.
I love hunting.
Do Platinum sit
with your arms up in the air.
Like Robbie Lawler after he,
after he won by knockout
animal.
But I like hanging out with tears.
I had to drop.
I don't like killing the actual animal,
but I like hanging with Joe and I,
no,
that's a fact.
This and there's this,
it's real.
But I have,
I do admit that I don't like killing the animal is the part,
but I,
but I wanted the time to do what I do it.
But I love the experience we have.
We laugh harder.
I make that fucker laugh harder than him.
Anybody ever met that?
He gets that high ticket.
Please
let me take it.
Let me tell you what happened in Montana.
We did kill him.
We were in the,
in the,
in the bush.
That's how we talk about it.
We were on the same routes.
That's for sure.
It's bonding,
Bro.
When Lewis and Clark traveled across the West,
that's where we went.
We were on the Missouri River.
We were in the Missouri breaks in Montana.
It was fucking fantastic.
Miserable.
Five days,
a Dick Jokes.
Oh,
I never said it was all cock and gay stuff.
And Brian doing this bit to today,
to this day is one of the hardest things I've ever like,
like hyperventilating,
tears running down my face.
It's maybe six degrees outside the room called the ravine comer jerking off into
a roofing.
I killed his deer and we were gutting this deer.
And Brian's eating.
It's eyeballs like it was like,
really?
Yeah.
He eats a tello behind the eyeballs.
I'm,
I'm fucking crazy.
I hate to write.
I cut a piece off and ate it.
Raw flesh around bro.
Hunter,
what were you saying?
Go flash behind the eyeballs.
Tastes like bread dough.
Dough.
Fernald gave it to me and I ate it.
Throw it off the face.
Go throw up in the fucking,
you're a few can't even handle this conversation.
Alan going,
Alan does this.
He's just doing this character called the ravine comer.
We have this deer tied to this tree.
We pull this deer down.
We're fuck you freezing.
We're fucking freezing.
I remember like,
Oh my God,
where am I,
Montana?
The fucking ground is frozen.
It's eight degrees outside.
We're cutting this deer and we decided to have a fire.
It's,
we had this little tiny little campfire and Brian County goes,
why don't you the a bottom tier like to come and he gets shit.
He gets near the bridge,
not a bridge like Lyft
and he starts,
he starts jacking off in front of this ravine and saying he's the ravine.
Calmer because you asked me what I was doing
were crying.
It's me and Rinella and mode tears rolling down her eyes.
That deer skin,
that deer,
I'm taking coq to hand.
I'm coming and just repeat screaming.
I'm coming,
I'm coming.
It's out.
When you say you're coming,
like you're pulling,
it's hilarious.
Can you see something about people on boats and the distance hearing your cries
so fucked up about it because we were like a couple of months we're going to
pack out with the meat.
He's like,
we're miles away from the river.
Hey,
my cries of pleasure.
And he just keeps jacking off in the bushes,
thumb off as like Tom off.
I call it thumbing,
but it was five days of that.
I know it was five days of the best audience when I got you alone,
you are the best audience cause you fucking laugh hard and I just wait for my
openings and I take them.
I just take them.
What about when I led some days I fucking,
the other day I W I was blue.
Joe Kept laughing and I was fucking funny out of ammunition and I didn't know
what to do and I just fucking,
I was spazzing out and I go,
ah,
I kicked the table over it.
I need some fucking attention.
I didn't know what else to do and I was funny to see Doug Durham was there.
I was like,
I don't always get making them all laugh.
And I go,
I'll have,
fuck man,
I kicked bleed.
Hey,
well I need some fucking intention.
Barely had the energy to sleep when we were in Wisconsin.
It was just always,
shit.
Fuck,
this shit is shit on the ground.
You will laugh your ass off when you go to bill.
Here's the problem with hunting.
Here's why.
Hunting sucks.
You're cold,
you sleep on the floor,
it rains,
you don't see animals.
There's all kinds of things that sucks about hunting.
But guess what?
That's what brings you together.
You're all together in a tent.
Gale force winds and you're laughing your fucking balls off.
I listened to that podcast we did with Rinella after you had talked about it.
It was great.
It was awesome.
And we did that podcast soaking wet,
miserable for five days in a row.
You were so cold and do in Alaska,
you don't remember this,
but you were,
I remember there was the morning and you couldn't get dry cause all your shit
was to go ahead if you didn't bring waterproof anything and so you're wet.
It's in the morning,
six in the morning.
You were shaking so bad.
I don't know if you remember,
you were shaking so badly and I was too cold and miserable to say anything.
Your Lips,
you're a fucking lips.
We're going back and forth.
They look like they look like a short when it's grabbed the fucking like his
latest work,
his lips,
his big fat fucking fat dsls we're going like this back in June
they were,
they were literally going from left to right east to west,
east to west,
just the way the way a pitbull shakes a fucking rabbit and I was like,
dude,
those lips are fucking big,
meaty and cold.
That's all I kept saying.
I remember the one night where it didn't rain for like a few hours.
We started a fire.
She does with Cheetos.
And by the way,
a fire is the best thing.
Well,
when you're so miserable,
jerk off,
we don't just go,
Oh hell no.
You don't.
You take shits,
you take,
you get up in the middle of the night,
you got to Piss,
you go Neil and just go just an inch out of my fucking 10 I'm terrified.
I'm,
are you there?
Yes,
Dan Dodi and Mike.
I remember Mike,
we figured out how to make a fire with Cheetos.
Was it Dan Dodi's idea stand noting when you light Cheetos.
Cheetos,
light on fire and all the bullshit that's in Cheetos.
Best kindling
dude.
Slow,
slow burn.
Cheetos are incredible.
They stay a light forever.
It's a slow to fuck off once or the crunchy ones one.
That's the one thing.
All the Zombie movies and TV shows didn't get,
you know from this point on they're going to use the Cheetos.
It's a slow burn.
Beautiful.
Bernie took something like trees and we chopped trees down and hacked off the
bottom of the trees cause that was the driest spot.
We,
we hacked off the insides of the limbs because the outside of the lambs are more
wet.
Do we were Desperado we took paper and we started paper to develop a wet fire
and we'll wet five means like it's touch and go the whole way.
You're,
you're burning wet stuff and you're trying to get the driest stuff that's
available.
And Cheetos saved our ass.
And tell me,
if you tell me,
hey
you to feel this,
tell me if you didn't feel this.
And I'm not being dramatic when I say it.
It's like that's not possible.
Well that's true.
That's very true.
But when you're in the middle of that majestic wilderness,
literally that doesn't care about you.
You do get a sense.
There is a very,
there is a feeling of sadness,
of feeling of I'm being so insignificant that it makes you a little bit
depressed sometimes.
Yeah.
Did you feel that?
Did you ever feel that?
When we were sitting up at the top of this one of these ridges and you and I and
m Yonis were up there and we were taking a break and we sat up there and we
glassed this canyon and it was,
the rain was coming in and going out and we're looking around and I'm,
and my team was there too and we were just like,
Jesus Christ,
like this land doesn't give a fuck of your here are gone.
Yes.
It's going to be the same like a,
it's like a realization that no matter what mark you think you're laying,
it doesn't matter if you're fucking King Tut it does it.
It doesn't matter.
Matter you are ultimately,
it's all bullshit.
Yes.
Like you get this,
this entirely temporary existence and it the world and the universe is bigger.
Yes.
You still a grain of sand and that's hard to deal with because you want to pass
your genes and you want to be special and you want to show greatness and you
want people to remember your name after you're gone.
But ultimately that's not really what's important.
And that when you're confronted with that reality,
whether it's through psychedelic drugs over there,
it's through sitting on a mountain in Prince of Wales and best buddies sitting
there going,
man,
we can't even fucking find a deer.
We didn't find a deer for days and days so lonely.
It's such a lonely part of the world.
You can see for miles and miles it what you think about it.
For me,
what I thought about it was exactly what he's talking about,
like the notion that I'm so,
um,
I'm so insignificant and so much of my effort all day,
so much mind in a way.
So much of my effort.
First of all,
you also realize how vulnerable you are without food and water without like,
uh,
no how without the culture and the accumulated knowhow of how to survive in that
we should talk about what we bring.
We bring a freeze dried foods and we bring some,
some like hard snack bars.
No,
no,
we're fine.
We're not doing any survivor man,
firemen shit five to six days.
It's true.
We have a limited supply and it lets you know that like without this stuff,
cause we're not trying to live off this mountain ops food,
no,
whatever the fuck it's called,
whatever the meals or call.
I don't think it's mountain ops.
Not An ops is like a good protein,
a US company for hunters.
But um,
what will you realize?
It's like if I didn't have the stuff that I brought with me,
I'm not going to survive just living off the land.
It's hard as hell.
So you're saying you weren't worried about your Twitter followers?
Instagram,
you realize how much bullshit you need,
less sleep and just that it's not,
this cell phone doesn't work.
Isn't there a satellite?
No,
no.
Cell phones or direct to wreck.
It's like,
that's why you have this fake trees and the four or five cell phones.
No,
no,
no.
Not at all.
So set gps,
which is global positioning satellites,
GPS satellites.
I here,
I'll Glen ground and GPS global positioning satellites.
That's what it literally is.
Yes,
absolutely correct is not like the GPS in your iPhone is run by satellites.
This is how it works.
Let me explain.
Let me explain to you Eddie,
how it works.
Launch.
No,
no,
no.
It's all land based based on youtube science.
Let's avoid this.
We were just talking about just being alone,
being up there without any,
any connection to what you are used to realize how small you are.
I,
it's good to get away from the cell phone and the bullshit and I think,
I think cell phones are awesome.
I think computers are awesome.
I think Google is awesome.
I think it's,
I think reality shows are awesome.
I think basketball wives is awesome.
I think it's hilarious.
I think we should enjoy the most fucked up aspects of the greatest time people
who've ever been alive.
I think it's amazing,
but I think it's also good to push all this external dialogue aside and just how
do you feel about the world and how much of how you feel about the world is
honest and how much have you feel,
how you feel about the world is objective and how much of it is based on the
actual world itself and not the opinions of all these other people around you
and get a good look at who you are and what you think about that.
Do that.
Every night I try to shut myself up like around when I get home from Jujitsu and
teaching.
If there's some important email I got to get to,
I'll get to it.
If there's an important text or call I got to get to,
but generally I'm going to watch them bullshit ass TV for about an hour and a
half.
I don't want to hear,
but see when you're in,
when you're hunting,
when you're hunting on youtube and watch like the hottest,
when hunting those,
those usual escapes don't exist.
And a lot of times for real,
what you have is just yourself and the sound of your breathing men and dark.
Very hard.
It's sound.
It's a bit like feeling.
It's a bit like being in a free fall if you're not used to it.
And in the beginning,
like the first two days you might panic a little bit or you might kind of need
to hold on hold on thing.
But let me just back up.
She's sleeping.
Hope your sleep bed.
Yes,
absolutely.
Eddie,
you're the first American at top of Gracie.
He's no,
there's no pussy in you.
You don't have any pussy.
You are.
No,
no,
no.
Well you are as an slider.
No.
You honest about the way you feel.
There's a lot of people pretend to try to do that.
A lot of people pretend that they feel different than the way they actually
feel.
But when you,
when,
when push comes to shove and you perform,
it's one of the things like when we went to Sao Paulo,
like I'd seen you compete in the trials.
You competed in San Diego and the trials.
And those are the only times I saw you compete.
I started competing trials and I saw you compete on video.
We've looked at some video before,
but when I saw you compete,
when we flew down to San Paulo,
Sao Paulo,
and uh,
I saw you tap Gustavo's Dante says,
who's a Brazilian Jujitsu world champion?
I was like,
Oh shit.
Like Eddie Bravo knows how to perform an depression.
If there's a moment in the fight for me,
tell you something good about this.
It's 2003.
Okay.
Tapped a world champ.
Let me tell you something happens.
Eddie Bravo has got this dude in a position where a lot of traditional Brazilian
Jujitsu referees practitioners might not have understood what was going on.
And he was moving towards this guy's back and uh,
Eddie's holding onto him and the referee is insinuating that there's some
stalling and then it's going to have to be some moving.
And Eddie turns to him,
it looks to me was a star and he was,
I'm not stoned,
I'm about to take this dude's back and Gustava Dante,
she says like what?
Like,
and then all of a sudden Eddie takes his back and chokes him out and taps him
and Wa and gets up on a white truck truck.
Well,
when you will truck,
but when you were in the truck,
that's when the referee stepped in and said that you were stalling you.
I'm not dawn,
I'm about to take us back.
No,
no.
I was at,
when he came in,
what happened was I swept him.
We both pulled guard.
I forced,
I forced pull guard.
He pulled guard,
I poke guard.
What?
I tried to force each other.
I forced him on top of me,
swept him and he stayed in a position.
I had them in side control and he stayed in a position basically fetal away from
me.
So as soon as he got up his knees,
I was going to the truck or if he came into me,
I was going to the truck,
but he stayed there for minutes.
Adam inside Katoi to stay there and I'm like,
are you going to go this way?
Whatever way you go,
I'm going to put you on the truck.
But he didn't do shit.
He stayed there.
He knew the system.
Mark Layman was in his corner and saying don't do nothing.
So I was like just sitting.
I'm like,
okay.
I remember saying to the referee though,
I'm about to take his back.
The reason I take in a long road here at it,
the reason I said that,
no,
the reason I said cut,
we kind of,
the reason why I kinda wrapped it up and was that uh,
I knew mark layman stories before.
They said,
dude,
that the ref,
the referees in Brazil,
they're going to fuck you.
The Brazilians
rafts,
they don't like Americans.
And I heard that and I'm like all scared.
So I'm thinking this guy is actually going to stand me up.
So the only reason I said anything is because I thought,
oh shit,
this motherfucker is going to stand me up in Brazil.
He was talking to you and I said,
that's exactly what I said.
The Rub has taking the law.
But that's what I said
is you said I'm about to take his bachelor's gangster as fuck.
I'm about to take his back.
Yeah.
And then he took his back and choked him out some kinks to show,
but the only reason I said that was because I said don't stand me up.
You didn't want me to stand you up.
But you said the weight
because I was actually worried that we're going to stand me up.
I think.
I think that like w w I was thinking about what bothers me the most.
That's why I appreciate you.
You're talking about your friend.
Like what you did is pretty extraordinary and you'd have to take moments in life
to fucking say that the Wayne McCullough cause one of my favorite people on the
fucking plan.
I love it.
I love that guy.
And somebody was talking to Wayne with a lack of respect to me,
like the in the boxing gym.
They were acting like he was just a guy who holds mitts and I,
and I said to the guy,
go,
I got to just stop you for a second.
This is fucking important to me.
Can I stop?
You just really happened.
Yes,
you can ask Wayne.
I said,
but listen to,
he'll get mad at me for saying this,
but I want to say this.
Listen to this.
You asked such a Dick,
Dick,
buddy.
But listen,
this is my point.
My point is exactly what you were saying with Eddie.
I said,
a legit boxer didn't say this to you.
What's that?
A legit guidance.
Yes.
And I said this,
he said,
I said crossfit dude way super pale.
The way the person was tasked gags to trying to be,
I'm trying to kind of talk around this because somebody wasn't treating Wayne
with the kind of respect he deserves.
And I tried to explain,
I said,
listen man,
let me explain something cause this stuff.
He was a fucking world champion.
He was a world like WBC Carey.
Who are we talking about?
We're talking about the garbage man.
A famous person like I don't want you to say his name.
The dude working at Carl's Jr.
Yeah.
What kind of guy is he dropped.
He was a guy who was trying to box at the actual boxer.
Uh,
no.
Well,
he's just a guy.
Yeah,
just somebody who was like calling him gray.
Yes.
Who's somebody who's locked.
Great.
Okay.
So Greg was treating Wayne,
Wayne,
Greg,
the screening.
Wayne like,
Oh hey,
hold these myths from a essentially,
you know what I mean?
And I kind of,
for me,
that's what he does.
No,
he doesn't.
he's got a,
he's got a legit guy who was fighting right now for our big fight.
But the point I'm making is that the point I'm making is that you in life,
when you see somebody who accomplished a great deal,
you got to fucking give it up.
You have to have respect for that.
You have to have gratitude for it.
You have to market.
You have to treat it with some reverence.
Reverence is important.
We can't use him as an example.
Here's what is important.
There's no reason to disrespect him.
He's not like he's doing anything.
Even if you will,
to a legend.
You should.
Of course.
No,
but it's more than that.
You know that he's highly accomplished in the sport that you're attempting
to metal.
Say Olympics.
It's amazing.
Get your fucking champion boxer.
But,
but here's what I'm saying.
It's like why would you want to say bad things about him ever?
But people,
what I'm saying is people,
they might,
who knows?
Yeah.
But people who don't express gratitude like that and don't like they know older
boxer though.
So my hearing's young guy who has no idea.
Here's what I did.
Here's what it is.
That's what bothered me.
People know that when you have something and it's amazing and then you lose it,
you realize you're not as great as you once were.
So they recognize that Wayne McCullough was a world champion boxer,
a silver medalist in the Olympics,
and it's athletic peak.
He was lazy love throughout the land and he's not there anymore.
So they recognize this as an opportunity to see someone who has diminished from
the previous ice and they try to attack.
Exactly.
Try to attack him to make him feel bad because they know psychologically that
this has to have some sort of an effect on the way his self esteem because they
never touched because they never fucking came close to that kind of
accomplishment doing it.
It's time to bring him down.
It's an animal instinct,
an animalistic,
and that's a bummer.
But Shit,
haters are lose.
Exactly correct.
They have to be,
and that's what I was experiencing recently.
A winner and also be haters.
They don't go.
Exactly.
Yeah,
and that's what I was trying to say.
I go,
if you can't celebrate and have some reverence for what that do did or anybody
like that you,
that's your fucking problem.
And that,
that,
oh well they never been beat up then probably.
You're right buddy.
So should good luck.
And I fucking gentlemen this cheese away.
Everyone's Joe out.
It's,
yes.
I was watching some jokes outside the training footage of somebody put it on
Twitter today.
I was like,
Jesus Christ dies.
Dad,
man.
Oh my God.
It's fucking hand speed was retarded.
He was so fast.
He lost a Hopkins right now.
He Peed Hopkins would be Roy Jones Jr beat Hopkins where he appeared later.
Duff.
He did he beat out undefeated.
Yes,
he did.
He beat Hopkins.
He'd be Roy Jones Jr.
We just don't accept him because he wasn't in medic gone.
No,
cause he was a,
he was an English gentleman.
He gets no credit plus and Joe cows.
Augie.
He's like an all time great.
I mean he might not call rugged mother fucker.
He might've retired.
Does it have as a 46.0 this is fucking running around saying
I'm asleep and I'm causing you can't sleep on John's Bernard.
Bernard Hustler,
Kessler,
a beat.
A lot of like Jeff Lacey.
Jeff Lacey was one of his big wins like early on his career Talker,
but Hopkins,
the beeper,
nine hop.
Whose name talking to him,
he'd be Roy Jones Jr.
What was the year that fight?
Oh eight oh eight enrolling in the same year.
I honestly,
Roy was not the Roy of his prime
oh eight he was still pretty bad ass,
wasn't me.
No,
no.
Well,
compared to everybody in this room,
he's bad ass right now.
If we all had to get it in the right jobs,
junior could ever five tequila shots.
Box the shit out of everyone in this room.
I think everyone in this room to take that silly bitch down.
Fuck that dude.
Hey Man.
[inaudible] ass fucking reference.
This is what I'm talking about.
You hate her mother fucker went dark.
You went dark.
It's real life.
I'm a critical thinker.
I said I sat directly behind roads engineer and this was my monologue in my
head.
I was quite like this.
I was going to quit his full time that I was doing this.
I was saying stuff like this.
It's got a lot of fast twitch muscle.
Look at these fucking traps.
It's got a weird head,
but he can move that head.
He could kick my ass right now,
one of what I would do if I had to fight and they're just are all the questions
I asked 49 years old.
I'm asking these questions,
Dick pic and an elevator.
He's taken me down.
[inaudible] you down.
Knock me down.
That's what,
wait,
listen and elevators where you gave your best shot.
I know it's not getting to win.
No Bitch.
The fuck out of my,
he's got a dirty budget.
Tight shoulders come up.
You shoot him.
What's he doing?
He's hitting elbows.
He's got no gloves,
elbows.
He hitting bone mother fucker.
That's what I say is I fucking bring his niece.
I bring him in down and then I bar with my bad arm bar,
my blue belt.
Armbar Brendan,
what do you think about that?
I don't see that
you guys have her a job with heavyweight for real,
like a real roll.
Eight minute round.
Let's go for real dude with Brenda Shadow.
Is that a yes or no?
I know I had rolled a ton.
I always fucked with.
I have.
I have grabbed him in a perfect head,
an arm lock,
thrown my hips out.
Judo style brought his head and he's a Harmon with a cable with a Grable grip.
Kept my chin tight and looked at them and gone.
He was trying to take a nap and I go,
you're going fucking nowhere,
motherfucker.
And had them tight.
I mean Armand had tight judo,
hips,
slave,
hips splayed.
Fucking uh,
what's his name?
The,
here you go.
This is another one that's high fall.
This is correct.
Look at this.
Doctor's chicken is
amazing with no hormone supplements.
You don't just break.
Nah.
Fuck you.
Look at that high fucking you look at,
you'd be Super Fun.
If I was near that I'd be like [inaudible] he does.
He loves tongue.
Has He ever gotten,
you
know,
49 year old comic did not be penny.
It's not a call and he beat,
he fucking catch you every night we got to stop talking over each other.
I know,
but I mean I couldn't do and I had a gun.
It would be
a problem.
He does whatever he wants.
That's why you got to let them come.
I've been talking about that on it.
It always comes down to the cone and these lessons is a reason why big people
exist.
They were podcasting for four hours.
Fuck.
Wasn't it measuring time?
Is this still going though?
Who gives a fuck but we weren't allowed to.
It was that we can do whatever.
It's like we're in Alaska,
but Jamie,
Jamie,
I'm going to be cut off at three hours.
No more rules.
I'm tired.
I can't do it anymore.
No one's gone.
Cages.
We'll break this podcast up into part one and part two.
I can't be employed in A's.
Can't do it anymore.
I have it left in me.
Is drained like a sponge exist.
Hey,
be free.
This podcast for us,
thanks to your urging has been a life changer.
Going to let you
know,
excuse me,
talking about podcast each other.
You see such a random movie trail that she goes a little bit.
Let's talk about tip.
Going to want to see it though.
Jamie,
what were we trying to encourage?
Eddie Bravo and to bringing back any bravo radio and you want to talk about
tickling funny.
I don't have,
I don't have to get punched in the face and work as a podcast.
It's incredible.
I loved and doing my podcast.
But I feel like sometimes,
you know when you do a podcast and you've got to,
you get new audience and you've got to tell the fucking same story over and
over.
I hate saying the same.
You know when people start saying over here,
he goes,
why would you say the same story over?
And it comes up here on a podcast.
I've done that.
It's you gotta say you gotta kind of,
you got to get an abbreviate it and say I've talked about this before,
but unfortunately,
unless that's like cut up in like a clip,
it's hard for people just started listening to your podcast to find that.
So it becomes annoying cause you're speaking of so many people like you were
getting like what?
Like 50 a hundred thousand downloads,
how many downloads?
How many again,
nothing.
Whatever you're getting nothing.
Let's say,
let's say,
let's say you're getting 5,000 even if you're getting five times,
that's 5,000 fucking people in an arena.
I mean Ari and I had this conversation when we first started talking about
Twitter because aren't get on Twitter.
He's like,
I only got 2000 followers.
I go,
what would you think if you went to a show and you're like,
it's only 2000 people.
You would never think that.
You'd never think that.
You'd be like,
Holy Shit,
there's 2000 people.
He's like your art or the,
yeah,
I'm right.
Yeah.
There's 2000 people listening and eventually you're going to say something funny
and someone's going to find out,
I'm not going to spread it to five people will spread it to 10 you'll have 1500
people and six months.
How many Twitter followers do you have till road?
Um,
I don't know.
Over a million.
1.9 or something like that.
What is it,
Jamie?
Is it Jeremy?
1.9100000000000001 point 9 million Instagram followers.
1.1 million fans.
It was crazy.
You know it's,
listen,
you guys will have that too.
It's an accumulative effect.
There's girls out there to just do nothing but stick their ass in front of a
camera.
They have like 10 times as many as I blessed.
We're
Russian broad.
Oh my God.
I almost jerked off in front of my friends.
Let me see her.
She's so hot.
She was that high.
It didn't make any sense.
I'm going to tell you how frustrated I don't want to get more followers to
please tell me now.
I have to know 10 fucking piano later.
I don't remember it a farm on Bro.
Don't be a bitch.
Don't I don't remember Jamie.
You know I just randomly found too dark hair.
Light hair dark.
Yeah.
You guys are getting more followers.
She would bring her up.
Let's move on.
This is what's important.
Um,
it's uh,
it's about consistency.
Like when you're,
when you're,
um,
using social media,
it's about honesty and consistency and you guys are super honest and you shoot
her consistent.
So it's going to be people don't like you.
It's inevitable.
People don't like me.
They don't like Eddie.
Oh,
Jesus.
Lord.
She's a good girl.
Those are muscular quads.
Yeah,
she does some squads.
Yeah.
Bitch can jump over buildings.
I'm going to come up.
Pitch can jump rope your day.
Oh my fuck.
Oh God.
Changes top 10.
Jamie
thinking about is the [inaudible] property was about take it down and you guys
all I'm thinking about as the milking properties,
the fact that pussy,
he's like
farmer's hand squeezing out a wet pair of socks.
A farmers hand,
a pharmacy.
Man,
you guys want,
if you guys want to come or was
down by the river with a fucking set of sheets
that bitches onto my site,
her quads are way.
It's the,
it's the let's come cut podcast guys.
One more picture of that girl for the hell of no,
no,
no more.
Who brought the fucking Puritan to the party?
You know,
it's a beautiful thing about potty web belts on your hats.
The beautiful thing about politics,
we have all of us together.
It's like a legit network and not just us,
but everybody else out there.
You know,
there's always been networks like CBS and ABC and NBC,
but those networks like businesses,
but like we're a network of friends.
Like that's a new thing.
That's a new thing.
Like everything that you do helps me.
Everything that I do helps you.
We all help each other.
You guys come on my podcast,
we blow it up on Twitter.
We put it up on Instagram.
We do a fight companion all together.
Everybody blows up.
This is a network,
like an organic network as opposed to like a business network.
Well,
we sat down and said I needed to control 40% of this one glomerate and try and
there's no agenda.
It's just friends.
There's no agenda,
no paperwork,
no paperwork.
Everybody's cool.
Everybody helps everybody.
You know,
if there's ever like shows it need to be tweeted.
Everybody's happy to tweet for everybody.
I see everybody doing it.
We all do it for each other.
Our comedian friends do it for each other.
I didn't notice that shirt.
The kido kid get yo slim off.
He's Quito.
You don't even know about that shirt and you're in the business with him.
I don't.
I don't have them sign off.
It is the first time he sees barely penetrate.
You just make sure it's,
and I'm like,
Hey,
good job.
They go on sale this week,
Brian.
I called them the Kido kid at the beginning of our last podcast together.
Awesome.
Still,
I was in Arizona this week and people are yelling,
I'm Tito Kid,
the kid too and this is fucked up cause you can use the Kido kids.
They can't stand.
It's more legit.
What will,
if you put something before kid for me,
what would you call me?
The old kid,
I call him creepy creepy kid for sure.
The perfect kid.
Mildly Delusional Kid.
Briefly.
The wrinkle kid align kid the lying about the fact that my dad,
how about the fact that I told the story like a really good long story dramatic
and my father in front of a bunch of people goes like this,
like friends and he goes,
now how much of that story do you think is actually true?
That's right,
mother.
Fuck.
Well the problem is you understand drama so well that you'll occasionally
sprinkle it in as long as you keep the ethics of the original idea of storing
about sir.
Don't know what you're talking to.
You are more concerned with the entertainment value of what you're saying and
you are the voracity of the true.
I'm already involved statements.
Benjamin Button.
A case is showing,
why are we showing that Guy Jamie decided to spice it up with a random shows
like a naked man in the mirror with glasses on.
Yeah,
Benjamin Button.
I think overall like you,
you would never change the actual results of the story you're talking about.
Right?
But you would flavor that story with additional spices that weren't in the
original recipe.
Like a lawyer.
You'll throw some shit in there to make it better.
And I appreciate that.
We took a lie detector test,
but as a good friend,
I have to throw things through a filter and when you tell me something,
I have to go skeptical.
Skeptical.
I love this dude.
But let me see where I go with this.
[inaudible] he goes [inaudible] yeah.
Hey,
I took a lie detector test.
He asked me,
I said,
ask me all the tech went on your site or your psycho.
No,
the problem was it then I should go to your,
that's us when Brian tells any story.
So what happened?
Well,
she said,
she goes,
I live across the board about everything that she said.
He lies about everything you are true of the ass mate to see.
And it was,
it just didn't work out.
So I went and I sweat.
Here's the thing about a lie detector test.
Okay,
here's the thing.
As soon as you're measuring something,
you're changing what that thing is because you're making someone conscious of
the fact that you're measuring it.
And so if you were a completely self conscious person who is always aware of how
people are viewing him,
like Brian Cowen,
which is one of the reasons why you're so entertaining.
It's cause you really want everybody around you.
You're very accommodating.
Yes.
And you're a very like,
like Brian,
like way more than me.
He suffers fools were around fools.
I'm like,
I am seeing us fucking wasted time.
Is a cloud common.
We've got to get in the car.
We got to get out of.
Brian loves him.
Oh my God.
He loves it.
He loves him a doofus and loves him in.
But it's because he's so accommodating.
Yeah.
He's like such a nice guy.
He's a cop and I can't do it any.
One of my favorite pastimes is to go through my life and think about
all how much time I would have saved if I had just walked away from certain
people and just listened to me.
How many times have I told you yes,
this has been a dozen times.
Like a lot of skies retarded.
This girl's crazy.
Yeah.
Like we've got to get away from him.
Like this guy is gonna fucking take you to jail.
You and I will both tell him about the same guy.
Oh,
you don't know or no,
hold up.
You don't know the same guy?
No.
See I bet cha no you do not.
I know by 1994
I can count from for 28 years old.
This is like,
you know,
rock card.
Do you know how you have those uh,
those goggles that people wear when they go swimming,
they doing laps in the pool.
Imagine if you took those and you painted black around everything except like a
pencil eraser and the seven in the center of each one of those.
And that's how you looked at the world.
That's how Brian would narrow life.
Just girls,
girls and Butare hints
and good food when he,
he'd have these friends and I'd meet these guys,
but I'll be like,
oh yeah,
Hey,
nice to meet you.
Come here.
You gotta get the fuck away from this guy.
What are you doing?
But throw in two dogs and parents and parents,
girl,
while I'd read Chris' House and he's got no door knob.
Okay?
First of all,
I have no door.
No,
he lives in Venice beach.
He's got no door on.
I walk in this house,
he's got a book sitting on the table and it's like a check Carol Dweck book.
I'm like,
you're not reading that book.
You want girls to think you reading that book.
Well,
I called you.
Remember I called you?
You fucking,
I called him up.
I go,
dude,
I'm laying book.
There's this girl.
I went to Princeton.
She was fucking really smart.
And I called Joe like,
Oh,
I have to call you because I,
you need to know that I'm a fraud.
But if I tell you I'm a fraud,
I'm not good bro.
I'm laying books out about around my fucking place.
So the girl things I read and I'm keeping,
I'm opening the pages,
but the fact that I'm telling my my best friend and I'm doing that,
it means I'm not a fraud like I'm lying but I'm not lying to you is a true
statement,
but the chronology code,
the chronology is broken.
I had informed him first that he was a fraud with his books on the coffee table
and I knew it and he was and he denied it and then admitted it and then called
me.
All right.
That's the actual,
there you go.
I don't know about that.
It's 100% true,
but you did come clean actually you have to come clean.
You cannot lie to your friends.
Your friends have to know who you are.
Man.
Isn't that funny?
Is that like like being a guy who was like secretly deep is attractive somehow
to the genetics of a woman.
It's searching for a man with character because the guy who secretly deep who
can deal with shit,
maybe it gets up in the morning,
sets his alarm clock or 4:00 PM and goes running up a hill.
That guy can understand what it's like to overcome pressure and that's,
that's a peeling to women's genetics because they know that this whole
supermarket highway thing,
this ain't going to last if shit hits the fan.
This is great
for like a small brief window of history,
but there's a thing called a super volcano and it's sitting in Yellowstone
national park and it's a continent killer and every six to 800,000 years he
fucking explodes and everything dies and the earth gets cool because it goes
into nuclear winter and the last time it happened was 800,000 years ago and it's
fucking dumb.
So they need to know you better,
enjoy this,
enjoy this.
So fuck the muscular guys that wake up in the morning,
be ready.
You listen,
you don't understand for what a fucking volcano lava,
you pausing and I hunt.
You stayed behind me once again,
find the fucking food.
This is what I think.
You can't control your breathing.
We're going to starve the universe.
The universe is just as content with us being hit by a fucking asteroid and
being knocked back down to single celled organism.
This is as it is.
You know,
they don't kill us succeeding and figuring out a way to get to Mars.
The universe is just as good,
just as happy with either result.
You can find out all this paperwork in that fucking air force base in Laurel
Canyon.
[inaudible]
into it.
I am going to listen.
I get home Tom's,
there can be no doubt that the government has tried to manipulate the
consciousness of the population.
It can be no doubt,
boom,
power over people form should do it.
And Nixon was,
Nixon was like a fucking total sneaky piece of shit.
I mean that's what Nixon is hold Dame hook.
They proven that Nixon's war on drugs was about controlling the civil rights
movement and controlling the antiwar movement.
It's 100% been proven.
It's one of the things that's being discussed right now in mainstream newspapers
and mainstream magazines.
The reason why they went after marijuana and mushrooms and LSD is cause they
wanted a silence.
The antiwar people in the civil rights period,
Ooh,
but they didn't create the doors.
No,
what's your split?
But they did,
but they didn't mean to.
Here's the thing,
you can't engineer beautiful creativity.
Don't you love her badly?
You can't do that.
You can't do that
reg on through
that guy.
Eddie,
you are,
you're a brilliant creative guy and one of the reasons why you're brilliant
creative,
thank you this because you,
you were repressed as a child.
You encountered a lot of stress and bullshit and a lot of,
uh,
a lot of people that were like counting against you.
Yeah.
They were rooting against you and you figured out a way to rise through that and
figure your way through this maze of life on your own.
And it's because of that pressure that created this creativity in my opinion.
I mean,
I might be wrong,
liked the doors of Jujitsu,
but I think that's it.
This the same thing that happens to a lot of guys,
whether it's Kurt Cobain or Jimi Hendrix or,
or Jim Morrison,
I think you,
you deal with the wrong,
you see the wrong thing.
You see a dad was an alcoholic or beats his mom and this fucking chaos in the
house gets repossessed and you see all the flaws of the people before you and
oftentimes the most together people are the people that grew up with parents
that were in together because they realize,
Whoa,
I got to realize what these people are doing wrong and I've got to get it right
myself.
So when you see a guy like Jim Morrison,
is this like fucking brilliant freak who came out of nowhere.
If you really look at musical history.
Exactly.
This is what I'm saying.
If you look at musical history like the 1950s we're like the doorway to this
rock and roll thing.
Like Elvis came through and Cherry Lee Lewis and there's trust,
but there's all this weird music came through and then the Beatles and then
there was these rock motherfuckers and there was all these drugs that are
involved and there's also the war and everybody's trying to get the fuck in the
civil rights movement and the civil rights people that and be able to vote in
1964 was when they were given granted the right to vote.
So it has all 1964 it has all the elements of of classic suppression and
Response to the suppression creative outburst.
But isn't that creative outburst is one of the most beautiful in like artistic
accomplishments of the human race.
If you look at the 1960s look at the Beatles,
you look at the led Zepplin,
look at the doors,
look at the who look at the music of the 60s look at Jefferson star ship.
Oh my God,
no one's,
no one's writing great music depressants and it's not happening.
All I'm saying is I don't know what the fuck's going on.
All I'm saying if it's true,
if it might not even be true,
if it's true that all those bands came from Laurel Canyon and they were all kids
of air force intelligence officers,
that's fucking weird.
Maybe that's what they related on,
but you do understand that they would ship,
the parents would be busy at work.
They don't even have time to spend time with their fucking kids.
The kids eventually wind up being drug out x.
They go to school,
they smoked cigarettes,
a hand with the cool kids and go hang out by the fucking the auto shop and they
learn how to fix tires and none of them,
none of them got drafted without a doubt.
Without a doubt.
The parents would use their influence to keep their children from being drafted.
Course,
it's happened throughout throughout history,
dig train.
They become rock stars and coincidentally,
but Eddie Cox,
it's a coincidence that you're assuming that,
but you're assuming you're assuming.
Yes.
All the bands.
You're assuming the Muller postures thing there all Friday,
Eddie.
Now you're assuming the most preposterous thing.
You're assuming that the most creative beautiful moment in music history,
arguably the 1960s that is what is traded by retards.
So fucking stupid.
That got a job with the government.
Correct.
How dare you?
Shit so farfetched.
Weary Eddie.
It's obvious we're suppression and this.
Why don't you read but don't do not.
Do not,
do not recognize the pressure.
Air Force intelligence space making propaganda films in Laurel Canyon.
All those bands.
You can name them all the doors,
the eagles,
Linda Ronstadt,
all of them.
They were all kids.
Let me ask you this,
let me work there.
What would be the benefit?
What would be the benefit the government would have?
I'm making off awesome music like the doors be besides being awesome.
I don't know.
You tell me.
The government doesn't have a music department
since.
Father,
what about your dad?
What about my dad?
I didn't even tell and dude,
he didn't orchestrate that.
What I'm talking about,
that's what I'm talking about.
Both of us don't even talk to our dads.
Why the fuck would you assume that Jim Marrs and talked to his dad?
I would assume that it's such a bad motherfucker.
He was close to his fall.
Come on.
If you're close to your dad,
you don't do acid.
You don't pull your dick out of Miami and get arrested.
So legit point guys is good dads.
Don't pull it.
That's that.
Sam,
you guys,
this podcast is out of fucking control and these handlers,
how far on the whole 10 control and that's velvet
mule deer,
Rochelle,
the cuts or eyes fucking mule deer.
They're much,
hey,
are we going to,
we're going to shoot some mule deer with Mongo.
You just no way you were doing by that time.
Unless we get some serious practices.
Look at me.
I don't think you understand this difficult.
It is target.
I'm getting my,
I'm getting my boat fixed.
I got to pay.
Did Not certainly did not have,
he's never even shot an arrow.
He came over my house once.
He couldn't pull my Boback bullshit.
I wasn't there.
You tell the truth.
What happened?
I had a fucking trick.
I have a trek shoulder.
His jet,
so he fuck.
Fuck that Nigga.
He hasn't got a 60 pounds.
Hasn't pull the bow back yet,
but we have to.
It's not ethical at this stage because we're talking about going out in August
and right now it's almost June.
Cyber progressed.
You think you're killing cause you started small with the little birds and shit.
Do you think you'll ever get to that now you're a bears and shit.
I didn't know
the first wife killer where you don't eat them and they're intelligent.
I don't want to eat.
Scars are very smart.
They're smart compared to what they know to eat their babies because the baby's
going to come back to haunt them later.
That's awesome.
Intelligence Bro.
That's a vision,
that argument that's like this motherfucker.
He's a little baby right now,
right now,
but he's going to grow up really quick.
Buck,
I'm going to try to fuck my shit up.
I better eating one of these,
a little baby after a,
you learn that in the wild.
That's the law of the fucking wilderness,
not why they kill each other.
They kill their babies because it brings the female back into heat so they could
fuck them like that.
So what happens is the female have a cub and then they'll go into their Dan and
they'll hibernate and their,
and they come out in the spring and the mail be horny.
But the females like I already have babies.
Fuck you.
And then so the male eats the typical not,
yeah,
it's
the same old shit.
This species,
the species.
It's the same shit.
He got crazy at all.
I got to pee.
Hold on.
You guys talked about this for the first time.
I've bet four hours,
man.
24 20 Oh my God.
My wife's going to kill me 20 minutes as a podcast.
Kate,
someone keep the podcast.
Let me just some doors here.
Okay then gentlemen,
Jim Morrison,
texting [inaudible] bad ass.
You want to do some of your how you want to be a fucking warrior?
Show me Eddie.
Eddie,
right here.
You want to be a warrior?
Tell me how bad you want to be a fucking warrior.
Tell me how bad you want it.
You want it bad?
I fucking practice psychic until I started coming off the ground.
I,
that's what I heard.
Yeah.
Cause that's where can I be honest?
I'm not trying to be a dick.
My Jab to practice my jab,
I catch birds out of the air.
I know it sounds weird by her.
Hey,
I hate to be a dick.
But the other day Brian was telling me how he thinks the whole nine 11 things
just you think you're full of shit.
Of course he's on that.
Sarah said he's on that side.
I love Eddie like you know,
no matter,
no matter what,
I'm getting so much that I never argued matter what he's,
he's your donors
because I like any too much.
I don't argue about how many times I've said it on our podcast.
I go,
I even when he goes into his,
no,
because I liked him too much.
I would love to believe that government and everything that I say to I would
fucking,
no,
no.
I'm talking about Brian.
He believes everything inside.
So no,
I don't think he does.
Why he doesn't believe everything the government says.
Tell me one big incident.
Once that he doesn't trust them.
No,
he totally does because he trusts everything about nine 11 and there's holes
everywhere.
So if you trust watching tower seven completely free,
fall on video from five different angles and you believe the government,
eight years later when I finally came out and they said,
oh,
it got too hot,
you believe that Shit,
you're on that side.
There's nothing.
There's,
that's the litmus test.
There's nothing you could say to those guys.
Nothing I give up as soon as that's the,
that's why I go to tower seven I go,
do you believe tower seven collapse at free fall speed because it got hot.
If they say yes,
then I'm done.
I'm done.
Well does that to me?
He believes all gum.
No that,
no,
no.
If you believe that that's the worst one.
It's on video.
Five different angles.
There's many on video demolition experts looking at this and saying,
hey,
experts that don't agree with that.
You don't have any video American sizing.
Amazing.
There's no amazing debunking all of your theories.
Okay,
so you believe tower southern collapsed at free fall speed because it got too
hot.
I don't know anything about,
I know nothing about that stuff.
When they ask,
when do you know what?
Let me,
let me educate you a little bit.
When they had a press conference,
a press conference with Nist,
the National Institute of Standards and technology,
they're the ones that came out and explained what happened.
Tower something.
When they asked them widened.
Did you guys check for explosive
exclusives?
It's really simple.
It's like kindergarten shit.
When they asked the head of kindergarten,
why didn't you check for explosives?
Why didn't you test for explosives on tower seven?
They said there was no reason to.
There was no ties to any hunches.
There was no witnesses.
Meanwhile,
there's about an hour of witnesses,
firemen,
policemen,
insane bombs went off.
Bumps.
Well,
there's video of Brian's going up.
Bombs went up and the guy said,
we didn't check for bombs because there was no witness.
What about that ceremony?
Who flew those planes?
Nothing.
Anybody can say it was remote control.
I can say to you,
you,
there's nothing I can say I provide a complete video evidence for you.
I broke it down for you,
but you're still saying you're still,
it's still not enough.
How much?
Nothing I can say.
I haven't said anything.
Well,
let me play devil's advocate.
He's fucking
momentarily.
Um,
when you look at tower 70 clearly looks like you can control demolition,
right?
It looks like the way it implodes,
and I seen it so long because it looks like a controlled demolition.
Is it possible that you could get a diesel fire in a building where the fuel
burns so hot that it fucks up all of the supporting beams to this building and
it all just gives out and impossible takes on each other.
That's an,
I'm not a structural engineer,
so that's what I'm saying.
I don't understand what happens.
There's 100,000 architects and engineers in the association and one by one it
was like 200 then it was 1,530 2000 that no,
no,
it's true.
It's not that you're simply wrong.
Hold on.
Fires made the building do that fire.
I don't know,
but maybe you don't trust the government.
You think the government blame me,
but,
but you don't think that's fucking fishy.
A detective would be all over that.
Like a fuck like flies on schematize something.
If that was my building,
I bought my fucking money back.
Shit,
crump,
there's some kind of hypnosis.
Who's fluid?
No,
no,
no.
We're not talking about that.
Nope.
That was three that went down.
But the third one was reported on because they knew the majority of the people
like you real smart would not even let go.
He said real smart after you just shit on you.
This shit on you.
Eddie is swaying the fuck out of me.
Kissing.
Listen,
three buildings went down,
two of them got hit by a plane.
One didn't.
I detective would be so all over at lawyers would be all over that shit.
And you don't trust the government.
You believe that government are criminals,
but yet you've got their back on this
than the tower dropping it.
Paul says there's a problem.
I know.
Is that possible?
But Eddie,
here's the problem.
None of us really understand structural engineering.
But understand what happened here.
None.
Exactly,
but when you hear guys that do one by one,
not all of them.
[inaudible] scientific American was scientific American architect,
their own,
they're all bought off.
Dude.
If you just look at scientific Americans,
but when you look at what's going on,
like when people look at what trends are going on,
this is the trend that's going on.
The trim is that there's 100,000 architects and engineers in the association and
bit by bit it's growing and growing because you know what?
The Guy,
that's the head of all that.
He's sitting down you saying there's 100,000 architects and engineers and died
11 in some some clubs,
association of architects and engineers.
There's a national association.
There's a 2,500 there's 100,000 of them will and 2,500 plus.
No,
no,
there's not.
No,
no,
no.
That's different.
100,000 in the whole association,
not including that 11 they don't give a fuck.
I know.
I'm saying 2,500 think is because Joe and I take a piss and I was lost that
Brendan,
Brendan thing.
It's the same thing that we were talking about before.
It's the same thing.
It's the same thing and everything.
It's exact same thing.
There's two ways you could look at it like,
Hey,
let me ask some questions.
Out of the hundred thousand did these 2,500 km from the hundred thousand being
shown the evidence and only 2,500 believe it or we're only 2,500 shown.
Does that make a difference?
Does that make a difference in your,
in you whether you jumped?
Of course it does.
So the reality is the hundred thousand don't even know.
Most of them don't even know three towers went down.
These are architects,
engineers,
that tends to look into it.
So one by one,
one by one that it's growing and growing because 50 at a time,
they're getting 15 at a time.
They're showing them the evidence of it going,
Holy Shit.
Mother fuckers were brought down.
That's what's going on.
But it's like what we're talking about,
what going steady it shot,
what's going on.
He,
anybody examining the evidence is gonna know.
Three towers went down.
Everybody knows three times when people don't know.
Three towers went down now got talking about the do architects,
engineers,
you don't think the predominant group of art,
if you looked at a million architects and engineers,
you don't think that like 999,999 would fucking know that tower seven was
brought down with tower one and tower to,
can I talk just because
it's like I just cannot go.
Oh my gosh.
Just because,
yeah,
just because you're an architect and an engineer and you're registered nothing
and you're registered in the association.
Just because you're an architect and an or an engineer and on and you're
registered in the association,
does it mean you have extra,
you're privy to extras knowledge,
right?
On nine one
one because the overall,
the overall knowledge of nine 11 is most people don't know.
Three towers went down.
That's an actual effect.
So these agree at he's architects and engineers don't even know,
but when they get to sit down,
all of them 100% when it gets into,
I know the guy had them on my pocket.
He's the head of all this shit.
Every one of them goes,
oh shit.
We've been hunting edict.
That's what's going on.
11 not 11
you saw tower seven go down with that,
but hold on a second.
Architects and the engineers don't know about tower seven but you do know of
course,
because they didn't look into their normal people.
They do think just because you're an architect,
an engineer,
you're going to get,
you're going to get an email,
you're going to get an email.
Most people don't know.
Even today,
I don't even know about three times.
You're going to get an email.
They're not researching it.
The ones that did contact or an engineer,
and you've passed through some sort of architectural course and you assume,
I assume you got some sort of a master's degree in engineering and someone asks
you to commentate on one of the most historic attacks in human civilization.
After some research,
you're going to do some research,
but you're going to look at all the different buildings,
100% talking about Eddie 100% if you ask them to examine what happened at tower
seven they're going to look at tower seven if you think they're going to talk to
them about nine 11 and not bring up tower seven that's crazy.
That's like,
that's like covered is up any,
nobody's covering it up.
You don't get to that level eight without research,
right?
Not any.
It's not,
it's not covering up.
It's just there's so much going on that day.
The tower seven seemed less important and because of the media to tower one and
two,
which were both hit by plane,
but whatever it was,
it didn't.
Whether it was an intentional cover up tower seven or it was a cover up because
there was so much hoopla.
Most people don't know this is what's going on.
So what Richard Gauges,
Jed.
Eddie,
why don't you think that architects don't know?
Why would you think that engineers don't know that?
We don't know.
You don't know?
I don't know.
But what we do know is sit down.
They say,
Oh shit,
I didn't know.
Maybe.
Oh Eddie,
calm.
Come on man.
That's not true.
You don't know that.
That's
crazy about this.
You're getting so emotional.
We were not involved in this like it's not a part of our lives.
And you don't know what they knew before they look.
You want to,
you want to think the tower seven collapse because they got hot to you
want what I want.
I don't know what.
I don't want to make a conclusion without having any facts.
What I look at tower seven Heti not true.
It looks like your control can be used in court.
There's plenty of expert testimonials and that kind of shit can be used in court
to prove a case.
And there's plenty of expert testimonial on video by nine 11 but you know
there's also expert testimonial that the diesel fuel from the
basement.
Show me that
there isn't.
Well show him a townie.
Many.
And how many architects medialink afternoon telling you anything you can
send you links.
Come on,
crush your shit.
You're talking about some links that don't exist.
You're talking about is looking right at you.
Yes.
He's pointing right at Chavez Chavez and of mouth
shop.
They try to educate.
You probably think that 11 was committed by motivated Islamic fundamentalist.
We should take this time to address all the nerds out there,
the feel disenfranchised,
but all this violent testosterone.
We love you too.
We all love each other.
We love everybody.
And you didn't say a word and uh,
Brian dogging this.
Brian has some thoughts on this.
I'll just wrap it up for let's say it's amazing that Eddie has an inside scoop
when every major publication from the Guardian,
from the York Times The New York Times to,
to Lawrence Wright or won a Pulitzer Prize winning book called the looming tower
that actually trace don't his fucking quote people to,
to,
I mean Time magazine,
Newsweek.
Uh,
I mean,
they've all been bought off by the Illuminati or the government and Eddie's
youtube and his,
his inside inside scoop has the truth and all the rest of us are.
I want to thank Eddie for being who the fuck he is because he's a national
treasure and I fucking love the guy.
I love Ed.
He's a good person.
As a good my fucking,
I want a fee.
Jack says I want to get on that call,
but I agree.
Please let me in this little petty you what?
I don't like the government.
You'll get them to stop talking over each year,
the Illuminati one of these days and I'm going to make a false flag directly for
Warner brothers and you're going to believe all that shit.
I want it.
That's definitely going to happen.
I'm glad we're talking about it.
That's totally not a waste of time.
No,
not at all.
We make it happen.
Watch Eddie Bravo is a national treasure and they have it in my head.
I just want you to not give the government so much credit.
They're not that organized was also a real,
that one
they couldn't do as a real benefit to not getting emotional and yelling about
things that you're not exactly sure about.
And when we talk about some client,
what's the better approach to step back and go,
what are the possibilities to the,
how much do I have invested in one particular argument that I've already like
the old chairs and I go to tower seven is cause that's the most obvious one.
That's the snap.
It's fucking curious for sure.
But it's not obvious you need a,
you need a new nor I as an architect or an engineer.
But it's obviously it looks like a controlled demolition is not obvious why it
fell a bar.
Shuri is not an expert.
So when a jury sits in and they listened to expert testimony research
and I was talking to you,
you know there's people out there to beat believe crazy shit,
right?
Like lipstick converting and you know what I'm talking about.
Have you ever listened to people,
you don't need this shit.
Come on man.
I ride the middle of a fucking 47 tower of 47 story fucking skyscraper collapses
a free fall speed and you're going to believe fire fucking did that shit.
Is the earth flat?
No,
it's fucking round.
Is it like a pair?
Right?
We should have what?
Tyson Muckross he says,
God Damn Daddy
Grassy was the pitch.
Is the Russell,
is there a flat lays and gentlemen,
there's no evidence that the earth is flat.
But you know what?
There is evidence is there's pure,
there's evidence all over the place that NASA is posting Cgi pictures of it.
[inaudible] come on.
[inaudible]
came to Thrones is on tonight
is round.
No,
no,
I'm not done.
I'm talking about that.
But NASA Sherlyn they have a snapchat account and uh,
just like girls,
Joe Rogan's flat earth tonight,
please don't you just hook them up.
You don't look,
that guy never said the earth is flat.
It's not flat.
If people are mad at me for saying it's not flat,
really.
Bj Penn apparently thinks the earth is flat.
Oh,
TNC.
Tila Tequila retweeted her the other day,
thinks the earth is flat.
She's so spoiled.
I love Tila.
Fuck man.
She was like a fun gap.
A lot of people think it is flat.
Hey listen,
I don't know what you're feeling.
You can't be my friend and do you believe we went to the moon?
Do you believe we went to the [inaudible]?
Of course you do.
Do you believe we went to the moon six times and back?
He goes,
of course we did.
You don't know.
You're on the fence.
He's from Ohio.
You don't know for sure.
We went in for sure.
We for sure went to the moon was on the stage.
I am not going to debate it.
I just want to know what you guys got your research.
Listen man,
he's,
here's 100 that shit I don't believe for one motherfucking second we went to the
fucking moon.
Six God damn times and back and we can't do it now.
We can't do it.
We can do it now.
Says we can do.
We got to figure out how to get through the van.
Allen radiation now.
That's what they said.
They're on record.
There's videos of it.
They're on record saying that now they're going to get two videos.
Brian,
we're going to get to the moon.
As soon as I talked to her house around three things,
three things.
They've got to figure it out.
They've already said it.
They were already admitted.
They've got to figure out how to get to the van.
Allen radiation belts.
They admitted that once they figured that out,
then they can have a man mission to them.
Like,
wait a minute.
Do we go six times and conditions change conditions.
Okay,
beautiful,
beautiful.
And then the next,
the next thing they said,
they got to figure out the right uniform took to handle that kind of radiation.
They haven't figured out the right space soon.
Right back today,
because I never said that from Brendan
[inaudible]
in this room.
I love everybody in this room.
Please say goodnight.
We're wrapping this bitch up.
Congratulations so smoothly.
Unlike every other government agency,
you guys got this shit down.
You'll figure it out.
We had manipulated media.
You figured out a way how to create Jim Morrison,
who's obviously one of the greatest musicians of all time.
He's done an amazing job and congratulations on tower seven
fell like butter.
You guys are wizards.
That's not odd,
motherfucker.
There's a way.
There's a way and whatever,
whatever way that is,
you guys,
you got it.
I'll do all that shit.
I was in the speed metal.